SENATE FLOOR WE DO HAVE A BUSY
DAY AND WE'D LIKE TO GET
STARTED.
THE SENATE WILL
CONVENE IN THIRTY SECONDS.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS
BATES WELL GORGEOUS BRADFORD BY
ADAM CHIANG DALLY DODD THE
BROWSER GALGIANI GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG HILL
HUESO- TADO JACKSON JONES LEYVA
MCGUIRE MELINDA'S MITCHELL
MONNING MORE LOCK MIRO. NIELSEN
PAN PORTANTINO RALPH RUBIO
INNER STERN AMBERG BY CASKEY
WIENER. A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS
BE ON THE REAL IN IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE LET
IN PER THIS MORNING BUT
SENATORS AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAINS WOULD BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE FLAG
CENTER THE LETTER CENTER. IN
THE ABSENCE OF SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN. WHO WI SO SORELY MISS.
BUT ME REPEAT. CHAU CENTER
OURSELVES IN GOD'S PRESENCE AND
CONSIDER THE BLESSINGS OF OUR
HUMANNESS AS WE PONDER ROOMIES
POEM THE GUEST HOUSE. THIS
BEING IN AS A GUEST HOUSE.
EVERY MORNING A NEW ARRIVAL. A
JOY A DEPRESSION A MEANNESS
SOME MOMENTARY AWARENESS COMES
IS AN UNEXPECTED VISITOR.
WELCOME AND ENTERTAIN THEM ALL.
EVEN IF THEY'RE A CROWD OF
SORROWS WHO VIOLENTLY SWEEP
YOUR HOUSE EMPTY OF ITS
FURNITURE STILL TREAT EACH
GUEST HONORABLY. THEY MAY BE
CLEARING YOU OUT FOR SOME NEW
DELIGHT. THE NEGATIVE. THE
SHAME THE MALICE. MEET THEM AT
THE DOOR LAUGHING AND INVITE
THEM IN. BE GRATEFUL FOR
WHATEVER COMES BECAUSE EACH HAS
BEEN SENT THE GUIDE FROM BEYOND.
LOVING GOD HELP US TO BE ALERT
FOR THOSE UNCOMFORTABLE
VISITORS WHICH CALL US TO RE
ASSESS ALL THAT WE THOUGHT WE
KNEW. MAY THEIR PRESENCE AND
THEIR APPEARANCE. NOT CAUSE US
TO LOSE OUR COMPOSURE. AND OUR
GRACIOUS DESIRE. TO BRING TRUTH
JUSTICE AND LOVE TO THOSE WE
SERVE I'M. JOIN OUR FLAG HE
SERVED AS. FIVE MILLION. THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. ZERO
YEAH ONE. IT IS A LITTLE YEAH
FOR ALL. MEMBERS THERE ARE NO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR AND AS
WE BEGIN I WILL LET YOU KNOW
THAT WE HAVE TWENTY FIVE MAJORS
BEFORE US TODAY HE- PRODUCTIVE
YESTERDAY LET'S HAVE A
PRODUCTIVE DAY AS WELL I'LL
TODAY. THE GOVERNOR WILL BE
DEEMED READ. MISTER IS FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MOTIONS SOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE TWENTY NINE TEN THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE ITEM ONE AB
EIGHT FORTY SIX ITEM TWO AB
TWELVE EIGHTY. WE WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR JUNE TWENTY SECOND TO JUNE
TWENTY SIX TWENTY TWENTY WILL
BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. WE ARE MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WILL START WITH SECOND READING
READING MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT FORTY
SIX TWELVE EIGHTY ONE. FIFTY
SIXTEEN FIFTY TWO AND ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN FORTY. SECOND
READING FILE WILL BE DEEMED
READ MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING
TO THE THIRD READING FILE WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
TWENTY FOUR SENATOR BATES ARE
YOU READY. YES. IN THE- PASS
TEMPORARILY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PASS TEMPORARILY REMOVED TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX SENATOR
ALLEN NOT AT HIS DESK ALRIGHT
MEMBERS- WE'RE NOW GOING TO.
ITEM FOR THREE A LITTLE OUT OF
ORDER TO SENATOR MINING CENTER
MORNING ARE YOU PREPARED. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL NINE SEVENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR MINING AN ACT RELATED
TO HEALTH FACILITIES SENATOR
MONNING. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE THE OP APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL NINE SEVEN SEVEN.
MEMBERS THIS IS A BILL DESIGNED
TO PROTECT PATIENTS OUR
CONSTITUENTS THIS YEAR A COVER
CALIFORNIA BRONZE PLAN FOR A
FORTY YEAR OLD COST FOUR
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FOUR DOLLARS IN EUREKA. FOUR
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS
IN SACRAMENTO. AND IN LOS
ANGELES. THREE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN DOLLARS
THIS BILL AIMS TO ADDRESS THAT
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED DOLLAR
DIFFERENCE IN PRICES BETWEEN
REGIONS WHY ARE THESE
DIFFERENCES LET ME EXPLAIN FOR
TOO LONG STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT HOSPITAL CONSOLIDATIONS
RESULT IN INCREASED PREMIUMS
FOR CALIFORNIANS AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAS NOT ADDRESS THE
ISSUE. THE EVIDENCE IS CLEAR AS
REPORTED BY THE LA TIMES THE
NEW YORK TIMES AND IT'S
PRESENTED IN ACADEMIC JOURNALS
WE KNOW THE PROBLEM EXISTS.
THIS ARE. SERVICES ARE GOING
DOWN EXISTING LAW PROVIDES A
LITTLE OVERSIGHT OF HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM CONSOLIDATION AND MARKET
PRACTICES LEFT UNCHECKED
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS WILL
CONTINUE TO GROW AND UTILIZE
ABUSE OF MARKET PRACTICES THAT
DRIVE UP PRICES AND REDUCE
ACCESS FOR CONSUMERS. SENATE
BILL NINE SEVEN SEVEN WOULD
REQUIRE LARGE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEMS AS WELL AS PRIVATE
EQUITY GROUPS IN HEDGE FUNDS TO
OBTAIN APPROVAL FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BEFORE AN
AFFILIATION OR ACQUISITION WITH
ANY OTHER HEALTH CARE FACILITY
OR PROVIDER. THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WOULD EVALUATE THE
PROPOSED TRANSACTION BASED ON
TWO FACTORS WHETHER THE
TRANSACTION WILL INCREASE CARE
COORDINATION OR INCREASE
AFFORDABILITY OF CARE TO AN
UNDERSERVED POPULATION. AND
SECOND WHETHER THE TRANSACTION
IS SUBSTANTIALLY LIKELY TO
RESULT IN ANTI COMPETITIVE
EFFECTS OUTWEIGH ANY BENEFITS.
IF THE ACQUISITION OR
AFFILIATION DOES NOT MEET THESE
REQUIREMENTS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL MADE THE NIGHT THE
TRANSACTION WERE PROPOSED TERMS
OR CONDITIONS TO THE DEAL.
SENATE BILL NINE SEVEN SEVEN
DOES NOT SEEK TO DENY OR BLOCK
TRANSACTIONS IT IS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT PATIENTS AND CONSUMERS
OUR CONSTITUENTS. THIS BILL
INSURERS OF HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
GROWS IT MUST INCREASE IT
SERVICES NOT JUST ITS PROFITS.
IF GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY I'M
COMMITTED TO AMEND THE BILL TO
CLARIFY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
REVIEW PROCESS AND TO ENSURE
THE CREATION OF A ROBUST
ADMINISTRATIVE RECORD. I WILL
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM TO MEAN
ENTITIES ARE SYSTEMS THAT
INCLUDES THREE OR MORE
HOSPITALS OF WHICH AT LEAST ONE
IS A GENERAL ACUTE CARE
HOSPITAL. THIS WILL BE THE
FOCUS OF REVIEW. ADDITIONALLY
SB NINE SEVEN SEVEN WOULD
DECLARE THAT HEALTH CARE
SYSTEMS THE EXERCISE
SUBSTANTIAL MARKET POWER MAY
NOT ENGAGE IN BEHAVIOR THAT HAS
A SIGNIFICANT LIKELIHOOD OF
ANTI COMPETITIVE PRACTICES. E.
G. RAISING PRICES BECAUSE
THERE'S NO COMPETITION. AND I
COMPETITIVE BEHAVIORS ARE
DESIGNED TO INCLUDE INCREASING
MARKET PRICES DIMINISHING
QUALITY REDUCING CHOICE
INCREASING THE TOTAL COST OF
CARE. IN DIMINISHING ACCESS FOR
AVAILABILITY OF HOSPITAL OR NON
HOSPITAL HEALTH CARE SERVICES
FINALLY SB NINE SEVEN SEVEN
ESTABLISHES A HEALTH POLICY
ADVISORY BOARD. THE BOARD WOULD
BE MADE UP. A BROAD CROSS
SECTION OF STAKEHOLDERS WOULD
ADVISE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
PROPOSED CONSOLIDATION
TRANSACTION IN BASED ON
AMENDMENTS THAT CAME OUT OF
APPROPRIATIONS THOSE WHO
MEMBERS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
REPORT ANY POTENTIAL CONFLICT
OF INTEREST IN FINAL FORM SEVEN
HUNDRED IN THE ONLY. AS THE
WORLD RESPONDS TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN CRISIS ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE IS MORE
CRITICAL THAN EVER BEFORE. BUT
AT THE SAME TIME COVERT
NINETEEN HAS CREATED ENORMOUS
FINANCIAL STRAIN ON BOTH
HOSPITALS AND PHYSICIANS MAKING
THESE PROVIDERS SUSCEPTIBLE TO
CONSOLIDATION EFFORTS BY LARGE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS IN PRIVATE
EQUITY FIRMS THAT DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE ANY PRACTICE
IN THE PROVISION MEDICAL CARE.
IT'S SECOND I'M A CRISIS THAT
CREATES AN IMMEDIATE NECESSITY
TO GIVE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
THE SAME AUTHORITY OVER PRIVATE
TRANSACTIONS CITY CURRENTLY HAS
OVER A TRANSACTION INVOLVING A
NONPROFIT ENTITY. SO IN ESSENCE
THIS BILL SEEKS PARITY THAT THE
SCRUTINY WE ALREADY APPLY TO
NON PROFIT WE SHOULD ALSO APPLY
THAT SCRUTINY TO FOR PROFIT
TRANSACTIONS. FOR THE PURPOSE
OF PROTECTING PATIENTS OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN A MARKET PLACE
THAT WE DON'T SEEK TO STIFLE.
WE SEEK TO REVIEW AND PROTECT.
THE GOAL OF PATIENT ACCESS
PATIENT CARE. AND BLOCKING ANTI
COMPETITIVE PRICING MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER MONNING
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SENATOR BORCHERS. THE
MAN PRESIDENT PHILOSOPHICALLY I
WOULD NORMALLY BE INCLINED TO
PROMOTE- COMPETITION AND BE
CONCERNED ABOUT ANTI TRUST
DEVELOPMENTS- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT HERE
IS THAT DURING THE PANDEMIC- WE
NOT CREATE A SITUATION WHERE WE
ARE CREATING MORE OBSTACLES- IN
THE WAKE OF. THE NEED FOR- MORE
MEDICAL SERVICES IN PARTICULAR
I THINK ONE THE COMMENTS THAT
THE AUTHOR MENTION IS THAT THE
NONPROFIT IS SOLD AT A CERTAIN
LEVEL OF SCRUTINY THAT WOULD
THEN BE APPLIED TO A PRIVATE
ENTITY. THAT I THINK COULD BE
PROBLEMATIC- BECAUSE ONE YOU
HAVE THE FREEDOM OF CONTRACT
AND THE FREEDOM TO ENGAGE WITH
ENTITIES WHETHER BEING A PROFIT
SETTING- OR SOME OTHER FIVE
COMMERCIAL ENTERPRISE SO
CONCERNS ME THAT WE'RE TAKING
THE PUBLIC SCRUTINY. THAT WOULD
NORMALLY BE RESERVED FOR
ENTITIES THAT RECEIVE A TAX
BENEFIT AND THE NONPROFIT
RECEIVED BENEFITS BY VIRTUE OF
CLASSIFICATION INTO A PRIVATE
SITUATION THAT TYPICALLY
DOESN'T. SO IN A COLD SITUATION
MY CONCERN IS THAT DELAYING
THROUGH IN AG REVIEW PROCESS.
IN AFFILIATION WHEREBY A
LARGER- MEDICAL AND EIGHTEEN
COULDN'T USE CASH INTO A SMALL
FOR MEDICAL FACILITY AT THE
MOMENT OF DESPERATION
ESPECIALLY AS WE- THE EXISTING
RIGHT NOW I THINK IT COULD
HAVE. SOME WILDLY INTENDED
CONSEQUENCES EVEN THOUGH I
BELIEVE THE PART OF THE BILL IS
TO PROMOTE GREATER ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE BUT IN A CULVERT
SCENARIO I THINK CREATING THAT
BUREAUCRATIC IN ADMINISTRATIVE.
THE WORK THAT OFFICE IN MAYBE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS SHOULD BE
BROUGHT BACK ONCE OUR FINANCES
AND OR PUBLIC SAFETY MEASURES-
AND SITUATION HAVE IMPROVED
SIGNIFICANTLY AFTER THE
PANDEMIC IS ADDRESSED AND
RESOLVED HOPEFULLY. THANK YOU
CENTER BORDERS SENATOR ALAN.
LET ME START BY COMMENDING THE
AUTHOR FOR YOU KNOW GETTING
INTO A AN IMPORTANT AND
DIFFICULT ISSUE INVOLVING. THE
CONSOLIDATION OF OUR HEALTH
CARE INDUSTRY AND THE EXTENT T
WHICH- YOU NOW HAVE DIFFERENT
ENTITIES ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
STEPPING IN I'VE HAS FUNDS IN
THE REST. AND ENGAGING IN
TAKING OVER MANY ASPECTS OF OUR
OF OUR HEALTH CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SO- I AM-
I'VE HAD SOME VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE- CENTER MINING IN THE
IN THE IN THE RUN UP TO THIS
BILL OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A
CONCERN OUT THERE. I THINK THAT
THE WE'VE TALKED ABOUT NEARING
THE PARAMETERS OF THE TYPES OF
ENTITIES THAT WOULD BE COVERED
UNDER THIS BECAUSE WE REALLY DO
WANT TO FOCUS ON THE TYPES OF-
OF GREGIS IN AND KIND AND
MONOPOLY. BEHAVIOR THAT AT
LEAST IS AT THE HEART OF THE
TALKING POINTS THAT THAT- I'VE
HEARD FROM ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
THE SENATOR- WE TALKED ABOUT
MORE FLEXIBILITY FOR VISIT
PHYSICIAN PRACTICE GROUPS- DINO
THAT CONTINUES TO BE A CONCERN
FROM OUR FRIENDS. IN THE CMA.
THEY OF COURSE ARE ARE VERY
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PLAYERS IN
THIS WHOLE CONVERSATION- AND
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE GIVEN THE CORPORATE BAR-
WE TALKED ABOUT MORE
FLEXIBILITY ON THE DENY
LANGUAGE TO GET MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL- AS OPPOSED TO RIGHT
NOW WHERE HE'S AT LEAST
ACCORDING TO THE WAY THE LAWS
WRITTEN IN SECTION REQUIRES THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO NOT- THE
AND- ON AFFILIATION IF ONE OR
TWO FACTORS ARE. ARE ARE MATT
AND THERE OUGHT TO BE MORE
FLEXIBILITY GIVEN. HOW RIGID IT
IS RIGHT NOW WE TALK ABOUT MORE
MORE DUE PROCESS AS YOU SPOKE
ABOUT UPPINGTHE- FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND- THRESHOLD PERHAPS SO
AS TO. MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
REALLY FOCSED ON ON- ON ON ON
THE BIG ACQUISITIONS AT THAT
ARE OF CONCERN AND THEN ALSO
LOOKING AT THE ACADEMIC
INSTITUTION. DEFINITION THAT
WAS PUT IN IN APPROPRIATIONS
SO. WITH THOSE WITH THAT
CONVERSATION I I'D CERTAINLY
FEEL CONFIDENT. THAT THE AUTHOR
IS A IS COMMITTED TO REALLY
FOCUSING THIS BILL ON. THE P.
TALKED ABOUT WHICH IS. MAKING
SURE THAT THERE'S SOME
OVERSIGHT- OVER- BIG PLAYERS
OFTENTIMES OUT OF STATE COMING
FROM WALL STREET THAT ARE
COMING IN AND TRYING TO.
MANIPULATE OUR HEALTH CARE
MARKET- WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
PROTECTIONS AGAINST THAT. AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT THE AUTHOR
SEEKING TO- TO ACCOMPLISH HERE
SO I'M CERTAINLY PREPARED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL WITH THOSE
UNDERSTANDINGS MOVING FORWARD-
TODAY. THANK YOU THINK CENTER
ALLEN SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS- I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SEVEN SEVEN. I KNOW THAT IT'S-
IT'S BEEN REYES. IS THIS THE
TIME TO DO IT NOW ACTUALLY- AS
YOUR CHAIR OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE ACTUALLY FELT THAT
THIS IS THE TIME TO DO IT. OUR
HOSPITALS AND PHYSICIAN
PRACTICES ARE- SUFFERING
ECONOMICALLY. AND WHAT WE DON'T
WANT TO HAVE HAPPEN IS- SOMEONE
WHO DOES HAVE CASH ON HAND- TO
GO AND SEE THIS IS AN ARBITRAGE
OPPORTUNITY TO THEN BUY UP
HOSPITALS AND PRACTICES. OF FOR
THE PURPOSE OF LATER ON HAVING
MARKET LEVERAGE. YEAH IN THEIR
MARKETS AND THAT WILL NOT
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OUTCOMES ARE
IMPROVE ACCESS BUT- SOLELY TO
RAISE PRICES. AND THAT IS A
THINK WHEN THE ISSUES AND IT'S
A COMPLEX ISSUE. THAT THIS BILL
IS SEEKING TO ADDRESS AND WHY I
THINK THIS BILL IS SO TIMELY.
THE TRIGGER FOR THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY ONE THE- ONE PARTY IS
ACTUALLY A VERY AS A LARGE
HEALTH SYSTEM AND I APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR MAKING A COMMITMENT
TO CLARIFYING DATS AND ENSURING
THAT ONLY THE LARGEST SYSTEMS
WOULD BE INVOLVED IN TRIGGERING
BUT THINK ABOUT IT. SO WHAT
DOCTOR HAS SAID IS THAT YOU
ALREADY HAVE TO BE A THREE
HOSPITAL'S MAIN TO START WITH
SO IF YOU'RE A TO HOSPITAL
CHAIN ABOUT THIRD ONE THIS
WOULD NOT TRIGGER ANYTHING
YOU'RE READY THREE HOSPITALS SO
YOU LOOK AROUND IN YOUR OWN
DISTRICTS AND THINK ME
HOUSEHOLD YOU HAVE AND SOMEONE
ACTUALLY CONTROL READ OF THOSE
HOSPITALS. WHAT KIND OF MARKET
SIZE TODAY REPRESENT YOUR
COMMUNITY AT THAT POINT IN TIME
AND THEN- SEEKING TO PERHAPS
PURCHASE A FOURTH. OR TAKE OUR
OUR CONTROL. A YOU KNOW A LARA
AND MEDICAL GROUP OR SOMETHING
IN IN THAT AREA AND SO WHEN
THEY HAVE THEIR CONVERSATION
WITH THE HEALTH PLANS ARE OTHER
OF ENTITIES. THE AMOUNT OF
LEVERAGE THAT THEY HAVE IN THAT
CONVERSATION NOW. THEY SAID
THERE'S A TENSION BETWEEN
CONSOLIDATION WHICH CAN DRIVE
UP PRICES AND ALSO- CAN
COOPERATION TO TRY TO IMPROVE
QUALITY SO WHAT THIS BILL
DOESN'T DO IT DOESN'T SAY YOU
CAN'T ACTUALLY BUY THAT FOURTH
HOSPITAL AFFILIATE WITH THAT
MEDICAL PRACTICE BY THAT'S-
INVENTORY SURGERY CENTER. IT
SAYS IS THAT WHEN YOU HIT THAT
SIZE. WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
OVERSIGHT OVER THAT. THE AG'S
GONNA HAVE OVERSIGHT AND
LOOKING AT THAT AND ANOTHER
THING I DO WANNA SAY IN.
PERHAPS THE AUTHOR CAN ALSO
CLARIFY THIS IS THAT. YES WE DO
IN CURRENT EXISTING LAW HAVE
REVIEW WHEN NOT FOR PROFITS AND
THATIS BASED IS I THINK WAS
BUSY MENTION. ON A REVIEW-
BASED ON COMMUNITY BENEFIT
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT FOR
PROFIT. VIEW THAT ASKED IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILLS ACTUALLY
NARROWER THAN THAT SO IT'S NOT
SO BROAD THAT- WELL IF YOU
DON'T FEEL COMMUNITY WHAT WOULD
YOU DO HAVE TO THE NEW IS
THOUGH IS SHOW THAT SHE OF
BENEFIT TO THE PATIENTS ARE
TAKING CARE OF. SO I KNOW SOME
PEOPLE HAVE RAISED SOME
CONCERNS I'VE HEARD SAID WELL
YOU KNOW THE- AG'S REVIEW OF
NOT FOR PROFIT SEEMS TO BE A
LITTLE. YOU KNOW EXTENSIVE AND
SOMETIMES THEY DEMANDED CERTAIN
THINGS- FOR COMMUNITIES. IN
FACT IN THIS BILL. THE HEALTH
SYSTEM THE LARGE HEALTH SYSTEM.
BY THE WAY SO THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES THE SHOW THIS STATE.
THERE THAT DAY. THAT THEY HAVE
TO SHOW THAT THERE'S ACTUALLY A
PATIENT BENEFIT TO THIS MERGER
AND THAT'S BEYOND. THE MARKET
RISK OF ALLOWING THIS
CONSOLIDATION SO WE'RE TRYING
TO STRIKE THIS BALANCE. NOT TO
SAY THAT. YOU CAN'T TO BY OUR
AFFILIATE WITH SOMEONE IF
YOU'RE READY A BIG SYSTEM.
WE'RE SAYING IS THAT THERE
SHOULD BE OVERSIGHT AND IF YOU
CAN DEMONSTRATE THAT THERE'S
ACTUALLY IMPROVEMENT IN QUALITY.
IT CAN BE PROVEN IN CARE THEN
WE'LL LET THIS GO FOR BUT YOU
CAN'T DEMONSTRATE THAT AND ALL
WE SEE IS THAT YOU GOT THE
PRICES ARE GOING TO GO UP. THEN
PERHAPS WE SHOULD LET THAT
HAPPEN AND I THINK THAT'S A
VERY FAIR BALANCE I APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR CONSUMING TO DO THE
WORK- AND I'M SURE AND ASSEMBLY
ETCETERA. RIGHT I DO HOPE THAT
YOU WILL VOTE THIS BILL SO THIS
CONVERSATION CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD AND WE CAN HAVE A
TIMELESS SOLUTION TO THIS- SO
THAT WE DON'T FIND OURSELVES
NAY. WE'RE WE'RE HAVE LARGE.
RIGHT CORNERED THE MARKET AND
IT'S REALLY HARD TO UNWIND OF
THOSE INSTEAD OF TRYING TO ACT
PRO ACTIVELY TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE I OR DENIED IT THANK YOU
CENTER PAN SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
MONNING PLEASE CLOSE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS THE
QUESTIONS LET ME JUST ADDRESS A
COUPLE ONE COMMENT TO COME WITH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO WAS
MAYBE COVERT NINETEENTH NOT THE
TIME WE SHOULD BE DOING THIS
BECAUSE THE ECONOMY IS STRESS.
I WOULD COUNTER IT'S EXACTLY
THE TIME WE NEED TO DO IT ALSO
COMMENTED ON BY OUR SHARE OF
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE. BECAUSE
WE SEE THE MOVE OF THOSE WITH
RESOURCES TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THOSE WHO ARE IN DISTRESS. WE
KNOW THAT FROM TAX ONE HOSPITAL
SYSTEM RECEIVED THREE HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. AND
HAS FURLOUGHED TEN THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES. I WON'T TELL YOU
WITH THAT EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION PACKAGES THAT'S A
FOR PROFIT NETWORK WE REGULATE
THE PROFIT MARKET MARKET PLACE
GOVERNMENT THAT IS OUR ROLE WE
REGULATE HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
THERE ARE PRIVATE SECTOR BUT WE
REGULATE THEM TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC INTEREST THIS BILL SEEKS
TO APPLY THE SAME REVIEW. TO
THE PRIVATE SECTOR TRANSACTIONS
THAT WE CURRENTLY DO IN THE IN
THE NONPROFIT SECTOR. THE BILL
PROVIDES A WAIVER FOR CERTAIN
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND I KNOW IN
WORKING WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. HIS GOAL IS TO PROTECT
OUR CONSTITUENTS THAT'S HIS
SWORN DUTY IT'S ARE SWORN DUTY
HE DOESN'T HAVE A MINDSET VYING
IN A BLOCK. AN ACQUISITION
THAT'S GONNA LEAVE THE
COMMUNITY WITHOUT ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE. IN MY OWN DISTRICT
I'VE SEEN BOTH I'VE SEEN IN
ATTORNEY GENERAL IMPROVE THE
PROSPECTS FOR AN ACQUISITION OF
A HOSPITAL IN DISTRESS PART OF
A STATEWIDE NONPROFIT SYSTEM IN
THE AREA OF GILROY IN MORGAN
HILL- BOTH ATTORNEY GENERAL
COMMA HARRIS AND ATTORNEY
GENERAL. REVIEWED BLOCKS ONE
ACT WAS BLOCK AT THE TO GET THE
PROSPECTIVE BUYER TO COMMIT TO
MAINTAINING CERTAIN SERVICES
THE BUYER WASN'T WILLING TO DO
THAT NOW IT'S OPERATING UNDER
THE AUSPICES OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY ON TO THE BENEFIT OF
ALL. IN WATSONVILLE. ONE OF THE
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
IN MY DISTRICT AVERAGE FAMILY
INCOME NOT INDIVIDUAL FAMILY
INCOME EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS ER FAMILY.
PREDOMINATELY FARMWORKER
COMMUNITY THAT FOR PROFIT
HOSPITAL WITH AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT ACQUIRED BY AN OUT
OF STATE HEDGE FUND WITH ONE
DOCTOR IN THAT PARTNERSHIP NO
HISTORY RUNNING A HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. AND THEY SOUGHT TO HAVE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL REVIEWS AT
TO JUST TRY TO PROTECT EXISTING
SERVICES THE GENERAL SAID. I
DON'T HAVE JURISDICTION. SO
WE'RE NOT SEEKING TO BLOCK TO
IMPEDE OR STOP THE DELIVERY OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES WE DO WANT
TO PROVIDE A REVIEW. MECHANISM
AS THE DOCTOR FROM SACRAMENTO
POINTED OUT I'VE MADE
COMMITMENTS TO ONE THE FOUR S.
SHOULD I HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TAKE THIS YES. TO CONTINUE
WORK ON THE NARROWING OF SCOPE.
AND THE PROTECTIONS OF BALANCE
FOR PHYSICIANS FOR SMALL GROUPS
ETCETERA I MAKE THAT COMMITMENT
TO ALL OF YOU HERE ON THE FLOOR
TODAY. THE WAY OUR SYSTEM WORKS
TO FIND GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MOVE THIS TO THE ASSEMBLY.
TO WORK WITH THE ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE. IN A FIVE
BRING. EVERYONE CAN SEE FIVE
MAINTAIN THOSE COMMITMENTS FIVE
ACHIEVE THOSE COMMITMENTS IN IF
NOT. VOTE ME DOWN BUT I ASKED
TODAY FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY I DO
WANT TO THANK TOM THE GOOD
DOCTOR FROM SACRAMENTO WHO IS
CHAIR OF HEALTH. PUT SOME
AMENDMENTS IN THE BILL TO
CREATE SOME FURTHER METRICS
ESTABLISH NATIONAL NET METRICS
TO MEASURE HEALTH OUTCOMES TO
MEASURE INPUTS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT. PUBLIC IN COMMUNITY
HEALTH THE STRENGTH IN THE BILL.
I WANT TO THANK THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM LOCKING YADA WHO
ALSO- STRENGTH IN THE BILL WAS
SOME. INPUTS FOR THE-
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE ADVISORY
BOARD THAT'S CONTEMPLATED. TO
BE SUBJECT TO CONFLICT OF
INTEREST LAWS IT CETERA- MOM
AND I WANT TO THINK THE OTHERS
TO THEM ENGAGED WITH THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM SANTA MONICA. THE
GOOD SENATOR TOM FROM
HEALDSBURG WHO HAVE ENGAGE WITH
KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT THE BILL
CURRENTLY DOES IN WITH IMPORTS
OF WHERE WE WANT IT TO GO AS WE
MOVE FORWARD FRIENDS. THE TIME
IS NOW. THE CONSOLIDATIONS ARE
HAPPENING THE ACQUISITIONS ARE
HAPPENING. WE ARE SENT HERE BY
OUR CONSTITUENTS THE PATIENTS
IN THE CONSUMERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE TO PROTECT OUR
CONSTITUENTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER MONNING BANG
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES. BELL HI GORGEOUS. NO
BRADFORD. CABALLERO I CHIANG.
NO DALLY NO DODD. THE RISING HI
GALGIANI. GLAZER NO GONZALEZ I
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. HI HILL.
HUESO I TADO. JACKSON I JONES
NO LEYVA HI MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ
NO MITCHELL I MONNING I WARLOCK
NO MORALE NO NIELSEN NO HAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO.
SKINNER I STERN. NUMBER WHY
CASKEY AYE WIENER. FIVE WILK
NOW PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS BATES. BRADFORD
DODD. GALGIANI HELLO TADO.
MCGUIRE RUBIO. STERN I'M BURKE.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
WERE MOVING BACK TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX SENATOR ALAN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TEN FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR
ALLEN AND AFTER LEADING TO FIRE
PROTECTION SENATOR ALLEN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS- SB
TEN FORTY FOUR PROHIBITS THE
MANUFACTURE SALE AND USE OF
CERTAIN FIREFIGHTING PHONE THAT
CONTAINS THE CHEMICALS PER AND
POLY FOR FLOOR ALKYL SUBSTANCES
WHICH ARE KNOWN AS P. FIVE. P.
FIVE OUR KEPT THAT BUILD UP IN
OUR BODIES IN ARLINGTON
NUMEROUS HEALTH PROBLEMS
INCLUDING CANCER. AND DAMAGE TO
THE KIDNEYS AND LIVER. BUT VICE
IS ESPECIALLY HARMFUL TO
INFANTS AND CHILDREN CAN COST
LAD LASTING DAMAGE- INTO
ADULTHOOD- AND THERE'S
PARTICULAR CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH P. FIVE. NOW
WITH REGARDS TO PREGNANT WOMEN
AND FETUSES AND THERE'S A THAT
POWERFUL DOCUMENTARY ON NETFLIX
ABOUT THIS CALL THE WELL WE
KNOW THAT I RECOMMEND FOLKS
CHECK OUT. ABOUT HALF IN OUR
PEARL BLATCHINGTON MUNITY
DOWNSTREAM FROM DUPONT PLANT.
FORTY FIVE INTO THE WATER I
THESE DANGEROUS CHEMICALS ARE
ALSO CONTAMINATED DRINKING
WATER ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
I'VE THEY HAVE A PROJECTED COST
TO WATER UTILITIES NOW OF
TWELVE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT DECADE.
SO THEY CAN LAYS A GENTLEMAN
THIS IS BECOMING AN ENORMOUS
LIABILITY FOR THE WATER
DISTRICTS THAT PROVIDE DRINKING
WATER TO OUR CONSTITUENTS- AND
NOW THE ESTIMATES ARE THAT IN
CALIFORNIA THE WATER SUPPLIES
FOR AT LEAST SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE- OF FIGHTS IN
THEIR WATER. NOW ONE OF THE
PRIME DESERVE CONTAMINATION
PARTICULAR FOR A WATER SUPPLY.
IS FIRE FIGHTING FOAMS USED TO
FIGHT LIQUID FIRES. AND WE KNOW
THE FIREFIGHTERS ARE ALREADY AT
AN INCREASED RISK OF DEVELOPING
HEALTH PROBLEMS ELEVATED RISK
OF DEFIES CHEMICALS HAVE BEEN
DOCUMENTED IN THE BODIES OF
FIREFIGHTERS PUTTING THEM AT
EVEN GREATER RISK OF HARM.
INCLUDE CANCER. THANKFULLY THE
USE OF P. FOSSEN FIREFIGHTING
PHONE IS NOT NECESSARY
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE
ALTERNATIVES ARE EFFECTIVE COST
SAVING INTERN GLOBALLY. I YOU
CAN S. TRILLION AND IS NOT
STATE THAT HAVE TAKEN TO
PHASING OUT P. FILES- AND- THIS
BILL TAKES THE LONG OVERDUE
STEP OF BANNING THE USE OF
FIREFIGHTING FOAM CONTAINING P.
FIVE EXCEPT THE TUITIONS WHERE
IT IS FEDERALLY REQUIRED. FOR
IT. I TO. YOU CAN WITH THE BILL
THE PUSH THE DATE OUT TO TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR FOR LARGE STORAGE
TANK FIRES A CHEMICAL PLANTS.
FUEL STORAGE AND DISTRIBUTION
FACILITIES AND OIL REFINERIES
AND WE DO- REMAINING VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION WITH
FOLKS ON THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE FOLKS AT THEIR
REFINERIES HAVE THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO FIGHT FIRES WHILE ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE- FALLS.
OF NOT HAVING MORE V. FIVES-
CONTAMINATING OUR GROUNDWATER.
HI THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE IT'S SUPPORTED BY OUR
WATER AGENCIES BECAUSE GIVEN
THE CONTAMINATION LEVELS. IN
OUR DRINKING WATER THE LEAST WE
CAN DO TO STOP MAKING THE
PROBLEM WORSE. AND OF COURSE I
WILL SAY THAT OUR FIREFIGHTERS
ARE PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS BILL
AND LET'S LET'S ALL BE STRAIGHT
ABOUT THIS FIREFIGHTERS KNOWS.
ABOUT THE FIRE. AND AS MUCH AS
THEY WOULD LIKE TO PREVENT
THEMSELVES FROM GETTING ANSWER
TO. HER NOW. AT THE CARE MORE
BIG SURE THEY DON'T GET BIRD TO
IMPRESS. BUT ARE THAT'S RIGHT
FRONT OF THEM. AND SO- THEY
TOOK A WHILE THE THIS THE LAST
SEVERAL. BEEN WORKING WITH THEM
ALL SEVERAL YEARS. ALL RIGHT
YOU MIGHT TERM. AND I THEY'VE
COME TO UP WHERE THEY HAVE HAVE
FEEL COMFORTABLE. THAT THE
ALTERNATIVES ARE THERE THAT THE
DANGERS ARE SIDES- AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE THERE. SO
THAT THEY CAN DO THEIR JOB IN
FIGHTING OUR FIRES IN KEEPING
US SAFE WHILE ALSO KEEPING
THEIR BODY SAFE. ON THE SHORT
TERM. AND THE LONG TERM. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU
CENTER ALLEN MEMBERS DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE SENATOR DOLLY. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I HAVE THE
PLEASURE TO SIT ON EQ WITH THE
CHAIRMAN HERE WHO'S WHO HAS
THIS BILL AND I LAID OFF THE
BILL IN BECAUSE THERE WAS A FEW.
FOLKS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
SOME AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW THEM
TO PHASE OUT INTO IN TIME
VETERAN AND WHERE WE DON'T
HAVE. THAT WHAT WE'RE WAS
MAINLY FOR. THE HIGH
CONCENTRATIONS OF REALLY HIGH A
FLAMMABLE LIQUIDS LIKE- IN A
REFINERY AREAS AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE WORKING WITH THEM
AND I APPRECIATE THAT. ACTUALLY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. I
KNOW YOU'RE STILL LOOKING AT
SOME AMENDMENTS FOR THEM YEAH
AND I'M HOPING THAT YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO WORK THAT OUT SO THAT
IT NO CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE. AND THEY HAVE. A BIT
HARD TIME CONTAINING KNOWS A
BUYERS THAT THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO. A LITTLE MORE TIME
OR OR COME UP WITH NEW
TECHNOLOGY TO DO IT SO- REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS I
KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME
COMING AND- IT'S ALL THE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. AND
LOOKING. DOLLY CENTER ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY IN COURT SB. TEN
FORTY FOUR I BELIEVE PHASING
OUT OF A P. A.'S ALSO KNOWN AS
FIFA'S IN OUR FIGHT A FIRE IN
FULL IS A GOOD POLICY. IN FACT
SO THERE'S UNITED STATES
MILITARY THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE HAS ALSO BEGUN TO PHASE
OUT IF PH IN THE PHONE.
FOLLOWING A SIMILAR TIMELINE AS
LAID OUT ON SB TEN FORTY FOUR.
HOWEVER NO THE INDUCTOR
FIREFIGHTER STILL HAVE SOME
CONCERNS REGARDING THE PHONE.
THAT AND THE PHONES THAT DO NOT
CONTAIN AT PH WORKING AS WELL
AS THE FOR THE F. PH PHONE WHEN
DEALING WITH REFINERY FIRES. SO
I WOULD URGE THE SENATOR FROM
SANTA MONICA TO CONTINUE WITH
THESE STAKEHOLDERS. TOWARDS OF
NARAL WAIVER JEFF THESE
INDUSTRIAL FIREFIGHTERS GET
HAVE PROPER TOOLS AVAILABLE TO
ADDRESS THE REFINERY- WELL
FIRES IN IRAQ LAST RIVAL. HE
SAID. SENATOR BUT- YES I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THE ONE
CONCERN I HAVE BEEN SET AND THE
DATE CENTER FROM. LOS ANGELES
ALSO HAD I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CONNECTED HERE- I
HAVE THREE REFINERIES OF MY
DISTRICT THAT- RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE OF RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOOD. REALLY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF- GROWTH FRANKLY
BUT NEVER THE LESS I WOULD HATE
TO HAVE A BILL PASSED THE-
COULD THE- THEY HAVE A LAST.
MORE DANGER YEAH YEAH YEAH
BLOOD LUST ABILITY TO PUT OUT A
FIRE PUT IT OUT NOW SO THAT- WE
DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT
THE OTHER DAY DANGER TO THE
NEIGHBORS AROUND SO WILL THERE
BE AN EXTENSION GIVEN A MAYBE
I- IT MINISTRY TO DO DOWN THE
LINE IF THEIR TECHNOLOGY THAT-
WILL BE ABLE TO HANDLE THE-
YEAH SO WE'RE WE'RE IN
DISCUSSIONS OF ALONG THE LINES
OF I'M SO SORRY THROUGH THE
CHAIR. START WITH A PLEASE
PROCEED. HI IT'S BASICALLY A
THE LINES WHAT THE SENATOR.
TERMS OF LA COUNTY WAS TALKING
ABOUT WHICH WOULD BE A VERY
NARROW WAIVERS AND THAT THAT
THAT'S THE DESCRIPTION THE IDEA
BEING WE DON'T KNOW IF THERE IF
THERE TRULY IS NO ALTERNATIVE.
I THE TIME THAT THE PHASE OUT
HAPPENS- WE WANT OBVIOUSLY WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT THE
FOLKS TO PUT OUT FIRES A
REFINERS ARE ABLE TO THE OTHER
SIDE. OKAY PERFECT. THANK YOU
CENTER DOT MULLIN. BUT SIR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I THINK THE POINTS
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP ABOUT-
MAKING SURE THAT ALL OF OUR
FIREFIGHTERS HAVE THE TOOLS
THEY NEED TO FIGHT WHATEVER
TYPE OF FIRED IS THEY'RE
TENDING TO HIS VERY. HOWEVER.
IT'S NOT UP OKAY. MAYBE CAN YOU
HEAR ME NOW. THANK YOU. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE DO
ADDRESS THE FACT THAT THEIR-
THERE SOME FIREFIGHTERS OUT
THERE WHO TEND TO CERTAIN TYPES
OF BUYERS THEY HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT THEY
HAVE THAT THEY NEED AND I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE.
HOWEVER EIGHT TRADERS KNOW THE
TOOLS THAT THEY NEED FOR
DONNELLY FOR THE JOB THAT
THEY'RE DOING IT THEY'RE SAYING
THAT THIS TYPE OF TOOL IS
CAUSING THEM HARM THAT I THINK
WE OUGHT TO LISTEN TO THEM- I
HAVE A FIRE FIGHTER IN MY
DISTRICT WHO PASSED AWAY
RECENTLY FROM CANCER AND- YOUR
RECORD BREAKING. NO YOU KNOW
WHAT BUT HE WAS A FIREFIGHTER
BY TRADE SO YOU HAVE TO THINK
THAT IT WAS YOU KNOW SOMETHING
ANY CAME BACK AND CAME BACK HE
BEAT ONCE THEY CAME BACK HE BE
TO BACK ONCE AGAIN ANY CAME
ULTIMATELY SUCCUMB TO CANCER
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE PRETTY
CONVINCED IT WAS JOB. NEEDED SO
I DON'T KNOW HOW I'D STAND
THERE AND SAY WELL DEAN. I KNOW
YOU THINK THAT THIS TOOL IS
WHAT CAUSED IT BUT I'M GOING TO
INSIST THAT YOU KEEP ON USING I
CAN'T DO THAT IN GOOD
CONSCIENCE SO I'M I TRUST YOU
YOU'RE GOING TO WORK WITH
EVERYONE TO TRY TO GET THIS TO
A POINT WHERE I'M EVERYONE IS
SATISFIED EVERYONE FEEL SAFE
AND WANT TO BE WILL HAVE. TO I
KNOW. WITH THAT COMMITMENT FROM
YOU I'M I'M WILLING TO SUPPORT
THE BILL CHAIRMAN I THANK YOU
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR MELINDA'S
SEND CHIANG. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS THE SCIENCE
BEHIND THIS BILL IS SOUND AND I
DON'T THINK ANYONE DISTANT
DISAGREES WITH THAT WE NEED TO
FOLLOW THE SCIENCE ON THESE
KINDS OF PROPOSALS BECAUSE THE
HEALTH AND LIVES OF OUR
FIREFIGHTERS ARE. ARE AT STAKE.
EVER I'M CONCERNED THE BILL IN
ITS CURRENT FORM MAYBE. TOO
RIGID I'M NOT YET CONVINCED
THAT THERE ARE SPECIFIC
INSTANCES WHERE AN ALTERNATIVE
TO BE FAST. IS NOT AVAILABLE OR
SUFFICIENT WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THAT AND I HEARD
THAT YOUWILL BE A CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION SO
I. HOPE YOU CONTINUE TO DO SO.
I SUPPORT WHAT THE BILL IS
TRYING TO DO. BUT IT THE
COMPANIES TO BE TIGHTENED UP
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY AND HOPEFULLY I CAN SEE
SOME AMENDMENT FUTURE. VERY
MUCH. SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSS
OR DEBATE CENTER ALLEN YOU MAY
CLOSE I JUST APPRECIATE THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION I WANT TO
VERTICALLY AND THINK THE CENTER
FROM MICHAEL ARE FOR YOU AT
THAT VERY DIFFICULT CASE OF ONE
OF OUR FIRST RESPONDERS HE'S
OUT THERE PUTTING PUTTING THEIR
LIVES ON THE AND EVERY DAY AND
IT'S NOT JUST SHORT TERM.
FIGHTING THE TEARS IT'S ALSO
THE LONG TERM RISKS THAT
THEY'RE I TAKING ON THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THERE IS A DIRECT
CORRELATION- BETWEEN FIVE AND
CANCER. HI FOLKS THAT HIGH
EXPOSURE. WHENEVER KNOW
PARTICULAR GENOM BUT THE BUT IT
IS IT IS A- POSSIBLE PROBABLE
THAT THAT HE MAY HAVE GOTTEN IT
FROM FROM P. FIVE THIS IS WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT IT'S ABOUT
PROTECTING OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
PROTECT OUR YOU KNOW I. LOOKING
SURE THAT WE DON'T DO ANYTHING
IN THIS BILL THAT WOULD MAKE IT
HARDER TO- ACTIVE TO FIGHT
FIRES REFINERIES THE LAST THING
I WANT IS TO HAVE- TO PUT TO
REST. HI WHO EVEN NEARBY SO
WE'RE GONNA. CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THAT PART OF THE BILL BUT I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THAT THE
SUPPORT. AND THE AND THE
UNDERSTANDING OF CONCERN. ABOUT
HIM THE IMPORT THIS BILL ON
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES I TELL I FORGES
AYE BRADFORD. CABALLERO I
CHIANG HI DOLLY OR AYE DODD. HI
ROSEN I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO I TANTO I
JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA FIVE
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S AYE
MITCHELL. I MONNING FIVE MORE
LOCK MORRELL. I NIELSEN. PAN I
PORTANTINO HI ROSS. I RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER. I STERN. I'M
BURKE HI MY CASKEY AYE WIENER.
WILK HI REMOVE THE CALL MEMBERS
REMOVING THE FILE ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN SENATOR SKINNER ARE YOU
PREPARED SHE IS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL TEN
SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR SKINNER
AND ACTUALLY INTO PRISONS
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU-
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB TEN
SIXTY FOUR WOULD REQUIRE CDC
ARE TO FOLLOW COMPARABLE DUE
PROCESS PROCEDURES. THAT
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES FOR
TRIALS REGARDING THE USE OF IN
CUSTODY INFORMANTS. UNDER OUR
LAW WE DO NOT ALLOWED. EITHER
TESTIMONY OR CONVICTIONS FROM
ONE CORROBORATED IN CUSTODY IN
FORM. HOWEVER PROCESS IS IN
PLACE REGARDING INCARCERATED IN
CUSTODY INFORMANTS AS A RESULT
SUCH UNCORROBORATED INFO CAN
NOW BE ENTERED INTO A
CONFIDENTIAL PRISON FILES AND
PRESENTED AT PAROLE HEARINGS
FOR USED TO JUSTIFY DISCIPLINE.
SB TEN SIXTY FOUR DOES NOT
REQUIRE DISCLOSURE OF THE
INFORMANTS IDENTITY THE
INFORMANT CAN STAY ANONYMOUS
WHICH IS CLEARLY ESSENTIAL FOR
THE PERSONS- OWN A PROTECTION.
BUT WHAT YES BE TEN SIXTY FOUR
DOES IS REQUIRE THAT AN
ACCUSATION BE CORROBORATED
BEFORE IT CAN BE SUBMITTED TO
EITHER THE PRO BOARD OR USED TO
DISAPPOINT AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THAT
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. BATES NO BELL I BARGES.
BRADFORD AYE CABRERA I CHIANG
NO DALLY. NO DODD. I TO RISING
I GALGIANI I GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG I
HILL I LISTEN. I TADO. NO
JACKSON I JONES. NO LEYVA I
MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL
I MONNING I MORE LOCK. MORRELL
NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN HI NUMBER I
LIKE CASTING I WIENER. WILK THE
CENTERS CAN REMOVE THE CALL
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT ALSO SENATOR SKINNER
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTY NINE BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND ACTUALLY
NEED TO REAL PROPERTY. SENATOR
SKINNER THANK YOU- MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS HOMEOWNERSHIP
AS I THINK MOST OF US
APPRECIATE IS AN ESSENTIAL PATH
FOR WELL QUESTION. IN OUR
FAMILIES- BUT ACCORDING AND NOT
BUT ACCORDING TO FORBES THE
TYPICAL HOMEOWNER IN ACHIEVES
A- MULTIPLE FORTY FIVE TIMES
THE FINANCIAL ACHIEVEMENT THEN
A RENTER OVER A LIFETIME. NOW
WITH THE FOR CLOSURES OF THE
LAST RECESSION CALIFORNIA'S
OWNER OCCUPIED HOMEOWNERSHIP
DROPPED BY OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. AND RENTER OCCUPIED
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES INCREASED
BY SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND. THIS
FALL AND HOMEOWNERSHIP BY
FORBES OWN ACCOUNT WAS NOT THE
THOSE FORECLOSURES LARGE
CORPORATE VESTER SPOT UP FOR
CLOSE ROOMS AT ROCK BOTTOM
PRICES. AND MANY HOMES WERE
LEFT VACANT WHICH NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED NEIGHBORHOODS. AND
OTHERS WERE RENTED BY THESE
CORPORATE INVESTORS CREATING
ACCORDING TO WALL STREET A NEW
ASSET CLASS SINGLE FAMILY HOME
RENTALS. THIS INCREASE IN THE
CORPORATE HOMEOWNERSHIP
ARTIFICIALLY RAISED HOME PRICES
IN CERTAIN NEIGHBORHOODS AND
FOR MANY OF THE RENTERS THEY
EXPERIENCED LEASES WITH VERY
PUNITIVE AND COSTLY PROVISIONS
AND MANY HOME OWNERS OF FORMER
HOMEOWNERS OF THE HOME FOUND
THEMSELVES RENTING FROM THOSE
ENTITIES. NOW WHAT THE INTENT
OF SB TEN SEVENTY NINE IS TO
PREVENT THAT SAME SCENARIO IF
WE AND I HOPE WE DO NOT FACE A
WAVE OF FORECLOSURES ANYWHERE
AT THE LEVEL THAT WE DID IN THE
LAST RECESSION. THE TEN SEVEN
NINE HAS THREE KEY ELEMENTS. IT
ALLOWS FOR. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
NONPROFIT HOUSING DEVELOPERS
AND PERSPECTIVE OWNER OCCUPANTS
THE ABILITY TO HAVE A WINDOW TO
BID ON FORECLOSED HOMES AHEAD
OF INVESTORS. IT THEN LIMITS
PURCHASE OF A LARGE NUMBER OF
FOR CLOSE TO HOME AT A SINGLE
ACTION. AND IT ALSO ALLOWS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DEAL WITH
THE PROBLEM I MENTIONED WE'RE
HOMES MAY BE LEFT VACANT. IT
ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
INCREASE FINES ON VACANT ON
MAINTAINED FORECLOSED
PROPERTIES. THAT'S FINE IT'S
NOT MANDATED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
DO NOT HAVE TO USE IT AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHT IT CAN ONLY BE
ISSUED AFTER A THIRTY DAY
NOTICE. AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE SENATOR GORGEOUS.
MEMBERS OF THE QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR. THERE'S CAN WE TAKE A
QUESTION YES PLEASE PROCEED IN
A SCENARIO WHERE A COMMERCIAL
COMPLEX WITH MIGHT HAVE. IT
MIGHT BE IT- STRUCTURALLY
ESSENTIALLY ONE COMPLEX BUT
WITH MULTIPLE A P. ENDS FOR A
MULTI FAMILY. WITH MULTI-
MULTIPLE ATMS. HOW WOULD IT
WORK IN THIS SITUATION. THIS
THIS STATUTE BEFORE US IS. IT'S
TARGETED IN LANGUAGES SPECIFIC
TO SINGLE FAMILY FOUR CLOSE
TERMS NOT MULTI UNIT PROPERTIES.
I HAPPEN AND ON. TO KNOW OF THE
UNITS FOR EXAMPLE AT THAT ARE
IN A COMPLEX INDIVIDUAL LET'S
SEE TOWN OMES BUT THEY'RE IN A
COMPLEX WITH MULTIPLE EIGHT PM.
WITH THIS APPLY TO THE. I'M NOT
SURE EXACTLY HOW TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION IF THE TOWN HOME IS
UNDER ITS TITLE CONSIDERED A
SINGLE FAMILY HOME IT COULD
APPLY YES BUT IT WOULD. SO YES
IN THAT CASE OKAY THANK YOU AND
ALSO CONCLUDE TO BUY I THINK
THE AUTHOR. HAS SEIZED ON
SOMETHING THAT IS REAL IN MY
FORMER CAPACITY IS A SUPERVISOR
I THINK WE HAVE SEEN- MAJOR
INVESTMENT FIRMS BY UP THESE
THINGS AND- YOU'RE DEALING WITH
THE BUREAUCRACY OF HOW DO YOU
GET THEM TO REHABILITATE THE
PROPERTY AND ESPECIALLY AS
THEY'RE LOOKING TO FLIP IT SO
THERE IS A DEFINITE TRUTH TO
THIS- I WOULD. OTHERWISE HOPE
THOUGH THAT LOCAL CONTROL WOULD
BE MORE IMPORTANT IN THIS
SITUATION- AND IF THEY WANT TO
IMPOSE GREATER FINES OR IF THEY
WANT TO CREATE RESTRICTIONS- I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE A
FLOOD OF FORECLOSED PROPERTIES
UNFORTUNATELY. I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S GOING TO BE AT THE TWO
THOUSAND TENS LEVEL BUT
PANDEMIC WAS ALMOST CERTAINLY
GOING TO CREATE THESE PROBLEMS
AND COUNTIES ARE GOING TO NEED
TO UNLOAD THEM QUICKLY AND
RESTRICTIONS THIS COULD CREATE
A PROBLEM. THAT IS ONLY CAN.
THANK YOU CENTER JUST THE SCENE
OF TO ACTION AND- SEND SKINNER
PLEASE. YES THANK YOU SO
APPRECIATE YOUR RAISING THE
ISSUE ABOUT THE FINES THE FINES%
WHILE THIS STATUTE. DOES ALLOW
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT. OR RATHER
IT INCREASES THE CAP. THAT IS
NOW IN PLACE. IT IS NOT
REQUIRED THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TO USE IT IN SO IN THIS RESPECT
THE COMPLETELY HONORS LOCAL
CONTROL. SO IF A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CHOOSES NOT TO LET
ME FIND AT ALL THAT IS UP TO
THEM OR IF THEY CHOOSE TO
FOLLOW. THE FORMER FINDS THAT
THEY HAD BEEN UTILIZING THAT IS
ALSO UP TO THEM. THIS IS JUST
FOR THOSE CASES WERE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS REALLY SEEING AN
EGREGIOUS CIRCUMSTANCE AND I
WOULD- JUST GIVE A PERSONAL. I
VIVIDLY RECALL DURING THE LAST
RECESSION. TOURING WITH THE
CITY MANAGER AND OTHER
OFFICIALS. BLOCKS OF AREAS IN
BOTH THE CITY OF RICHMOND IN
THE CITY OF OAKLAND. WHERE MANY
MANY MANY HOMES WERE FORECLOSED
BANDS THAT IT A SINGLE THERE
WAS ACTUALLY TO SINGLE
CORPORATIONS THAT BOUGHT UP
MOST OF THE PROPERTIES. AND
LEFT THEM. AND THOSE PROPERTIES
AND THEN IN A COURSE REMEMBER
DURING THAT RECESSION. THEY
WERE STRIPPED OF ALL TYPES OF
COPPER WIRING OF IT I MEAN THE
THIS CONDITION WAS- SO
DISGUSTED. BAND THE FEW
NEIGHBORS THAT REMAINED HAD TO
LIVE IN BLOCKS OF THESE VERY
VERY. DERELICT PROPERTIES AND
THE CITIES WHILE THEY WERE
FINING AND MAKING NOTICES THEY
WERE GETTING NO RESPONSE
WHATSOEVER. ON THOSE INTO THE
BILL IS REALLY I HOPE THAT THAT
DOES NOT HAPPEN IF WE ARE HOPE
NUMBER ONE THAT WE DO NOT FACE
SERIES KNOWN FORECLOSURES AND
NUMBER TWO THAT WE DO NOT FACE
THAT KIND OF YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY. BUT THIS IS
SIMPLY A TOOL IN YES WE DO AND
WITH THAT I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL FIVE FOR
JUST NO BRADFORD I HAVE A- I
CHIANG NO VALLEY NO DODD. I
DORADO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
I HILL AYE HUESO. HI TANTO I
JACKSON AYE JONES. NO LEYVA
FIVE MCGUIRE. I MELINDA'S NO
MITCHELL I MONNING. I MORE LOCK
NO MORAL. NO NIELSEN NO HAN
FIVE PORTANTINO HI ROSS. I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN HI
NUMBER HI I LIKE HOW SKI. HI
WIENER. WELL HI CENTER SKINNER
MUSICAL MEMBERS. MEMBERS BEFORE
WE MOVED OUR NEXT ITEM WE ARE
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON FILE
ITEM FORTY THREE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS I BATES.
BRADFORD DODD I GALGIANI. HELLO
TADO. MCGUIRE RUBIO. STERN
AMBERG. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. BATES
BRADFORD. GALGIANI TELL TADO.
MCGUIRE RUBIO. STERN I'M BURKE
SENATOR MOVES THE CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE FORWARD THE
FILE TO FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN
SENATOR CABALLERO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN TEN BY SENATOR
CABALLERO AND ACTUALLY TO
TENDENCY CENTER CABALLERO THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SB
FOURTEEN TEN. WHICH IS DESIGNED
TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF TENANTS
THAT ARE AT RISK OF BECOMING
HOMELESS BECAUSE THEY ARE
BEHIND IN THE RENTAL PAYMENTS
BECAUSE OF THE COLBERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. AND ALSO TO HELP PUT
MONEY IN THE HEAD OF LANDLORDS
WHO NEED TO KEEP UP PAYMENTS ON
THEIR PROPERTIES. THIS BILL PUT
FORTH FOR KEY PROVISIONS ONE IT
ALLOWSLANDLORDS TO ENTER INTO
VOLUNTARY IF YOU CAN RELIEF
AGREEMENTS WITH TENANTS. GAVE
UNPAID AND IT CHANGED. CREDIT
INVEST. TEN YEARS TO REPAY THE
STATE THE UNPAID RENT IN ANNUAL
INSTALLMENTS BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR INTEREST
FREE THE TAX CREDIT FOR
LANDLORDS CAN BE RETAINED FOR
USE IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR OR
SOLD FOR IMMEDIATE CASH RELIEF.
AND FOR A PROHIBITS LANDLORDS
FROM EVICTING A TENANT DURING
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY UNLESS
THE LANDLORD OFFERS THE TENANT
THE RELIEF AGREEMENT. OR THE
EVICTION IS NECESSARY TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY WHICH IS THE CURRENT
STANDARD WHICH WAS SET UP BY
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL EMERGENCY
RULE OF COURT DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. AND FINALLY THE BILL
PROVIDE FURTHER AID TO RENTERS
BY ALLOWING QUALIFYING
QUALIFYING PARTICIPANTS THE
ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE WITH THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO FORGIVE
SOME OF ALL OF THE DEFERRED
RENT. BASED ON INCOME LEVEL. AS
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIANS ACROSS
THE STATE ARE STRUGGLING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET. UNEMPLOYMENT
HAS PASSED 16% THIS MONTH
HIGHER THAN AT ANY POINT DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION. AND SINCE
APRIL WE'VE SEEN AN INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF RENTERS CORNET
WHO ARE UNABLE TO PAY ALL OR
SOME PART OF THE RENT ON TIME
IN THE REALLY GOOD THING IS
THAT. MOST OF IT APPEARS THAT
MOST OF THE RENTERS ARE PAYING
HARSH AT LEAST PARTIAL PAYMENTS
ON WHAT THE- THIS IS WHY WE
CANNOT WAIT TO MOVE A POLICY
SOLUTION FOR THAT WILL ADDRESS
THE NEED TO BOAST TENANTS. AND
LANDLORDS ALIKE AND QUITE
FRANKLY THIS IS HAS BECOME THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE THAT I'M
HEARING IN MY DISTRICT IS THAT
PEOPLE JUST ARE DON'T KNOW HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
CATCH THEMSELVES UP BECAUSE
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN WORKING. AND
COMPOUNDED WITH THE FACT THAT
DE DE DE HAS STILL NOT
PROVIDED. BENEFITS TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE ALL ABOUT ELIGIBLE
BENEFITS MAKES IT VERY VERY
DIFFICULT BECAUSE E'S FAMILIES
ARE REALLY STRUGGLING. THE
START THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
HERE TODAY AND IN THE COMING
WEEKS SHOULD THIS BILL MOVED TO
THE ASSEMBLY. WE WILL EMPHASIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF TENANTS TO
CONTINUE TO PAY WHAT THEY CAN
TO WORDS OR RENT. AND TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEIR
LANDLORDS IN THE EVENT THEY ARE
STRUGGLING TO DO SO. LASTLY
THIS BILL HAS BEEN IN PRINT FOR
A LITTLE A LITTLE OVER A WEEK
AND THERE IS MUCH TO BE DONE. I
CAN GET TO MY COLLEAGUES. AND
THE STATE RESTORE TOGETHER IN
FAMILY SURE THE PROPER DISTRICT
BETWEEN BENEFITS PROVIDED TO
BOTH TENANTS. AND LANDLORDS AND
WE STARTED TO DO OUR RICH TOO-
THE STAKEHOLDER GROUPS THERE'S
A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE BUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR- VOTE
TODAY. YOU SENATOR CABALLERO. A
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I'M PROUD TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SELENA'S
ENJOYING AUTHOR OF AS THE
FOURTEEN CAN THIS IS ISSUE OF
GREAT CONCERN AS- WELL CHAIR OF
THE SENATE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
TASK FORCE THIS IS ONE OF THE
MOST DEBATED ITEMS IN ADDITION
TO THAT WE CAN WORK ON FOR
ALMOST TWO MONTHS. FIVE URGENT
WRIST TO CRISIS IT IMPACTING
AHA SO AND- DEALING WITH
FORECLOSURES EVEN BEFORE THE
COLBERT NINETEEN CRISIS THERE
WAS WELL OVER A MILLION RENTERS
WHO WERE STRUGGLING TO MAKE. A
RENT PAYMENT STATUS ONLY BEEN
EXACERBATED TO THE JOB LOSS AND
WHAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED OVER THE
LAST THREE MONTHS. IT'S MOST
BALLOT THAT IF A TENTATIVE
STRUGGLING TO PAY THEIR RENT
THEN I LANDLORDS ARE STRUGGLING
TO MAKE. THERE FIVE MORTGAGE
PAYMENTS AND I WANT TO BE CLEAR
AGAIN MANY TIMES WE THINK OF
APARTMENT OWNERS AS THESE MULTI
MILLION DOLLAR CONGLOMERATES
AND THEY ARE THE THOSE THAT
EXIST OUT THERE BUT MANY OF
THESE FOLKS- MOM AND POP
FRONTLINE WORKERS WHO'VE
INVESTED THERE ARE BUS DRIVERS
THERE ARE SCHOOL TEACHERS ARE
MALE MATT WHO BEST PROPERTY A
LOT OF TIME- OWNER OCCUPIED.
UNITS A HAVE A TRI PLEX OR
DUPLEX AND- THEY RENT THOSE OUT
FOR THEIR RETIREMENT IT'S
THEIR- KIDS COLLEGE FUND SO
THESE ARE NOT WEALTHY PEOPLE SO
WE TOOK THAT IN MIND MAKING
SURE THAT WE PROTECT PROTECTED
THEM. AS WELL AS A TENANT. WE
HAVE TALKED TO CONSTITUENTS AS-
MY COLLEAGUES STATED FROM
SALINAS IS IN THIS IS. I ISSUE
THAT REQUIRES A STACK NOW. AND
THIS BILL IS JUST ONE OF MANY
RESPONSES THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
AT DURING THIS CRISIS. TENDED
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE RELIEF
PROGRAM WILL STAY IN THEIR
HOMES AND THEY WILL REPAY THE
GRANT IN TIME. LANDLORDS TO
PARTICIPATE WILL GET A TAX
CREDIT AS STATED AND THEY CAN
EITHER KEEP THAT TAX CREDIT OR
SELL IT- THE HELP FILMS KEEP
MAKING THEIR MORTGAGE PAYMENTS.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT THIS IS
NOT AN EXCUSE FOR TENANTS TO
PAY THEIR RENT. WE HOPE IT'S AN
INCENTIVE FOR THE- TENANT TO
PAY THEIR RENT BECAUSE ZERO.
SAFEGUARDS BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
LOOK OUT AFTER THOSE WONDERFUL
TENANTS AND THOSE VULNERABLE
LANDLORDS- THEY MAKE SURE THAT
WE DON'T MAKE THE SITUATION
WORSE. WHAT CORPORATE DROWNED
OT STRUGGLING TENANTS CAN BE
EVICTED. PROPERTY OWNERS ARE
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO PAY THEIR
MORTGAGE AND PAY THEIR PROPERTY
TAXES WE CAN'T LEAVE THOSE
FOLKS WITHOUT A PATH. OUT OF
THIS CRISIS. SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE RAISED CONCERNS
BECAUSE OF EARNS EARNS
UNCERTAIN COSTS AS MY COLLEAGUE
DAVID THIS IS THE ISSUE HAT
STILL IN DEBATE BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT SURE HOW MANY PEOPLE WILL
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM.
AND A PERFECT BUT WE WOULD HOPE
NOT WILL. IN IT- I'M MORE WOULD
HAVE TO- PARTICIPATE BUT WE
WANT TO PUT THE SAVE OUR
DEMAND- IN PLACE AS MY
COLLEAGUE STATE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK. BUT ALL
INTEREST GROUP TEMP BILL FOR
AND WE- ALL THAT IT DOESN'T
HAVE ANY ACT NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
OUR JOURNEY FIVE. NUMBERS
THAT'S FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD SENATOR ATKINS.
RENDON PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I TO BE HONEST A LOT
OF WHAT I WANTED TO SAY HAS
BEEN SAID THAT I WANTED TO BE
VERY CLEAR. THAT I WANT TO
KNOWLEDGE AND THANK THE GOOD
SENATORS FROM SALINAS AND
GUARDINO FOR A- REALLY TAKEN OF
THIS AND CHAMPION A FIVE AND
BRING IT BEFORE YOU'RE- A- I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE-
MAJORITY LEADER IN OUR BUT
CHAIR. OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
ECONOMIC WITH FREE WORKING
GROUP THAT THE US DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS PUT TOGETHER.
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE OUR WE
HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING VERY HARD
TO FIND CREATIVE SOLUTIONS.
DON'T FALL. MONEY FROM THE
STATE. WHICH WE DON'T HAVE. OUR
OTHER. WAYS FOR THIS SO. I'M
GOING APPLAUD THEM FOR THE
CREATIVE ARE PROCESS IN
BRINGING THIS FORWARD FOR US TO
CONSIDER. BUT I DO WANT TO RE
EMPHASIZE IT HAS BEEN SEVEN I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
HEAR. THIS BILL IS NOT A
GIVEAWAY TENANTS ARE STILL
RESPONSIBLE FOR PAYING RENT AND
LANDLORDS WILL LIKELY GET A
HAIR CUT. BUT IT DOES PROVIDE
SOME TEMPORARY RELIEF TO ALL
THE PARTIES. YOU KNOW I LIKE IN
THE STATE ARE TRYING HARD TO
FLATTEN THE COAT. FOR IT AS IT
RELATES TO OUR HEALTHCARE OR
HEALTH THIS. THIS IS FLAG ME.
ARE THE- FOR. WEIGHT PEOPLE CAN
MAYBE HANDLE A LITTLE BIT
BETTER THAN HAVING NO SOLUTION.
AND IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT CREATIVELY
HOW TO DO THESE THINGS. ARE TWO
CALLS AS LITTLE HARM AS
POSSIBLE WE DON'T HAVE. EVERY
ANSWER. IT IS TRUE BUT THIS IS
AN INCREDIBLE EFFORT TO REALLY
HELP HURTING CALIFORNIANS
RENTERS AND LANDLORDS
PARTICULARLY. ARE I WOULD SAY
NOT ENTIRELY BUT PARTICULARLY
THE SMALLER LANDLORDS WHO ARE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
INVESTMENT. THEY DON'T LOSE AND
I'M SURE THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
HURTING PEOPLE AS WELL THESE
ARE THEIR TENANTS I'VE HEARD
THAT AGAIN AND AGAIN FROM THE
LANDLORD. FINAL IS THE EITHER
SAID THEY'RE STILL WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS I AM FULL AN
OPTIMISTIC NOTE. THAT WE CAN
FIND SO SINCE THE KEY CAN IT'S-
THE STAFF FARM. AND I KNOW AND
HOPE THAT BOTH PLAN TEN CAN. IN
GOOD FAITH TOGETHER TO FIND
SOLUTIONS AND CRITICS
INCREDIBLY HIGH QUALITY AFTER
OUR AND SENATE BILL TEN THANK
YOU THINK IS THANK YOU THERE AT
ARMS WE. OKAY YOU MADAM. I WILL
BE SUPPORT WELL AS BEFORE TEN
TODAY BUT I SO. AS I STATED IN
GOVERNMENT TO FIND WITH INTO
THAT IS MORE WORK- THAT IS
NEEDED ON THIS BILL- WE DO FACE
A HUGE RISK OF MASS PROTECTIONS
FOR NOT JUST AFFECTIONS THE
PEOPLES OF LEAVING I GOT A TEXT
THIS MORNING FROM A SMALL
LANDLORD I KNOW AND SAN
FRANCISCO IN FOUR EIGHT THAT
SEVEN OF HIS EIGHTEEN TENANTS.
HAVE SIMPLY VACATED. NOT
BECAUSE THEY WERE DYING TO
VACATE BUT THEY HAD NO WAY OF
PAYING THE RENT. AND SOMEONE
TENANTS CAN PAY THE RENT AND
EITHER ADDICTED OR LEAVE. THAT
IS TERRIBLE FOR THE TENANTS
IT'S TERRIBLE FOR THE COMMUNITY
AS A RESIDENTS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. AND IT'S BAD FOR THE
LANDLORDS BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING
TO STRUGGLE TO RE RENT A PLACE
IT'S INCUMBENT ON ALL OF US.
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
STABILIZE RENTERS IN THEIR
HOMES. OTHERWISE WE ARE GOING
TO STRUGGLE TO RECOVER. WITH
RESPECT TO SB FOURTEEN AND I AM
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
CREATIVE THINKING AND WE DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
KEEPING ALL PARTIES NEEDS AN
ACCOUNT BUT I WANTED TO POINT
OUT A FEW THINGS AND I HOPE
THAT WE CAN. CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THESE ISSUES FIRST OF ALL
THIS IS VOLUNTARY IF THE
LANDLORD DOESN'T WANT TO
PARTICIPATE. PAN THE BILL
DOESN'T GET TRIGGERED AND SO
THERE WILL BE RENTS. ARE NOT
PROGRAM WHO NEED FOR TIME AND
THAT CAN BE DONE THIS THROUGH
AMENDMENTS THEY'RE ALSO SEVERAL
ASSEMBLY BILL IS TO PROTECT RUN
THROUGH THAT ARE PENDING. IN
THE SENATE RIGHT NOW. FIVE
SECONDS. WITH RESPECT TO THE
REPAYMENT BY THE RENTERS. FIVE
TO BE CLEAR WHAT PEOPLE NEED TO
DO THERE IS A SLIDING SCALE SO
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE LOWER
INCOME. AND HAVE PART FOR ALL
THEIR- RENT OWED TO THE STATE
WAVED AND THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT I'M APPRECIATIVE OF
THE AUTHORS HAVE PUT THAT INTO
THE BILL. ON HOWEVER THE
MECHANISM TO REPAY IT'S OVER
TEN YEARS IT IS THROUGH YOUR
TAX RETURN THE FILE SO IF YOU
ARE TOO POOR. TO FILE A TAX
RETURN IF YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
INCOME EUROPE'S VERY OR
EXTREMELY LOW. INCOME RENTERS
YOU ALL HAVE START. FILING A
TAX RETURN EVEN THOUGH YOU
NEVER DONE THAT BEFORE. AND
THAT IS TRUE IF YOU ARE
UNDOCUMENTED MAYBE YOU'VE MAYBE
YOU DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH- MAYBE
YOU ARE FRAIL SENIOR. YOU KNOW
HOW TO START FILING A TAX
RETURN IN ORDER TO CLAIM THE
WAIVER OF THE RENT AND I CAN
THAT THAT'S SIGNIFICANCE AND
THAT THAT IS A BAD DAY OR-
MOREOVER. LEAVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. YOU WILL CONTINUE
TO HAVE TO FILE A CALIFORNIA
TAX RETURN EVERY YEAR AND SO I
CITY THINGS NINE OPPOSITION SO
I SUPPORT THIS BILL I WANT THIS
BILL TO SUCCEED- BUT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE REALLY
WORKING THANKS TO THE PEOPLE
CAN CAN USE SAYS THAT IT'S NOT
A BIRD AND PARTICULARLY ON OUR
LOWEST INCOME VULNERABLE
RENTERS. OUR SENIORS- PEOPLE
WHO DON'T. SPEAK ENGLISH.
PEOPLE WHO YOU KNOW THERE THEY
HAVE THEY'RE JUST TRYING TO
SURVIVE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THIS ISN'T A BARRIER AND THAT
PEOPLE CAN ACTUALLY USE A SO I
SUPPORT THIS BUT I- LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUING WORK
AN EVOLUTION OF THIS BILL TO
MAKE IT AS GREAT AS IT CAN BE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER CENTER FOR. THANK YOU A-
MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT TO JOIN
WITH THE PRO TEM IN THANKING
THE SENATORS FROM SELLING US
AND- MY CO CHAIR FOR DINNER AND
WORKING ON THIS MATTER RIGHT. I
START IN IT AND ALSO I WANT TO
THANK YOUR STAFF AND BUDGET
STAFF FOR THEIR EXTRAORDINARY
WORK ON ALL OF THIS. THIS
EFFORT HERE ARM YOU KNOW LAST
NIGHT WHEN THE BUDGET SHARE OF
CLOSE TO TALK ABOUT HOW THEY
WERE SIGNIFICANT PLANS THAN
THOSE CHANGE WHEN WE HAD A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC THE WORLD
CHANGED. AND SO THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED HERE AND WHAT THE
EFFORT AFOOT IS. WELL THE
GOVERNOR WAS DEEPLY ENGAGED IN
HAS BEEN DEEPLY ENGAGED IN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH ELEMENT. THE PRO
TEMPORE TOGETHER A WORKING
GROUP OF A WHOLE HOST OF US TO
BEGIN TO ANALYZE AND COME UP
WITH SOLUTIONS OF HOW THE HOW
THE BALANCE OCCURS. SHE
ARTICULATED WERE ON THE ONE
HAND WE DO THE LEAST AMOUNT OF
HARM TO THE BUDGET TO MAKE SURE
WE KEEP THE SOCIAL SAFETY NET
AND EDUCATION ALL THE OTHER
NECESSARY SERVICES. AND THE
OTHER HAND THE UPS THIS WALL
HYKSOS AS THIS IS THE FEDERAL
START TO WOULD WHICH START
BEING VERY SHORTLY WE- WHAT WE-
CAN TO THE FRAMEWORK AROUND
THIS JUST. MY CAR SPEAKERS.
HELLO HE ARTICULATED OF THIS
MESS THAT THERE IS NO FREE RIDE
THIS IS THE BALLOTS WERE PEOPLE
GET A HIT ON THE HEAD THE STATE
OF THE OTHER. WE CAN BASIC. SO
PORT TO MAKE THAT PEOPLE KEPT
IN THEIR HOMES AND NOT BECOME
HOMELESS IN A WAY WHERE
ULTIMATELY THE CONSEQUENCES TO
SOCIETY THE DEMAND OF THE
SAFETY THAT WOULD BE MUCH MORE
EXTREME. IN A WAY THAT OFF THE
COSTS TO FUTURE YEARS WHEN WE
CAN AFFORD TO PAY FOR THE IDEAS
THAT WE HAVE A THREE YEAR EVENT
HORIZON TO ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN
KEEPING PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES
WILL BE HELPING SMALL
BUSINESSES PROVIDING TOOLS THAT
ARE NECESSARY. FOR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND IS A CORE OF THIS
IS THIS ELEMENT WHERE PEOPLE
MAKE A SHOWING THAT THEY'VE GOT
THE HARM THAT WE KEEP IN THEIR
HOMES WERE LANDLORDS ARE BEING
TAKEN CARE OF WITH THE WITH THE
F. B. FUNGIBLE PAYMENT
METHODOLOGY RESIDENT INFORMED.
BUT DOES IMPOSE UPON THE
CURRENT A BUDGET YEARS IT HAS
ALSO SOME ELEMENTS WHICH WILL
BE DISCUSSED AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD HOLD ON YOUR TAX
CREDITS ACTION REDUCE TAX. IS
BEING OR INCOME GET. USED HOLD
ON TO THESE TAX CREDITS YEAR
INSTEAD OF SELLING. THERE'S A
WHOLE OF ELEMENTS TO THIS
APPROACH THAT HAS GREAT
BENEFITS FOR ALL PARTIES SHOULD
MAKE SURE. THAT WHERE IS WAS
EXPRESSED BY THE SENATOR FROM
SAN FRANCISCO. PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE THE FUNDS TO PAY THEY'RE
NOT GONNA HAVE TO PAY BUT IF
YOU DO HAVE THE FUNDS YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO PAY BACK THE
STATE. SO THIS IS REALLY WHAT
THOUGHT THROUGH AGAIN I WANT TO
GIVE GREAT CREDIT TO. THE TO MY
CULTURE TO THE- AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE AND TO THE PRO TEM
STAFF THEY GET IS A ERY
WORTHY. AND THOUGHTFUL A- TO
LEGISLATION UNDER VERY VERY
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES I ASK
YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG SENATOR DURAZO. YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I ALSO
RISE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL- I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR THERE
TO COME HERE WE TAKE A QUESTION.
THANK YOU. ALSO FOR THESE
PROCEED THANK YOU. I KNOW THIS
I THINK THIS IS BEEN BROUGHT UP
BY OF- OTHERS BUT I JUST WANT
TO GET SOME CLARITY AS FAR AS A
DIRECT- AND AGAIN I'M
SUPPORTING THIS BILL BUT THESE
ARE THE QUESTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN ASKED OF ME. HOW DO YOU
HAND. LANDLORDS WHO DO NOT WANT
TO ENTER INTO THIS KIND OF
AGREEMENT. AND WHAT IS IT WHERE
DOES THAT LEAVE THOSE TENANTS-
**** UNABLE TO PAY THE RENT.
EXCELLENT EXCELLENT QUESTION.
TERRY THIS IS A VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM AND IF THE LANDLORD
INTENDS TO EVICT A TENANT FOR
NON PAYMENT OF RENT THEN THEY
HAVE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM IF THEY DECLINE THAT
THEN THEY CAN NOT CONVICTED
TENANTS. OKAY AS I CAN YOU SAY
THAT ONE MORE TIME I'M TRYING
TO YES YEAH THE WAY THE PROCESS
IS GOING TO WORK. IS THAT THE
LANDLORD. HAS TO OFFERED THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THE TENANT OKAY.
AND LET'S SAY THE TENANTS SAYS
YES I'D LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE LANDLORD. IT WAS A SHAM.
THE LANDLORD IS NOT ABLE AT
THAT POINT TO AFFECT THE TENANT.
OKAY FOR NON PAYMENT OF RENT
FOR NON PAYMENT OKAY CLEAR
THANK YOU AND- MY SECOND
QUESTION I HAD REYES THIS. WHEN
THE IDEA FIRST CAME OUT WHICH I
THINK IS. GOOD TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF PAYMENT OF RENT
BECAUSE- OF THEIR BODY HAS
SAID. YOU KNOW IT CAN
ACCUMULATE VERY QUICKLY AND SO
WE'RE GOING TO BE FACING THAT
SIZE IS GLAD TO SEE THIS. I WAS
CONCERNED AND I STILL AM ABOUT.
THE DEBT FOLLOWING AS A BAD
CREDIT ITEM AND I UNDERSTAND
FOR MEETING. HERE THE ANALYSIS
THE BILL DIRECTS THE FTP TO
COLLECT- ANY UNPAID AMOUNTS
SIMILAR TO OTHER TAX DEBTS
INCLUDING LEANS AND LEVEES SO
SINCE THAT IT FALLS UNDER THAT
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT AGAIN
THIS POOR PEOPLE FOR THE MOST
PART YOU KNOW PEOPLE OF COLOR-
MAYBE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
SERVICES BUT HOW DO THEY DEAL
WITH THIS SORT OF DEBT RELIEF
FOLLOWING THEM IN A NEGATIVE
WAY VERSES. THIS IS OPPORTUNITY
GOOD STATE TO IN THE STATE AND
THE TENANT I DON'T KNOW I WANT
TO HEAR AN ANSWER. AND
EXCELLENT QUESTION SO- LET'S
ASSUME THAT THE TENANT- OWES
RENT. AND TO THE LANDLORD. AND
THEY DON'T HAVE A WAY TO BE
ABLE TO PAY THAT BACK RIGHT
AWAY BECAUSE THEY JUST DON'T
MAKE ENOUGH MONEY OR THEY'RE
NOT WORKING THAT DEBT WILL
FOLLOW THEM FOR EVER IF THEY
EVENTUALLY LEAVE OR IF THE-
THE- THEY DON'T TO ENTER INTO
THIS AGREEMENT. THEY WILL HAVE
A HARD TIME FINDING ANOTHER
APARTMENT BECAUSE THAT THAT
WILL FOLLOW THEM. SO WITH THIS
PROCESS ENVISIONS IS IF THEY
PARTICIPATE IN THE RENTAL
AGREEMENT THE DEBT THEN BE
BECOMES A DEBT OF THE STATE.
AND WHAT HAPPENS IS IF THE
INDIVIDUAL IS EARNING A HUNDRED
AND 50% OF THE MEDIAN INCOME.
YEAH TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THEN
THEY'RE EXPECTED TO START
PAYING THAT DEBT BACK. AND THE
F. T. B. WELL COLLECTED JUST
LIKE ANY OTHER DEBT THAT'S
BOWED TO FTP. WHICH MEANS IT'S
A PAYMENT PLAN RIGHT. IF THEY
EARN BETWEEN A HUNDRED AND A
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE PERCENT.
BEN IT'S A 75% REPAYMENT AND
AGAIN IT'S OVER TEN YEARS. AND
IT'S WITH NO INTEREST AND THERE
SO THERE'S NO PENALTIES ON IT
AT THAT POINT. IF THEY EARN
BETWEEN SEVENTY FIVE AND NINETY
NINE PERCENT. THEN THEY PAY 50%
AND IF THEY. EARN 75% OR BELOW
THERE'S NO REPAYMENT BUT THIS
DEPENDS ON WHAT THEY'RE EARNING
AT THE YEAR THAT THE OBLIGATION
TO PAY START. SO TO BE REALLY
FRANK ABOUT IT. IT'S PROBABLY
MORE PROBABLE THAT THE POOREST
PEOPLE WILL HAVE THE HARDEST
TIME MAKING THE RENT PAYMENTS.
AND THAT'S WHO WILL END UP IN
THE PROGRAM AND WHOSE DEATH
WILL BE FORGIVEN. IF THEY'RE
STILL NOT EARNING. THE MEDIAN
INCOME. IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
OKAY SO IT IS AN INVESTMENT BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA JUST TO
BE CLEAR. IN STABILIZE THE
HOUSING MARKET SO THAT PEOPLE
CAN STAY IN THEIR IN THEIR
RESIDENCES ARE IN THE UNITS
THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE RENTING
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US NOT TO END UP
WITH. HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES HOMELESS. SO FOR THE
ANSWERS. I WOULD CONTINUE TO
URGE THE ISSUE OF WAGE
GARNISHMENT A LEVEES LEVI'S
BECAUSE I REALLY- I'M CONCERNED
THAT THAT BECOMES A STAIN ON
THE ON THE CREDIT FOR ON THEIR
HISTORY SO WITH THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR
ALSO CENTER JONES. YEAH I WANT
TO THANK OUR OUR GOOD CALLING
FROM LOS ANGELES SHE ASKED A
VERY GOOD SERIES OF QUESTIONS
SOME OF WHICH- I HAD THE SAME
CONCERNS AND I DO HAVE- TO
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS MADAM
PRESIDENT IF I MAY ASK- TWO
QUESTIONS ON TWO DIFFERENT
TOPICS IF. YOU'RE WITTY THE
QUESTIONS YES PLEASE PROCEED
AND I'LL ASK HIM IN ONE
STATEMENT SO YOU CAN ADDRESS
SOME- THERE'S SOME CONCERNS IT
YEAH THIS IS A VERY AMBITIOUS-
GOAL TIME. TO FIX THIS PART OF
THE MARKET THAT'S BEEN KIND OF-
MESSED UP IN CALIFORNIA DUE TO
THE COVE IN NINETEEN STUFF- SO
TO. CONCERNS OF THE BILL AS IN
PRINT ONE THE CONSTITUTIONAL
CONCERNS THAT IT VIOLATES THE
CONTRACTS CLAUSE OF THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION AT BECAUSE OF THE
RETROACTIVITY OF IT. ALSO IS
THE STATE IS INTERFERING WITH A
CONTRACT. BEEN SIGNED IN AND
PROPERLY EXECUTED BY TWO
PARTIES. AND THEN THE SECOND
QUESTION IS THE ACTUAL PROCESS
OF. EXCHANGING THESE
MARKETABLE- TAX CREDITS- I
UNDERSTAND THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD IS NOT COMPLETELY GOT
THAT IRONED OUT OR HOW OR-
MAYBE NOT EVEN AGREED TO PART.
TO PAY. SO IF YOU CAN ADDRESS
THOSE TWO CANS THAT CREATES
CONSTITUTIONALITY AND THE
PROCESS. IT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO
HAPPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THOSE QUESTIONS SO- IN REGARDS
TO THE CONSTITUTIONAL CONCERNS
QUITE FRANKLY- THIS IS A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM NEITHER PARTY
NEEDS. TO AGREE TO IT. BUT THE
A BY SOME CONDITIONS FOLLOW
FROM IT THE- GOVERNOR HAS
ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
WHICH- PROVIDES THAT EVICTIONS
CANNOT OCCUR DURING THIS
PANDEMIC IN ITS WITHIN HIS
AUTHORITY TO DO THAT- THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAS ALSO
WEIGHED IN AND HAS SAID- NOT
ONLY CAN YOU NOT A VICTORY IN
THE TIME ON. THAT IS THAT IT'S
BEEN IDENTIFIED BY THE GOVERNOR
AND HE IS EXTENDED BY THE WAY I
BELIEVE THE END OF JULY. BUT IT
AFTER AFTER THAT THEY WILL NOT
BE TAKING. AT THE PAY WORK FOR
EVICTIONS AND SO WE HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE- BECAUSE OF THE
AUTHORITY. THAT IS GIVEN TO THE
GOVERNOR DURING. A PANDEMIC. ON
THOSE. THAT SITUATION IS IN
PLACE RIGHT NOW WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS TO COME IN AND
TO SAY SO WHEN THAT ALL IS
DONE. WHEN IT'S FINISHED WITH.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO WITH
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE.
THOUSANDS OF SMALL. LANDLORDS
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN GETTING FULL
PAYMENTS. AND THAT ARE AT RISK
OF FORECLOSURE AND MAY LOSE.
THERE ARE THEIR PROPERTIES AND
THOUSANDS OF TENANTS HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF TENANTS WHO
WOULD BE. AT RISK OF EVICTION
AND IF THAT HAPPENS WOULD HAVE
A REALLY HARD TIME FINDING A
LANDLORD TO RENT TO THEM
BECAUSE THEY JUST GOT EVICTED
AND SO THEN YOU KNOW THEY DON'T
THEY THEY DIDN'T PAY THE RENT
SO WHAT THIS DOES IS IT SETS UP
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LANDLORD
AND THE TENANT. TO VOTE BOTH
VOLUNTARILY AGREE THAT THIS IS
A PROCESS THAT THEY WANT TO GET
INVOLVED IN AND THEY
VOLUNTARILY. THROUGH THE RACKS.
ASIAN CONDITION. TRUCKS A DAY
BEEN INVOLVED IN. SO THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE CONSTITUTIONAL. MY%
VERY SIMPLE CONSTITUTIONAL
ANALYSIS- THEN AND THEN THE
SECOND ONE IS THE PROSPECTS TO
EXCHANGE THE TAX CREDITS. THAT
THAT WERE WORKING ON BUT WE
HAVE BEEN TOLD BY. THE
FINANCIAL EXPERTS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO PROBE THIS QUITE
FRANKLY BECAUSE THIS IS KEY TO
THE WHOLE. THING WORKING IS
THAT THOSE TAX CREDITS HAVE
MONETARY VALUE NOW YOU MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO GET A DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR IF YOU SELL IT THE
MARKET TODAY. BUT IT WILL HAVE
MORE. VALUE TO YOU- AT. RIGHT
NOW IF YOU NEED IT TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE YOUR MORTGAGE PAYMENT
OR TO PAY. DEBTS THAT YOU HAD-
AND IF YOU HOLD ON TO IT VALUE
INCREASES OVER. SO LET BE ABLE
TO MAKE TAT TO FOR THEM WITH
THEY NEED CASH RIGHT NOW OR
WHETHER THEY- THEY- WANT TO
SAVE IT AND USE IT IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU ARE ON MY OWN
TIME AND PRESENT SO I DO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THE PROCESS
WITH THE- ANTI TAX BUT HAS NOT
BEEN COMPLETELY IRONED OUT AND
THEY'RE STILL WORKING ON THAT-
AND THEN REGARDING THE
VOLUNTARY- WE'VE HEARD SEVERAL
TIMES. IN ANSWERS EVEN- SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT ARE ARE GOOD
CALLING YOU- FROM AT LOS
ANGELES WAS ASKING. IN THE%
ANSWER WERE HEARING THAT IT'S
VOLUNTARY BUT WE'RE ALSO
HEARING AT THE SAME TIME THAT
IT'S- REALLY THE VOLUNTARY IS
ONE WAY- OF. THE RENTER- YOU
CAN VOLUNTEER FOR PROGRAM. AND
THEN THE AMERICAN SAY YES OR NO
THEY'RE GONNA VOLUNTEER. BUT
EVEN IF THE LANDLORD DOESN'T
VOLUNTEER UNLAWFUL DETAINER IS
TO RESTRICT. SO THE LANDLORD
REALLY DOESN'T HAVE A VOLUNTARY
SITUATION HERE. IT LOOKS LIKE
WE'VE GOT A REAL. A REAL
CONCERN IN CALIFORNIA WITH THIS
RENTAL MARKET. IT'S A SIMPLE.
PROBLEM RANGERS CAN'T PAY RENT.
AND BUT IT'S CAUSED BY THE-
POLICIES THAT THIS GOVERNMENT
LAID OUT IN MARCH. THAT TOO
BECAUSE IT IS IT IT'S A
TEMPORARY IT'S A TEMPORARY
CHALLENGES AND PROBLEMS.
MEANING THE ECONOMY IS COMING
BACK SLOWLY BUT IT IS COMING
BACK EVEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WORKERS ARE GOING BACK TO WORK.
THEY'RE GONNA GET CAUGHT UP
THERE- WE'RE HEARING ALREADY
FROM A LOT OF. IF RENTAL
ADVOCATES AND LANDLORD
ASSOCIATIONS AND OTHER PEOPLE
TO DEAL IN THAT MARKET THAT
REALLY THAT MANY PEOPLE HAVE
NOT STOPPED PAYING RENT-
COMPLETELY SOME HAVE REDUCE
THEIR ABILITY TO PAY RENT BUT
YEAH I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
GET CAUGHT UP AND I THINK THE
MARKET. AND THE AND THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
LANDLORD AND THE TENANT IN
THOSE CASES CAN MAKE UP THERE
ALL IN ALL IN MOST OF THE
CASES. THE LANDLORD AND THE
TENANT ARE GONNA BE ABLE WORK
THIS OUT WITHOUT US INTERFERING
WITH THAT RELATIONSHIP THE I
DO. COMMAND THE AUTHORS THAT
THIS IS A VERY AMBITIOUS- SIX
YEAH IT'S VERY CREATIVE. AND
PROBABLY SOMETHING WE'VE NOT
SEEN CERTAINLY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OR ANY OTHER STATE
IN THE COUNTRY. THE PROBLEM IS
IT'S VERY COMPLICATED AND
CONVOLUTED. AS WE'RE ALREADY
HEARING FROM THE DEBATE THIS
THIS MORNING THERE'S A LOT OF
LOOSE ENDS IN THIS BILL. A LOT
OF THINGS THAT ARE COMPLETELY
STILL NOT FIGURED OUT- I'M NOT
SURE THAT THE CONSTITUTIONAL
PROBLEMS OF THE BILL HAVE BEEN-
COMPLETELY ADDRESS I APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR- YOU KNOW LETTING US
KNOW THE CURRENT STATUS OF THAT
SITUATION. AND YOU KNOW. WE GOT
A TEMPORARY. AT THE STATE NOW
IS GOING TO BE INVOLVED IN FOR
THE NEXT TWELVE TO FOURTEEN
YEARS- TRYING TO SOLVE IT. AS
PEOPLE FIGURE OUT THESE
MARKETABLE. TAX FREE TAX
CREDITS OR WHATEVER WOULD CALL
IN AND- PLEASE DON'T I JUST
THINK IT'S A GOES TOO FAR DOES
TOO MUCH IS NOT FIGURE OUT
ENOUGH TO ME LOOSENS ASK FOR NO
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER JONES
CENTER JACKSON. THANK YOU ARE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES ARE. I AM STILL
HOPEFUL THAT WE ARE AT THE END
OF THIS CRISIS AS MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO-
POSITS BUT I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
YOU BUT IN LOOKING AT THE DAILY
NUMBERS THAT ARE COMING OUT OF
CALIFORNIA THE NOTION THAT WE
ARE OVER THIS IS PREPOSTEROUS.
THIS PROBLEM IS GOING TO
CONTINUE UNTIL WE HAVE A CURE.
A TREATMENT OR VACCINE NONE OF
WHICH SEEM TO BE ON THE HORIZON
SO AN ISSUE LIKE THIS ACTUALLY
DOES HAVE VALUE AND I WANT TO
THANK THOSE WHO PUT TOGETHER
THIS VERY UNUSUAL AND I THINK
ELEGANT SOLUTION. I DO HAVE
CONCERNS THOUGH BECAUSE IT IS A
NEW CONCEPT THE NOTION OFGOING
TILL TWENTY THIRTY FIVE I THINK
IS AN LEASE FOR ME. A DEAL
BREAKER GOING FORWARD I THINK
THAT'S WAY WAY WAY TOO MUCH
TIME SO MUCH CAN HAPPEN- BUT I
DO THINK THAT WE ARE ON THE
RIGHT PATH. AND SO I WILL
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT TODAY- I DO
THINK WE NEED TO BE REALISTIC
ABOUT WHAT IS TRANSPIRING WE'RE
ALL HOPING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S GONNA STEP UP WITH
CARES TO WORST MOTHER. GRAHAM
BECAUSE WE'RE RUNNING OUT OF
MONEY HERE AND PEOPLE ARE MAYBE
GO TO SUMMER GOING BACK TO WORK
BUT IF THIS TREND CONTINUES
HEARING CALIFORNIA. IT WOULD BE
MY- THAT WE WILL PULL BACK.
BECAUSE OUR NUMBER. PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOW INFECTED AND ARE GOING
TO THE HOSPITAL IN A REAL NICE
TO YOU AND ARE POTENTIALLY-
THREATENED WITH THEIR LIVES IS
INCREASING. DRAMATICALLY AND SO
TO THINK THAT WE ARE AT THE END
OF THIS IS TRUST ABSOLUTELY
MIND BOGGLING TO ME. AND I
THINK WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS TRY
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN KEEP
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES. AND AT
THE SAME TIME RECOGNIZED ARE A
LOT OF LANDLORDS OUT THERE. WHO
ARE NOT BIG LANDLORDS THEY'RE
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT OWN A DUPLEX
OR INHERITED SOMETHING THAT
THEY NOW RENT OUT AND I HAVEN'T
HEARD YET A DISCUSSION THAT
SHOWS THAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE
ANY KIND OF MORTGAGE
FORBEARANCE BECAUSE THAT'S SORT
OF THE OTHER PART OF THIS.
MORTGAGES ARE UNDER FEDERAL
CONTROL AND WE HAVEN'T SEEN
MUCH MOVEMENT THERE. BUT I DO
WANT TO EXPRESS MY THANKS FOR
THIS THINKING OUTSIDE THE BOX
BUT ALSO MY CONCERN GRANTED
IT'S A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM. BUT
WE HAVE TO BE REALISTIC ON BOTH
SIDES WHEN THIS PANDEMIC IS
GOING TO END WE DO NOT KNOW IT
IS BLOWING UP IN OUR FACES HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE. BUT WE WANT
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO STOP THEIR
HOME SO I COMMEND THE F. I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING. THIS MOVIE
GOING FORWARD BUT WANT TO BE
VERY CAUTIOUS- IN IN
EXPECTATIONS- THAT THERE'S A
SIMPLE SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM. THANK YOU A MAN
PRESENT THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON CENTER BORDERS. THANK
YOU I AGREE WITH. MY COLLEAGUE
FROM. SANTA BARBARA THAT THERE
ARE THREE PARTIES IN THAT A
PART OF THIS DYNAMIC GET YOUR
RENTER'S YOUR LANDLORDS HERE
LENDERS. THIS IS DEALING
PRINCIPALLY WITH THE FIRST
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THE SECOND.
NOT BE ABLE TO AT THIS POINT
ADDRESSED THE THIRD. A
PRACTICAL STANDPOINT I'M TRYING
TO WALK THROUGH THIS SO. WE
HAVE A LANDLORD. WHO HAS
TENANTS IN THE TENANTS ARE NOT
PAYING. SALANDER MUST FRONT
LOAD THE VALUE OF THE RENT TO
SATISFY HIS OR HER NOTE. I
THINK WE'RE IN AGREEMENT WITH
THAT. THE CREDIT WOULD NOT BE
ON A DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR BASIS.
AND PRESUMABLY THE LANDLORD
WOULD HAVE TO WAIT TO ACHIEVE
THE TAX CREDIT UPON THE TAX
RELEVANT TAX FILING PERIOD
LET'S JUST SAY APRIL. SO THE
LANDLORD CONCEIVABLY COULD BE
FRONT LOADING THE FULL VALUE
OF. THE RENT FOR THE PERIOD OF
TIME AND UNTIL THE CREDIT IS
ISSUED. AND THEN WE MOVE INTO
THE CREDIT SCENARIO WHERE IT
NOT ONLY WAS IT NOT DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR BUT IF THE LANDLORD THEN
WANTS TO FLOATED. BACK CREDIT
ON THE MARKET TREATED AS PAPER
AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT BEFORE.
WHOEVER Y PURCHASE IT. IS
GOING TO WANT A PROFIT SO LET'S
SAY IT'S TEN THOUSAND DOLLAR
CREDIT. IT'S GONNA HAVE TO BE
FLOOD ON THE MARKET FOR
SUBSTANTIALLY LESS THAN THAT
FOR SOMEONE TO WANT TO BUY IT.
SO THE LAND IS LOSING THE RENT
FOR A YEAR NOT ALL AND NOT ON A
DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR BASIS IS
GETTING A CREDIT AND WHEN THEY
FLOATED ON THE MARKET. THEY'RE
GONNA AT THE PLATE PAY A
PREMIUM FOR TO BE PURCHASED.
ARE THESE REASONABLE
REPRESENTATIONS OF THIS DYNAMIC
SO FAR. IS A QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR. WE KNOW IT UP. ALL
WITHDRAW THAT I THINK THE I
THINK THEY ARE REASONABLE. WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING. AM I
GUESS AND MY QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR IS THIS THROUGH THE
CHAIRED BY MAY. WIN WOULD WE BE
ABLE TO GET THE SPECIFICS ON
HOW EXACTLY DOES WORKS THAT. IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO MOVE ON
THIS. SENATE HAVE AIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT QUESTION IN
IN THE PROBLEM WITH YOUR
COMPOUND. QUESTION BUT YOU HAD
SOME PARTS OF IT WRONG THIS IS
A DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR CREDIT.
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU ENTER INTO
THE AGREEMENT IT'LL BE A DOLLAR
FOR DOLLAR CREDIT WHETHER YOU
DECIDE TO SELL IT ON THE MARKET
OR NOT- AND WHAT YOU CAN GET
FOR IT WILL DEPEND ON THE
MARKET. AND SO IF YOU IF YOU
HOLD ON. THEN YOU GET IT YOU
CAN USE IN THE FUTURE THAT
MEANS YOU'VE GOT THE FINANCIAL
ABILITY TO DO THAT. BUT IF YOU
CAN'T AND YOU NEED SOME CASH
NOW YOU SELL IT AND ON AND
RECEIVED A CASH BUT THEN YOU'RE
AT THE RISK OF THE MARKET JUST
JUST LIKE ANY OTHER PAPER
CREDIT. FOR PROBLEM PATIENT.
WORKING I'M THROUGH THE
TECHNICALITY AND IT WE JUST
SOME TIME DO IT AND SO WHEN
WILL WE HAVE THAT PROBABLY OVER
THE BREAK WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
GOING TO BE WORKING ON THIS AND
OBVIOUSLY REALLY NEED TO ANSWER
THESE QUESTIONS IN THE ASSEMBLY
IN THE SECOND HOUSE GONNA WANT
ANSWERS THEY'RE NOT BACK. TILL
THE END OF THE MONTH SO-
THEORETICALLY WE HAVE A MONTH
TO DO IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
ADMIRABLE THIS IS NOT EASY IN
NINETEEN YOU KNOW WANT TO GIVE
YOUR A PLOT IN CENTERED AS WELL
IN ORDER TO. EASY TO FIGURE OUT
THANK YOU THINK THE REPORTERS
JONES. FIVE ONE OF THE COMMENTS
IN THAT THE- ARE ARE. CALLING
FROM BARBARA OUT I NEED MEAN TO
COMMUNICATE THAT. I FEEL LIKE
WE'RE OUT OF THIS THE ENDING I
HAD A COUPLE OTHER MEMBERS OFF
THE FLOOR. SAY THAT THEY
THOUGHT THAT'S WHAT I SAID TO
SO. NO I DON'T THINK WE'RE OUT
OF THE KOBE SITUATION AT ALL-
AND WE DON'T KNOW HOW LONG
WE'RE GOING TO BE IN THIS
SITUATION I DIDN'T MEAN BY
SAYING TEMPORARY. WAS THAT IN
RELATION TO THE LENGTH OF TIME
THAT THIS BILL PROPOSES TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM. TEMPORARY
AND AT SOME POINT TIME I THINK
SOON BECAUSE- MEMBERS THE
INCIDENT WILL BE BACK WITH THE
PEOPLE ARE GOING BACK TO WORK
NOW. AND MORE MORE PEOPLE AS WE
PROCEED WILL BE GOING BACK TO
WORK AND WE'LL FIGURE IT OUT SO
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER JONES
MEMBERS SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THERE
CABALLERO YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS FOR THIS-
THIS REALLY ROBUST DEBATE I'VE
I APPRECIATED VERY MUCH LET ME
JUST GIVE YOU. SOME NUMBERS
THAT THAT WE GOT FROM- AND THE
DAM I HAVE WAY TOO MANY NUMBERS
HERE BUT SOME NUMBERS IN
REGARDS TO THE- WHAT TENANTS
ARE DOING NATIONWIDE AND- IT'S
HARD TO GET THIS. REAL TIME.
BUT THE ACCORDING TO
INFORMATION. THE MONTHLY
NATCHER NATIONAL SURVEY. ON
ONLINE RENTAL MARKET PLACE- IN
APRIL. 24% OF THE TENANTS
FAILED TO PAY ON TIME IN THIS
COURSE IS THESE ARE THE
LANDLORDS REPORTING INFORMATION
TWELVE MADE NO PAYMENT AND
1212% MADE NO PAYMENT 12% MADE
A PARTIAL PAYMENT IN MAY IT
INCREASED 31% FAILED TO PAY ON
TIME. 22% MADE NO PAYMENT AND
9% MADE A PARTIAL PAYMENT SO
WHAT THE SHOWS IS THAT T EVERY
MONTH IT'S GETTING A LITTLE
TOUGHER IN JUNE. 31% PER TO
FAILED TO PAY ON ON TIME 19%
PAYMENT AND 11% PARTIAL
PAYMENTS WE HAVE TEN SO BETTER
TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT THING
THEYJUST DON'T HAVE THE MONEY
AND WE HAVE. AN LORD ALLOWING
TENANTS TO MAKE PARTIAL
PAYMENTS BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT
IT'S A TOUGH TIME AND IT'S
BETTER TO PART OF THE MONEY IN
HAPPEN. WHAT IS IT. IT'S GOING
TO TAKE AWHILE TO RESULT ITSELF
THIS PANDEMIC IS NOW GOING AWAY
QUICKLY. AND THE DANISH. AS MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM SANTA BARBARA
SAID THAT WERE THAT THE NUMBERS
ARE ON THE RISE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT SOME OF THE ACTIVITIES
OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ENGAGING IN
ARE VERY VERY DANGEROUS AND ARE
LEADING. TO THE SPREAD OF THE
OF THE VIRUS IN EXPONENTIALLY
AND SO WHAT THIS MEANS IS THAT.
WHEN WE RECESS IN AUGUST WERE
NOT GOING TO BE THROUGH ALL OF
THIS AND WE NEED TO HAVE A
SOLUTION THAT'S GOING TO HELP.
TO STABILIZE THE RENTAL MARKET
TO HELP TENANTS AND TO HELP
LANDLORDS AT THE SAME TIME. WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORK. THERE'S
JUST ABSOLUTELY NO QUESTION
ABOUT IT BUT I WANT TO THANK.
THE WISE HEADS. IN THIS
ECONOMIC STIRBT STABILITY GROUP
FOR COMING UP WITH SOMETHING
THAT I THINK IS REALLY
INNOVATIVE AND IF WE DO IT
RIGHT COULD MAKE A TREMENDOUS
DIFFERENCE. IN OUR IN OUR
HOUSING CRISIS WHICH WE FACED
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. AND
MAY AND REALLY WHAT THE PURPOSE
OF THIS IS TO HELP US. TO
RECOVER FROM THIS PANDEMIC SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE VOTE TODAY TO ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR TO COVER I
THINK HONESTY BRADFORD WAS ALSO
CONCLUDED THAT GOES WITH YOU
CENTER BRADFORD YES I JUST WANT
TO ADD MY VOICE WANTED THAT.
CALLER FROM SALON DOES THE
JOINT AUTHORS THIS THING. AND
MEMBERS YOU'RE RIGHT THIS IS A
COMPLICATED. ISSUE WE'RE NOT
GONNA CANDY COAT THIS AND SAY
THAT WE HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS
HERE. BUT I WANT YOU TO
CONSIDER ONE THING WHAT IF WE
DIDN'T HAVE THIS PROGRAM. WHAT
IF WE CAN TRY TO PUT SOMETHING
TOGETHER IT'S TWO THINGS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE GUARANTEED IF.
AND FORECLOSURES WE SAW THAT
TWELVE YEARS AGO DURING THE
GREAT DEPRESSION HERE AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND WE SAW THE NUMBER
OF ADDICTIONS AND OF NUMBER FOR
CLOSURES THAT HAPPEN. THIS IS A
PLAN TO FIGHT AS WHOLE BUT- THE
STATE THAT ALL. THE REASON WHY
IT'S STILL SO MANY MOVING PARTS
YEAH STATE IN AS OUR STATED
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THIS
DESCRIPTION WERE HOPING WE
DON'T HAVE TO USE THIS. BUT
THERE THIS IS THE EIGHT FIFTY
ACT. TO PROTECT NOT ALL CAN.
AND THE LAND IT'S A- I CAN
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN. AT
LEAST. TAX CREDITS WILL WORK
BUT AND IF YOU DON'T HAVE IT
YOU HAVE ONE THING FOR SURE
THAT LANDLORDS WILL BE IN
FINANCIAL TROUBLE THIS
GUARANTEES HERE SHE SOME KIND
OF FINANCIAL SECURITY MOVING
FORWARD AGAIN THIS IS NOT
EXCUSE EIGHT TENANTS FROM
PAYING THE RENT WE'RE GOING TO
ENCOURAGE BILLS STAND IT YU
CAN PAY IF NOT A 100% OF THE
RENT SOME PORTION OF THEIR
RANK. SO THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO PROVIDE A SAFETY NET
FOR BOTH THE TAP- TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS IT'S A WORKING
PRODUCT PROGRESS WITH AS MY
COLLEAGUES STATED AS WE STATED
IN A WORKING GROUP THE WORKING
POOR PERSON WE'RE COMMITTED TO
GET THIS RIGHT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR RIVAL. SAID REMEMBER TO
BE CLEAR THEY ARE JOINED. THAT
IS WHY THEY BOTH CLOSED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
BATES NO WELL I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I HAVE A I CHIANG.
DALLY DODD I TORONTO I GALGIANI
I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I HILL I HUESO TADA I
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA I
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S NO
MITCHELL. I MONNING. I MORE
LOCK MORALE NO NIELSEN. PAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN HI I'M BURKE
AYE AYE WACO SKI. I WIENER I
WILK NOW PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS FOR AGES.
CHIANG. NO VALLEY NO GROWTH.
HUESO MORE LOCK. NIELSEN. I
KNOW SEVEN. PAGE TWENTY SEVEN
KNOWS EIGHT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE SENATOR
SKINNER ARE YOU READY. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TEN EIGHTY FIVE BY SENATOR
SKINNER AND ACTUALLY DID A
HOUSING CENTERS CAN. THANK. YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS. MY
GLASSES ON AND LET THEM FOG UP
THE- CALIFORNIA'S DENSITY BONUS
LAW WAS THREE IT IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT TOOL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ENACTED TO HELP
INCENTIVIZE MARKET RATE HOUSING
PROJECTS TO INCLUDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS. NOW IT'S A VERY
GOOD LAWN AN IMPORTANT LAW BUT
IT IS NOT BEING USED AS
EXTENSIVELY AS CLEARLY THE
INTENT WAS LESS THAN HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE APPROVED PROJECTS THAT
UTILIZE THE DENSITY BONUS END
OF THOSE THAT HAVE THERE'S ONLY
BEEN ONE OR TWO PROJECTS WITHIN
THOSE JURISDICTIONS. THE
OBSTACLES INCLUDE THAT
INCLUSIONARY RULES THAT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE ALSO
ADOPTED DON'T ALWAYS SEE WITH
THE DENSITY BONUS LAW WHICH
THEN LEAVES BUILDERS OPTING NOT
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
DENSITY BONUS AND THEY END UP
BUILDING THEIR PROJECT ONLY
WITH MARKET RATE UNITS. THE
PURPOSE OF SB TEN EIGHTY FIVE
IS TO IMPROVE OUR DENSITY BONUS
LAW SO THAT WE ACTUALLY
INCREASE ITS USE AND MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS GET
BUILT. SO WHAT SB TEN EIGHTY
FIVE DOES IS IT MODIFIES THE
DENSITY BONUS SO THAT IN THE
HIGH COST HOUSING AREAS LIKE
THE BAY AREA. IT CAN BENEFIT
MIDDLE INCOME RESIDENTS WHO
LITERALLY CANNOT AFFORD EITHER
RENTAL OR PURCHASE UNITS IN
THAT AREA ART MIGHT. IT ALSO
INCREASES THE ALLOWABLE DENSITY
BONUS FOR THE VERY LOW INCOME
UNITS FROM 35% TO FORTY
PERCENT. BANDED INSURERS THAT
IF A PROJECT AFFORDS ITSELF OF
THE DENSITY BONUS. IT DOES NOT
IN THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS A
FORD A HOUSING IMPACT FEE THAT
THAT IMPACT FEE IS NOT CHARGED
ON THE AFFORDABLE UNITS THAT
THE PROJECT INCLUDES BECAUSE
THAT'S GOING TO DOUBLE COUNTY.
IT ADDITIONALLY HELPS INSURERS
THAT DENSITY BONUS CAN BE USED
FOR STUDENT HOUSING PROJECTS
AND I THINK THAT WE OF ALL.
EXPERIENCED AND SEEN THE DATA
ON HOW- HOUSING CHALLENGE
STUDENTS ARE ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND HOW MAY WE ARE NOW FINDING
LIVING IN VEHICLES NINE FORTY
B. AND FOR ONLY. THE DENSITY
BONUS WITH OUR HOW YOU CAN BILL
ACT AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI HI
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS EIGHT. BELL
I FORGES. BRADFORD I HAVE ITEM
I CHIANG. DALLY DODD I DRAWS A-
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO FIVE- TADA I JACKSON
AYE JONES NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
I MELINDA'S. MITCHELL BY
MORNING FIVE WARLOCK MERLE.
NIELSEN PAN FIVE PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH. I RUBIO I SKINNER AYE
STERN. NUMBER FIVE MY CASTING
HI WIENER. FIVE WILK HI PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
BATES. FOR JUST. CHIANG DALLY.
GLAZER GROWTH. MELENDEZ. MORE
LOCK AYE MORRELL. NIELSEN STERN
HI GLAZER I'D- SIZE THIRTY
KNOWS WANT THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS REMOVING THE FILE ITEM
THIRTY SENATOR HER TATO. VERY
GOOD MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL ELEVEN- THREES
BY SENATOR HER TADO AN ACT
RELATING TO JOB TRAINING CENTER
TACO. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I RISE TO PRESENT SB ELEVEN
ZERO THREE RELATED TO
INCREASING LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS ACCESS TO HOPE HI
ROADS JOB TRAINING PROGRAMS.
THIS BILL WILL ACQIRE THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO SUPPORT
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS
COMPLETING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING PROGRAMS.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE
BOARD TO DEVELOP ADDITIONAL
EMPLOYMENT PARTNERSHIPS TO
ADDRESS DISPLACEMENT OF WORKERS
INCLUDING FARMWORKERS.
DISCONNECTED YOUTH AND YOUTH AT
RISK DESCRIPTION FROM
EMPLOYMENT. DURING. OUR CURRENT
RECESSION IT IS CHRIS. WE LEARN
FROM OUR LAST RECESSION DOUBLE
DOUBLE COMMUNITIES ARE THE
FIRST BECOME UNEMPLOYED.
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS
HAVE A PROVEN IMPACT ON
APPROVING UPWARD MOBILITY AND
ALSO INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR CHILDREN LIVING IN POVERTY
WHEN THEY BECOME ADULTS.
HOWEVER ACROSS CALIFORNIA MANY
WORKFORCE TWENTY PARTICIPANTS
ARE NOT ABLE TO COMPLETE THEIR
JOB TRAINING PROGRAMS DIGITAL A
LACK OF AFFORDABLE
TRANSPORTATION OR LACK OF
AFFORDABLE CHILD CARE. I'VE
SEEN THIS FIRSTHAND. TEEN
MOTHERS STRUGGLING TO PURCHASE
FORMULA FOR THE BABIES. AND
WORKERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO
PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE
PRIORITIZING THESE POPULATIONS
DURING THE CURRENT RECESSION
WILL HELP LIFT FAMILIES OUT OF
POVERTY AND INTO PROSPERITY AND
IT STARTS HERE WHAT SB ELEVEN
ZERO THREE. AMENDMENTS WERE
TAKEN MEDI NARAL THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PROGRAM
TO THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD ALLOW FOR
LEHMAN OF HIGH ROADS TRAINING
PROGRAM PARTNERSHIPS TO LINE
WITH LOCAL REGIONAL LABOR
MARKET DEMANDS. AND INCLUDE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW
CONSIDERATION OF LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND QUALIFIED
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS. NOW MORE
THAN EVER DURING  PANDEMIC
INDUCED RECESSION SB ELEVEN
ZERO THREE WILL HELP PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE ASSISTANCE TO
UNEMPLOYED AND UNDEREMPLOYED
WORKERS TO PURSUE JOB TRAINING.
STOP THE CYCLE OF MOLD CHEN.
POVERTY AND PURSUE THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER HURTADO
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT BECAUSE THE QUESTION
FOR THE AUTHOR SIR TOTAL WE
TAKE A QUESTION YES PLEASE
PROCEED A VERY NOBLE COSTS ARE
THEN I AM VERY VERY ARE LEADING
TO SUPPORT A IT IS ABOUT THE
COSTS AND I THINK ON OUR
ANALYSIS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN GRANTS
THAT WOULD NEED TO BE
APPROPRIATED A COULD YOU
ADDRESS SLAPS- I'M ASSUMING
THAT THAT. MODIFY THAT TO I
WOULD HATE FOR IT TO BE THE
THING THAT SOMEHOW STOP ME THE
ARE INTERNET AND THE AUDIENCE
ABOUT WHAT IS REALLY GOOD IN
THIS LEGISLATION. CENTER TOGGLE
THERE SHE WILL GOAL IS TO THE
TO. SIR FOR THOSE FUNDS TO.
MAKE THEM OF. FOR THIS FOR THIS
BILL BUT I THINK THAT THERE'S
LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL THAT THAT
STILL IS GOOD FOR A LOT OF
CALIFORNIANS THAT WE CAN STILL
CONTINUE TO APPLY MOVE FORWARD
EVEN WITHOUT FUNDING. THANK YOU
A MAN PRESENT ON MY OWN TIME I
DO PLAN TO SUPPORT THIS I THINK
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS. FOR OUR
YOUNGER GENERATION AND THOSE WE
ARE CAPTIVE IN POVERTY THAT
THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
GET THE- AND I WILL SHARE WITH
YOU WHEN I WAS A SOCIAL WORKER
THE MOST FRUSTRATING THING IS
THAT. PROGRAMS WERE NOT
AVAILABLE. WAY TO PEOPLE I IN
THE INDEPENDENT SO THIS IS A-
GREAT. CHARLIE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENT. CENTER BORDERS.
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
CONGRATULATE THE ALL ON THIS
THE NORM I MY WANNA. EXACTLY
WE'RE ALL THIS MONEY WOULD GO.
BUT I THINK BECAUSE HAVING
SERVED ON THE RIGHT REGIONAL
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT BOARD.
THAT TYING THIS TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SEEKING THE
SKILL SETS THAT GO ALONG WITH
REGIONAL WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAMS- IT HAS PROVEN TO BE
EFFECTIVE AND I'M PROUD THAT
YOU MOVE THIS THIS FOR TO BE
GLAD TO SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU.
YOU CENTER BOARD MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THEN CENTER
TOPPING MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
MADAM FOR THEM I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA. I ATKINS.
BATES AYE WELL. I FOR JUST. AYE
BRADFORD. HI COME BY ADAM I
CHIANG I DALLY NO DODD I DORADO.%
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO BY- TADO I
JACKSON. I JONES NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S. NO
MITCHELL. MINING I MORE LOCK
MORRELL NO NIELSEN. PAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO.
SKINNER I STERN FIVE ON BURKE I
WHITE HOUSE SKI. I WIENER AYE
WILK HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS GROVE. MITCHELL
MORE LOCK. NIELSEN. RUBIO HI
FIVE THIRTY ONE KNOWS FOR.
MAJOR KERRY'S MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING OUT ON TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY ONE SENATOR HILL. ONE
MOMENT. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
LIST THE LIFT THE CALL ON FILE
ITEM FORTY THREE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. EIGHT BRADFORD.
GALGIANI HELLO. HER DAUGHTER.
MCGUIRE RUBIO. STERN AYE AMBERG.
SIZE TWENTY ONE KNOWS ELEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM THIRTY
ONE SENATOR HILL MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN FIFTY NINE
BY SENATOR HILL AND AFTER
LEADING TO WORKERS COMPENSATION
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE A
BILL THAT SEEKS TO PROVIDE
NECESSARY MEDICAL CARE. FOR OUR
FRONTLINE WORKERS FIGHTING
COVERT NINETEEN AS WE ARE ALL
PAINFULLY AWARE COVER NINETEEN
HAS RAVAGED OUR STATE. WELL
MUCH MEDIA ATTENTION HAS BEEN
ON THE ECONOMIC CHALLENGES OF
THIS PANDEMIC THE SCALE OF
HUMAN SUFFERING IS
UNPRECEDENTED AND DIFFICULT TO
OVERSTATE. THIS IS WHY I TEAMED
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOM DALY
CHAIR OF THE IN. COMMITTEE TO
AUTHOR A WORKERS COMPENSATION
PRESUMPTION COVERT NINETEEN
BILL. THIS BILL WILL EXTEND A
COVERT NINETEEN REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION TO BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR WORKERS
CURRENTLY. AS WRITTEN THE BILL
CODIFIES THE GOVERNOR'S RECENT
EXECUTIVE ORDER ON COVERT
NINETEEN AND WORKERS
COMPENSATION. IN THE WEEKS TO
COME OUR OFFICES WILL WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORK FOR
DRESSING WORKERS COMPENSATION.
AND COVERT NINETEEN FOR THE
FUTURE THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I HAVE THREE
RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR HILL
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SITTING IN HERE YES OKAY
I'VE GOT SENATOR DOLLY AND THEN
CENTER MORE LAW CENTER DOLLY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- WHEN
NO GOVERNOR THE GOVERNOR ISSUED
THE- EXECUTIVE ORDER IN SIXTY
TWO TWENTY- MY EMAIL BOX WITH
UP BUSINESSES WERE OPERATION WE
SHOULD BE TO EMPLOYERS CANNOT
BE AND SHOULD NOT BE HELD
LIABLE FOR WHAT THEIR EMPLOYEES
MAYBE DOING OUTSIDE OF THE JOB.
THAT MAY HAVE ACTUALLY
CONTRIBUTED TO TESTING THE FOR
THE COR VIRUS- EXAM WE JUST HAD
AN EXAMPLE OF A TENNIS PLAYER
WHO CONTRACTED. OVER NINETEEN
BUT WE HAVE LOTS OF VIDEO BAR
HOPPING AND ALL KINDS OF OTHER
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE LONG AND
FAR AWAY FROM THE REVIEW OF. A
PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT AND SO FOR
THIS REASON- I OPPOSE THIS
PRESUMPTIVE- THIS PRESUMPTION-
ON EMPLOYERS MASS FOR NO VOTE
ON SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
CENTER MORE LOT. SENATE OLLIE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I ALSO RISE IN
OPPOSITION YOU KNOW THIS IS A-
A BIG REACH FOR THE GOVERNOR TO
USE AN EXECUTIVE ORDER. TWO
METAL IN WORKERS COMP I WANTED
TO SHARE WITH YOU THERE WAS A
TIME IN MY BUSINESS THAT I PAID
FORTY TWO CENTS FOR EVERY
DOLLAR. I PAID TO AN EMPLOYEE
FOR WORKERS COMP AND NEVER HAD
A SINGLE CASE. FILED AGAINST MY
BUSINESS. QUITE FRANKLY WAS
BECAUSE I OWNED CATTLE. AND
CATTLE FOR SOME REASON DRIVE
YOUR WORKERS COMP UP. AND SO
AFTER WE FIGURED OUT THE AMOUNT
THAT THE CATTLE OR CAUSES WE
GOT ALL THE CATTLE BUSINESS.
AND WE DROPPED OUR WORKERS COMP
TO ABOUT TWELVE CENTS FOR EVERY
DOLLAR THAT WE PAID OUR
EMPLOYEES. NOW THOSE SCENARIOS
ARE SET IN PLACE BECAUSE
THERE'S RISK AND THE RISK IS
SET BY THE AMOUNT OF THE AMOUNT
IS SET BY THE RISK IN THIS CASE
THERE HAS TO BE PROOF OF WHERE
THE RISK IS WHERE'S THE WRIST
THE WRIST IS IT IS IT MY JOB OR
IS IT WHERE THE EMPLOYEE TAX
COVE IT. WHAT'S SAYING IS
SENSUALLY HERE IS THAT. NO
MATTER WHAT. NO MATTER WHERE
YOU CONTACTED OR YOU ARE YOU
GET SICK YOU'RE GOING TO PUT IT
OFF ON THE EMPLOYER. IT'S GOING
TO DRIVE A THAT'S A COST OF
DOING BUSINESS IS GOING TO
DRIVE UP HERE. THE PROOF. THE
CONTACT JUST LIKE YOU WOULD
WITH ANY OTHER CASE THAT YOU
WOULD BE FILED AGAINST YOUR
BUSINESS. FOR THE RISK OF. OF A
OF THE JOB THAT YOU DO. SO
ARBITRARILY LETTING THE
GOVERNOR DO EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
PUT ANOTHER COSTS ON TO MY
BUSINESS AND YOU CAN'T BROUGH.
WHERE THAT RISK IS JUST ABSURD.
AND WE SHOULD NOT BE VOTING TO
RATIFY THIS IN THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION FOR THOSE REASONS I
URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER DOLLY MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE CENTER
HELD ME CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THIS IS THE
GOVERNOR'S. THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER REVOLVED AROUND
THOSE HIGH RISK WORKERS- WE'RE
SOCIAL DISTANCING IS PRETTY
MUCH IMPOSSIBLE THOSE POLICE
OFFICERS FIREFIGHTERS NURSES.
WITH WAREHOUSE WORKERS AND
OTHERS AS THE CENTRAL WORKERS
THAT WOULD HAVE IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION. AND FOR THEM THE
PURPOSE OF THIS LEGISLATION IS
TO WORK WITH OUR COLLEAGUES IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP AND
CRAFT. A MEASURE THAT ILL BE
LIMITED AND IT WILL BE SUNSET
IN AT SOME POINT IN TIME IN THE
FUTURE BUT IT'S NECESSARY. THAT
WE PROTECT THOSE WORKERS WHOSE
WORKERS THAT ARE ESSENTIAL TO
OUR ECONOMY ESSENTIAL TO OUR
VERY EXISTENCE AS A STATE. THAT
THEY ARE PROTECTED FROM THAT-
THE INEVITABLE THAT MANY OF
THEM ARE STRUGGLING WITH TODAY
SO ASK FOR LIVE- COLLEAGUES AND
THIS BILL WILL BE WORKED ON.
LAND AREA AND WILL BE A OF A I
THINK AND FEEL AT THE END OF
THE DAY SOMETHING THAT WE WILL
ALL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT. AS IT
WOULD PROTECT THE WORK IN
PROTECT OUR EMPLOYER GOING
FORWARD PAST RIVAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR HELLO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCH OR I AT. I BATES.
NO BELL I FORGES NO BRADFORD I
HAVE A- I CHIANG NO DALLY NO
DODD I DORADO. HI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI GROWTH.
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO. HI TADO HI JACKSON.
JACKSON. JONES NO LEYVA I
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S NO
MITCHELL. I MONNING. HI MORE
LOCK NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO
HAN. PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO
I SKINNER. I STERN HI I'M BURKE
I Y. CASKEY. HI WIENER I WILK
NOW PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. JACKSON I PAN. FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT NOS ELEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY FOUR SENATOR BATES MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR BATES AND ACTUALLY IN
THE STATE HIGHWAYS SENATOR
BATES THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
HI AND MEMBERS OF. BRING TO YOU
A BILL THAT SEEKS TO
MEMORIALIZE THE DECISION MADE
BY THE TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR
BOARD ON MARCH TWELFTH TWENTY
TWENTY BY DELETING AN ALIGNMENT
OF STATE ROUTE TO FORTY ONE.
LINE SOUTH OF SO PARKWAY AND
EAST OF THE CITY OF MISSION
VIEJO DOING MALES WILL PROMISE
THAT IT WILL NOT RUN THROUGH
THE CITY OF SAN CANADIAN
APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN HUNDRED.
ACRES OF FEDERALLY AND CITY
PROTECT OPEN SPACE. BUT BEFORE
I CONTINUE ON MEMBERS I WANT TO
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT SHOULD THIS
BILL MOVED TO THE ASSEMBLY I DO
INTEND TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS
TO ENSURE THAT THE TENTH
TRANSPORTATION BORDER AGENCY.
CAN ACT DEVELOP IMPACT FEES
WHICH WILL PROVIDE THE- THREE
AND THAT IS S. TO CONTINUE THE
PLOT TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS.
THE RELEASE. SENATE
TRANSPORTATION CHAIR BY NOT
TAKEN THESE. ARE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR BUT INTO TAKE THEM AT THE-FIRST IN THE ASSEMBLY POLICY
COMMITTEE. FOR HIS
RECOMMENDATION THAT THEY CAN
HAVE A FULL VETTING IN POLICY
DISCUSSIONS TO VET THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED SINCE
THIS. ALMOST UNANIMOUS VOTE IN
THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. THE BILL IS
NECESSARY TO REMOVE FROM THE
BOOKS A STATE HIGHWAY ALIGNMENT
THAT STATE AND REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES HAVE
DECIDED TO ABANDON. DUE TO ITS
WAS DIPPING ENVIRONMENTAL
ECONOMIC CULTURAL AND SOCIETAL
COSTS AND I'D LIKE. MADAM
PRESIDENT FINE NAME. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THIS IS FROM THE
PRESS RELEASE FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR
AGENCIES FOLLOWING THEIR MARCH
TWELFTH DECISION AFTER A ROBUST
FOR YOUR PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT
AFTER EFFORT WE ARE HAPPY WE
HAVE A SOLUTION THAT REPRESENTS
BOTH THE COMMUNITY'S INPUT IN
TECHNICAL ANALYSIS. THE LOS
PRODUCTOS PARKWAY EXTENSION
WILL RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
REGIONAL MOBILITY IMPROVEMENT
SAID CRISTINA SHEA CHAIR WOMEN
AND- MAYOR OF IRVINE ARE
APPROVAL MEANS THAT ALL OTHER
ALTERNATIVES INCLUDING ALL
ROUTES THAT CONNECT DIRECTLY TO
INTERSTATE FIVE ARE REMOVED
FROM CONSIDERATION IT. IS TO C.
A.'S EFFORT TO EXPAND THE TWO
FORTY ONE TOLL ROAD. THE BILL
IS NECESSARY TO MOVE FROM THE
BOOKS THE STATE HIGHWAY
ALIGNMENT THAT STATE AND
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION OR READ
THAT SORRY BUT THE POINT IS
THAT THE CURRENT ALIGNMENT FOR
THE TWO FORTY ONE IS ABOUT FOUR
MILES EAST. OF THE CITY OF SAN
COMMITTEE IN IT WOULD TAKE
STATE LEGISLATION TO MOVE IT
BACK ANYWAY ALSO NOW IS THE
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE THERE'S
BEEN SO MUCH CONTROVERSY SO
MUCH STUDY ABOUT HOW TO ADDRESS.
SO THIS IS. CAN IT DOES MAKE
SENSE TO REMOVE OUR- FROM OUR
STATE OF ROADS AND HIGHWAYS-
THIS ALIGNMENT CANNOT YOU WILL
NOTICE IN YOUR ON. COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS IT SPECIFICALLY SAYS
IN MAY I READ THAT. WITHOUT
OBJECTION ENACTING THIS
PROPOSAL IN THE CURRENT
LEGISLATIVE SESSION DOES NOT
PROHIBIT FUTURE LEGISLATION
FROM AGAIN ALTERING TO FORTY
ONES BOUNDARIES WITHIN THE
STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM AND THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED BECAUSE
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO ONLINE AT
THAT TRANSISTORS. ANTI THE GOOD
NEWS IS THE- ARE DOES NOT
PRECLUDE THE REGION FROM MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE TRANSPORTATION
CONGESTION ALTERNATIVES THAT
HAVE WIDE SUPPORT- THAT. OF THE
EXTENSION OF LOS FOR DRUMS
PARKWAY THIS WAS ALL DECIDED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL WHY DO WE HAVE
A STATE INVOLVEMENT CLEARLY ARE
CALTRANS ACTUALLY WAS VERY MUCH
A PART OF THIS EFFORT. IN MAY I
READ AGAIN WITH THE- CAN FIND
IT IN HERE. IT SAYS CALTRANS IN
COORDINATION WITH FOOTHILL
EASTERN TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR
HAS DECIDED TO DISCONTINUE
PROJECT DEVELOPMENT CALTRANS IS
THE NEED A LEAD AGENCY WILL
THEREFORE NO LONGER ADVANCE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT STATEMENT
ON THE SOUTH COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION FOR RELIEF
EFFORTS TO SO SPECIFICALLY THE
STATE IS STEPPING OUT AND I
THINK THIS WILL CODIFY OR
MEMORIAL BY STAFF. I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTAN BUT WHAT DOES
REMAIN IS WHAT DO WE DO TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO OPPOSE
THE BILL THAT THEIR ISSUES ARE
ARE TO BE ADDRESSED YOU ARE NOT
FINANCIAL BUT TO DO THAT IN THE
SENATE COMMITTEE OF TIME
BECAUSE OF THOSE DO COME
FORWARD TO STARTED TAKING A
LOOK AT WHETHER WE WERE
ACTUALLY GONNA HAVE THE FUNDING
THAT SO IMPORTANT TO. MEET ON
THE GLOBAL WERE SET WITH US
SIGNIFICANT FOUR YEAR OF LOCAL
INPUT THE STATE ENTER HERE AND
IT IS THE ADDRESS WITH THIS I
VERY VERY CA. TO CAN'T CONTINUE
MY EFFORT TO IT POLICY ISSUES
THREE I KNOW. BACK END TO BE
APPRECIATED IF YOU COULD DO
THAT THANK YOU MUCH- DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE SENATOR BILL. THIS
THIS ISSUE HAS BEEN. DISCUSS
AND YOU KNOW AT DIFFERENT
LEVELS IN- THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE I THINK FOR FIVE
YEARS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
AND IT KEEPS BUBBLING UP. SO
I'M PRETTY HAPPY. THAT THE GOOD
SENATORS TO IS DECIDED TO.
MEDIATE AND HELP WORK OUT AND
WORK OUT A SOLUTION LET'S GIVE
HER A CHANCE TO DO THAT. AND I
ORIGINAL VOTE ON THIS SO I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS PROCEED
IF IT IF SHE'S NOT SUCCESSFUL
JUST GONNA COME BACK AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN SO. I
I'M PLEASE SHE'S GOING TO WORK
WITH ALL HER COLLEAGUES- LET'S
TRY TO GET THIS WORKED OUT. SO
WE CAN COME UP WITH A GOOD
SOLUTION STORAGE AND I VOTE ON
THIS THANK YOU CENTER BILL
CENTER MORLOCK. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT ALSO BEING OF.
SENATOR FROM ORANGE COUNTY I
LIKE TO PROVIDE A LITTLE COLOR
OF CENTER FROM SANTA CLARA
CERTAINLY ADDRESS ONE OF THE
ISSUES AND IF. THE AUTHOR CAN
FIX THIS PROBLEM THEN WILL EVER
WORK WITH THE SUNNIS AND THE
KURDS AND TAKE CARE OF THAT AND
SO WELL BUT- THIS IS A ONE OF
THOSE CLASSIC NAME BE BILLS-
AND I'M JUST REALLY CONCERNED
BECAUSE HE- AGENCY THAT. THIS
BILL IS DIRECTED TOWARDS IS
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. ORANGE
COUNTY HAS THIRTY FOUR CITIES
ONLY ONE OBJECTS TO THE ROAD
IMPROVEMENTS NEEDED FOR THE
ENTIRE COMMUNITY BY RUNNING
PLEA IT'S THE CITY THAT IS
ASKED FOR THIS PARTICULAR PIECE
OF LEGISLATION- SANTA MANY. AND
SECOND MANY. ACTUALLY ACTUALLY
NEEDS SOME KIND OF ROAD SYSTEM
THE MOST OF OUR CITIES IN SOUTH
COUNTY. WHEN THEN THE
SUPERVISOR BATES TONIGHT SIR ON
THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE WORKED.
AGGRESSIVELY TO FIND ANOTHER
REDUNDANT ROAD OUT OF SANTA
MANY IF YOU IF YOU VISITS AND
COMMITS A COASTAL TOWN THE FIVE
FREEWAY GOES THROUGH IT- AND
THAT'S THE ONLY. ROAD AT THE TO
LEAD TIME IN AND OUT OF THAT
PARTICULAR CITY. AND SO WE WERE
ABLE TO WORK- TO EXTEND. LOW
PADA ROAD WHICH DEADENDED BY
ONE OF OUR MAJOR LANDFILLS AND
SO WE WERE ABLE TO GO THROUGH
OUR LANDFILL AND CONNECT SO.
THE RESIDENTS OF SANTA MANY
COULD HAVE A REDUNDANT WAY TO
GET OUT OF THEIR CITY WHY WHY
HAVE A REDUNDANT WAY TO GET OUT
OF SAN COMMITTEE BECAUSE JUST
SOUTH OF SAN FOR MANY- IS THE
BORDER OF ORANGE COUNTY AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND AT THE VERY
TOP OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY. THE
BILL HE- US THE YES SENATE FREE
NUCLEAR CHEN. STATION WE CALL
IT SONGS AND IT HAS BEEN DE.
BUT THE FUEL RODS ARE STILL
THERE. SO IF THERE WOULD BE ANY
KIND OF ACCIDENT WE HAD ONE
ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO WERE ROD.
FELL WHEN THEY WERE MOVING IT
BUT IF WE HAD ANY KIND OF
ACCIDENT OR TSUNAMI LIKE
FUKUSHIMA. IT WOULD BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THE RESIDENTS OF
SANTA MANY. THEN STORMONT. RID
THE TO HIGHWAYS TO ROW WILL ONE
FREEWAY IN ONE ROAD TO GET OUT
IN AN EMERGENCY. SO FOR CLOSING
ON THE TWO FORTY ONE EXTENSION.
YOU KNOW MAY REDUCE TRAFFIC
NOISE FOR THE CITIZENS OF SAN
COMMITTEE BUT IT COULD BE A
DEATH KNELL IF THERE WERE
REALLY A AN EMERGENCY. SO I
DON'T MEAN TO BE AN ALARMIST
BUT- YOU KNOW THE LAST FEW
MONTHS NOTHING'S GONNA SURPRISE
MANY MORE WHAT COULD POSSIBLY
HAPPEN. BUT COLLEGE THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY ORANGE
COUNTY OPPOSES THIS BILL- ED
AND THIS. ALL THE CITY'S OPPOSE
THIS BILL- AND I'M I'M JUST
REALLY CONCERNED THAT. WE DON'T
ENCOURAGE FRUSTRATED
MUNICIPALITIES TO COME TO
SACRAMENTO TO. SETTLE DISPUTES-
WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO ENCOURAGE
THE BUILDING MORE HOUSING- A
COMPONENT OF THE STRATEGY IS TO
DISCOURAGE NIMBY ISM AND
APPROVING THIS BILL WOULD SEND
A SIGNAL THAT MAYBE WE DON'T.
SUPPORTING THIS NOT IN MY
BACKYARD APPROACH SO COLLEAGUES
BUT WE SHOULD NOT DO THINGS THE
INDEPENDENT JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES AGENCIES THAT THEY
ARE NOT ASKING FOR OR- FOR THAT
THEY ACTUALLY OPPOSE. AND IN
WITH THAT. THE KEEPING SHORT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. A NOBLE
THANK YOU SENATOR MORE LIKE
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THIS PUTS ME IN AN
AWKWARD SITUATION IS I HAVE TO
AMAZING A REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
THAT ARE BOTH FROM THE SAME
AREA OF ORANGE COUNTY. BUT I DO
KNOW THAT MY GOOD COLLEAGUE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND THE
SENATE REPUBLICAN LEADER
AMERICA'S IS COMMITTED TO
WORKING FOR A SOLUTION. FOR
THIS PROBLEM AS IS HER NATURE
THAT WE KNOW SHE ALWAYS
OPERATES IN THIRTY MINUTES
COMMITTED TO HAVING HEARD IN
THE SIMPLY POLICY COMMITTEE
SEEKS TO ADDRESS THE OPPOSITION
CONCERNS REGARDING THE PLAN FOR
THE DEVELOPMENTALLY IMPACT
THESE TO COMPLETE THE
TRANSPORTATION PROPERTY TRIED
PROJECT IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS THAT WILL RESULT. THESE
ARE CONCERNS- THAT WERE RAISED
AFTER THE BILL WAS FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE ENTER
DESERVING A FULL REVIEW WHICH
HE HAS PLEDGED TO GIVE HER FULL
DISCUSSION AND I JUST SAID IN
MY OPENING REMARKS AND HER
DEMEANOR IS TO SOLVE PROBLEMS
AS A LEADER EMERITUS REPUBLICAN
AT HIS. THAT WAS OUR GOAL IS TO
SEE BLOOM SO A I HOPE THAT WE
CAN ALL COME AND HELP ME SOLVE
THE CITY IS WITH ON LET SHE.
FOR MANY YEARS. DRESSED IN. AND
I. THANK YOU SENATOR GROW
MEMBER SEE NO TO OR DEBATE.
SENATOR BAYH PLEASE CLICK CLOSE.
LET ME RESPOND TO THE NIMBY
COMMENT BECAUSE IT'S ABSURD
THERE IS NOT A CURRENT
ALIGNMENT THE TRANSVERSE AS SAN
CLEMENTE TO DEVELOP ONE IS A
HUGE PROCESS SAM COMMITTEE HAS
BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
LOWER PART EXTENSION THROUGH
THEIR COMMUNITY BY WORKED ON
THAT FOR THE ENTIRE EIGHT YEARS
THAT I WAS ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. I SERVED ON THE
TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR AGENCY
FOR FIFTEEN YEARS WE ATTEMPTED
TO GET THE TWO FORTY ONE TO
FOLLOW WHAT IS CURRENTLY IN THE
STATE STREE FOR HIGHWAYS CODE
WHERE IT- YET- IS ON THE
EASTERN BOUNDARY OF
UNINCORPORATED AREA OF ORANGE
COUNTY THERE IS NOW AYE
CONSERVATION EASEMENT. THAT HAS
BEEN APPROVED BY THE
TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR AGENCY
WHICH ESSENTIALLY BLOCKS- THE
TWO FORTY ONE BREAKS DEAN SOUTH
OF MANY WHICH IS CURRENTLY IN
THE STATE STREET AND HIGHWAYS
CODE SO WHAT THE PROCESS WOULD
BE IS TO CREATE A NEW ALIGNMENT
ATTACHING ATTY ITS TERMINUS NOW
IT ALSO CAN BRING THAT THROUGH
SAN CLEMENTE. ARE OPEN SPACE
AND I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
THE FEDERAL OPEN SPACES
PROTECTED THERE'S ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED AND SOME MAKERS THAT
WAS A CAST IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE. THE ONE THAT IS
CURRENTLY IN THAT PATHWAY IN
OUR THANKS FOR MANY THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE NEW ALIGNMENT TO BE
A DRIVEN THROUGH IT WAS PUT
THERE IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN SO
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT JUST
HAPPENED LIKE ALL MY GOSH STOP.
THEY HAVE BEEN VERY MUCH A PART
OF THE TCA THEY HAVE BEEN ON
THAT BOARD AND THEY VOTED FOR
THIS PARTICULAR SOLUTION WHICH
BY THE WAY IS SIGNIFICANTLY
BETTER IN TRANSPORTATION
CONSCIOUS CONGESTION RELIEF FOR
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY THE BEEN
NUMERAL TRAFFIC STUDIES TO
PROVE THAT. THAT IS WHY THE
BOARD VOTED TO MOVE OFF THE
CURRENT ALIGNMENT AND MOVE OVER
TO THE LOS FOR DRYNESS
EXTENSION WHICH BY THE WAY
CONNECTS TO BUKHARA WHICH TAKES
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TRAFFIC
NORTH AND SOUTH OF THE I FIND.
IN I CAN SHOW GOOD COLLEAGUES
ORANGE COUNTY YOU'D LIKE LOOK
AT THOSE TRAFFIC STUDY BECAUSE
FRANKLY. THAT'S THE DAY THAT WE
USE TO MAKE THE CITY. ON
CONGESTION RELIEF PROJECTS AND
THE ONE THAT'S IN THIS BILL
THAT MEMORIALIZES THAT USE THE
VERY BEST TO ADDRESS ALL THOSE
EMERGENCY EVACUATION ISSUES.
AND CERTAINLY RESOLVE THE
ISSUES REGARDING THE
ENVIRONMENT SO I URGE VIRGIN
AYE VOTE JUST GIVE ME A CHANCE.
AND I WILL TRY TO DO THE BEST
JOB IN IF WE DON'T IT WON'T BE
BACK HERE. AT LEAST OF THIS
YEAR I THINK THAT THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE OUR DEAN
OF THE SENATE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION. THAT IT VERY
CLEARLY IF WE DON'T RESOLVE IT
IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO COME
BACK THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
URGING NINE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA. ATKINS AYE BATES I
FELL FIVE FOR JUST. FIVE
BRADFORD I HAVE A YELLOW.
CHIANG DALLY I DODD I TO RISING
I GALGIANI I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ.
I GROWTH HI HERTZBERG HI HILL
NO WAY SO NO TADA. I JACKSON.
JONES I LEYVA. LEYVA NO MCGUIRE.
MELENDEZ MITCHELL FIVE MONNING
I MORE LOCK NO MORAL. NIELSEN
BY HAND. PORTANTINO AYE ROTH HI
RUBIO. SKINNER STERN NO NUMBER.
WHITE HOUSE SKI. WIENER NO WELL.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN ARCHULETA. CUT
BY ADAM I CHIANG. JACKSON
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S HIGH
MORALE. PAN RUBIO. SKINNER
NUMBER. WHITE HOUSE GAVE I
TWENTY FOUR NO SIX THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO SENATOR
STERN. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE BY SENATOR STERN
AN ACT RELATING TO ANIMALS.
SENATOR STERN THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS BILL
ADDRESSES BOTH THE A PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE AND A AND A
CONSERVATION ISSUE AT THE SAME
TIME DEALING WITH WILDLIFE
TRAFFICKING ISSUES- THAT IMPACT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT
BUILDS ON A INITIATIVE THAT
MANY OF US VOTED FOR A FEW
YEARS BACK- THAT DEALT WITH
TRAFFICKING OF ENDANGERED
ICONIC SPECIES. COMING FROM
TROPHY HUNTING ABROAD- BUT THIS
THIS UPDATED VERSION REALLY
RESULTS FROM THE RESEARCH WE'VE
BEEN DOING IN WILDLIFE
TRAFFICKING WITHIN OUR OWN
STATE AND WITHIN. THE DOMESTIC
UNITED STATES AS WELL AS FROM
ABROAD- THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
RISKS OF ZOO NORDIC
TRANSMISSION AND INVASIVE
SPECIES- INTERVENTION IN OUR
ECOSYSTEMS IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEMS THAT WE THINK. ARE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
NEED STRONGER REGULATORY
AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE LOOK AT
AND CRACKED DOWN ON- NOT
EVERYTHING IS ALWAYS ABOVE
BOARD IN THIS SATE- AND SOME
OF THE BLACK MARKETS IN. BOTH
TROPHIES ANIMAL PARTS AS WELL
AS- EXOTIC SPECIES THAT REALLY
DO POSE A RISK- TO HUMAN
HEALTH- IS VERY REAL AND IT MAY
NOT BE OBVIOUS TO EVERYBODY BUT
IT'S OUT THERE- I HOPE THAT. WE
CAN BUILD ON OUR PROGRESS THAT
WE MADE A FEW YEARS BACK- AND
TEN YOU TO PUSH FORWARD AND
STOP IN THE STORAGE OF WILD
TRACK. THEY ARE SO. DON THIS
SPEECH WE HAVE A NATURE DEEPLY
I IN THIS MOMENT AND I THINK-
IT SENDING US A MESSAGE WHETHER
WE CHOOSE TO LISTEN OR NOT IS
UP TO US RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RIVAL THANK YOU CENTER STERN
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN OUR TO LET ALLEN
AYE ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES.
BELL GORGEOUS NO BRADFORD.
CABALLERO CHIANG HI DOLLY NO
DODD. I DURAZO HI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I GROW NO
HERTZBERG. HI HILL FIVE WITH SO.
FIVE TADO. I JACKSON I JONES NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ
NO MITCHELL. FIVE MONNING FIVE
MORE LOCK MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO
HAN. PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH I
RUBIO. SKINNER FIVE STERN I
UMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WIENER.
FIVE WILK HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES. WELL I
BRADFORD. BECAUSE I ADAM I MORE
LOCK NO HAN. RUBIO HI BUT AS
TWENTY NINE NEWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY THREE SENATOR
UMBERG MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL ELEVEN NINETY
SIX BY SENATOR UMBERG AND
ACTUALLY TO PRICE GOUGING SEN.
SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS- DURING THE COURSE IS
PANDEMIC MOST CALIFORNIANS OF
STEPPED UP AND HELP THEIR
NEIGHBORS THERE'S A FEW THAT
HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE TO PRICE
IT OUT WITH THIS BILL DOES IS
THIS BILL CODIFIES THE
GOVERNOR'S- EXECUTIVE ORDER ALL
ADDS PANDEMIC OF ONE OF THE ONE
OF THE MERSEY CONDITIONS THAT-
TRIGGERS ISSUES CONCERNING
PRICE GOUGING OF IT ALSO. IF
YOU ARE A MAJOR PRESS GALLAGHER
IF YOU PRICE GALLOPS MORE THAN
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS YEAH YOU
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR A WHILE BLUR
POTENTIALLY IF ONLY. THERE ARE
CONCERNS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS ARE WITH
RESPECT TO HOW WE DECIDE HOW WE
ALLOCATE HELD A BILL CODIFIES.
THE TEN THOUSAND DOLLAR PRICE
RANGE- THAT WILL BE ADDRESSED
IN THE ASSEMBLY BUT WHAT WE'RE
COMMITTED TO DO IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT OVERHEAD COSTS AND LABOR
COSTS ARE INCLUDED. SO THAT
INCREMENTAL SOME THAT WOULD-
POTENTIALLY EXCEED TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IS A IS A IS A FAIR
DETERMINATION I REGION I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG CENTER
CHIANG. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I STAND AS A PRO CO
AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE WHICH
WOULD PREVENT THE- TERRIBLE
PRACTICE OF PRICE GOUGING FROM
TAKING PLACE. DURING THIS-
GLOBAL PANDEMIC WHEN SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY AND SIMPLY. TRYING
TO SURVIVE THIS SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO PAY EXORBITANT AMOUNTS FOR
ESSENTIAL ITEMS SUCH AS MASS
HAND SANITIZER. IS DISINFECTANT
WIPES ETCETERA I'VE ACTUALLY
HEARD THAT THERE WAS A- HARDEN
A VAGUE SELLING FOR TEN BUCKS
IN MY DISTRICT. OUR
CONSTITUENTS DO NOT DESERVE TO
BE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF DURING A
PANDEMIC AND I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES TO
SUPPORT THE MEASURE TODAY I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR OFTEN THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG
MEMBERS FOR THE DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
NONE ST NUMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU I ORIGINAL
VOTE THANK YOU SIR MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. I FELL FIVE FOR JUST
AYE BRADFORD I CUT BY ADAM I
CHIANG I DALLY. I DODD HI THERE
I WASN'T. I GALGIANI I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG
I HILL HI HUESO. I TADO HI
JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S I
MITCHELL. I MONEY I MORE LOCK
FIVE BOROUGH. HI NIELSEN AYE
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN HI
I'M BURKE. I Y. CASKEY AYE
WIENER. I WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. JONES. FIVE
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE ONLY
ON THE FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR
CENTER MCGUIRE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL ELEVEN
NINETY NINE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT. SENATOR MCGUIRE.
HAPPY FRIDAY MADAM PRESIDENT
AND GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA FACES A TERRIFYING
NEW REALITY WHEN IT COMES TO
THE SIZE AND SCOPE AND CANDIDLY
pADDITION TO THE TENS OF
BILLIONS OF INSURANCE CLAIMS
OVER A HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT
LIVES WERE LOST TWO FIRES.
DURING TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
IN THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
SEASON ALONE ACROSS THIS GOLDEN
STATE THERE ARE AN ESTIMATED
THREE POINT SIX TO FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION HOMES IN THE WILD
IN URBAN INTERFACE ACCORDING TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH. BASE ON
WILDFIRE RISK BASED ON WILD
FIRE RISK MODELS INC FIRE DATA
MORE THAN ONE MILLION HOMES IN
THAT. ARE I THEIR VERY. FIRE
RISK AREA IN AFFORD IN AVAIL IS
WE- INCREASINGLY IN MORE
CHALLENGING TO OBTAIN FOR
AVERAGE MIDDLE CLASS
CALIFORNIANS IN THOSE
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE ON FIXED
INCOMES APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY. THOUSAND OF
OUR NEIGHBORS HAVE BEEN NON
RENEWED FROM THEIR INSURANCE
COMPANIES BETWEEN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
RESIDENTS AND COMMUNITIES
AFFECTED BY FIRES BETWEEN
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SITE 10% INCREASE IN
NON RENEWALS RESULTING IN
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
LOSING THEIR HOME INSURANCE
WHICH MEANS THEY CAN NO LONGER
SELL THEIR HOME. IF THEY CAN'T
SECURE RESIDENTIAL INSURANCE SB
ELEVEN NINETY NINE WILL STAB
WISH A NEW COMMISSION ON
HARDENING. LED BY MEANS
COMMISSION WHICH WE RESPONSIBLE
FOR DEVELOPING DATA DRIVEN IN
SCIENTIFICALLY SOUND BEST
PRACTICES FOR BOTH HOMEOWNERS
IN COMMUNITIES TO REDUCE THE
RISK. OF LOSS FROM WILDFIRES
YOU KNOW THE COMMISSION ON HOME
HARDING WILL ESTABLISH A TIERED
SYSTEM A STANDARDS FOR FIRE
PREVENTION OF INDIVIDUAL HOMES
THE STATE TO INCLUDE VARYING
LEVELS. OF HARDENING INCLUDING
STANDARDS FOR FLYING NUMBER
RESISTANCE IN FOR FLAMING HEAT
RESISTANCE TO INCENTIVIZE
HOMEOWNERS. TO TAKE THE STEPS
THESE TERRORISTS IN THESE TEARS
APPEALING TO RECOMMEND. IN IT
IT IS FOR. ARCHERD CATION. I
WILL SAY MATTER HER. THE GOOD
CHAIR AS A SENATE TO HOUR TO
SAY THING YOU TO THE CHAIRMAN
HAVE BEEN WORK ON THIS ISSUE
FOR A NUMBER OF MONEY. BUT SHE
NIGHT OF TO TAKING AMENDMENTS
THE SIM TO ADDRESS HER CONCERNS
WHICH WILL REMOVE THE AUTOMATIC
POLICY RENEWALS IN THE BILL.
AND CLARIFY THAT INSURERS MAY
CONSIDER THE WORK OF THE
COMMISSION MAY CONSIDER THE
WORK OF THE COMMISSION WHEN
SETTING RATES AND IN. A SHOWING
INSURANCE ADDITIONALLY AGREED
UPON AMENDMENTS WILL ENSURE THE
COMMISSION PUBLISHES ALL THEIR
WORK IN RESEARCH USED TO
SUPPORT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
AGAIN BUT NOT A PRESIDENT WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE- RICH
CHAIR OF INSURANCE FOR HER
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS BILL. LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUE OUR WORK
TOGETHER IN THE ASSEMBLY BUT
PRESENT WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER MCGUIRE CENTER GROVE DID
I SEE YOUR FLAG UP. OKAY PLEASE
RECEIVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT DO YOU KNOW WHEN THE
WHEN THE AUTHOR STARTED OFF
THAT. WHEN HE WAS SAYING THAT
YOU KNOW THIS- THIS STATE HAS.
HAS SEEN A SCOPE OF OVER
REACHING AND DEVASTATION RIGHT
ANYWAY TO WILD FOR AS I THOUGHT
HE WAS GONNA SAY GOVERNMENT SO
THAT THREW ME FOR A LITTLE BIT
OF A LOOP. BUT I RISE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL AND THE
REASON WHY. SO I MEAN YOU CAN
CALL IT SELF CENTERED.
SELFISHNESS OR WHATEVER BUT I
LIVE IN A COMMUNITY WHERE WE
LIVE- ABOUT EIGHT MILES FROM
TOWN EIGHT MILES FROM TOWN OUT
ON A CREEK AND THERE'S PROBABLY
FORTY FIVE HOMES OUT THERE.
EACH TIME HAS FIVE TO TEN TO
TWENTY ACRES DEPENDING ON AND
THEY'LL BACK UP AGAINST A
CREEK. ALL OF THIS COULD NOT
GET INSURANCE RENEWAL FOR HOME
AND OUR PROPERTY THIS YEAR.
BECAUSE OF THE POOR POLICIES
PASSED OUT OF THIS BODY- AND
NOT TO MENTION THE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE NORTH OF US THE TWENTY
MILE PEOPLE AWAY IN A THIRTY
MILE PEOPLE AWARE OF THE PEOPLE
THAT LIVE IN MOUNTAIN
COMMUNITIES. LIKE TO HAVE TO
PEE OR GLENDALE OR KERN VEIL.
THEY LIVE IN THE LAKE AREA MY
PHONE AT THE OFFICE IS RINGING
OFF THE HOOK BECAUSE THERE'S
NOT ANY INSURANCE AVAILABLE. I
THINK THAT INSURANCE THAT
ALLOWS YOU TO GET THE STATE IS
AFFORDABLE THERE'S NO WAY IT'S
AFFORDABLE AND THAT WAS A
SUBSTITUTION POLICY THAT YOU
GUYS PASSED OUT OF HIS BODY
ALL TO OFFER AN ALTERNATIVE FOR
INSURANCE. CAN TAKE THAT OUR
PERSONAL INSURANCE WENT FROM
THIRTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR
WITH RANCH PROPERTY HORSES.
BECAUSE ALL THAT IS A LIABILITY
SHE- TO MAKE SURE YOU GO. WITH
AROUND. EIGHT OR- UNDER ALL OR
IS. TO SET. FIVE DOLLARS A- AND
THERE IS LEADING TOWARD A S.
WHO IS ELDERLY. WHOSE PROPERTY
WE HELP HER TO MAKE. A SHE IS
REALLY STRUGGLING TO PAY THAT
INTO COSTS. WHAT'S REALLY SO
ABOUT THIS IS THAT THIS IS NOT
A SO. TO ANY OF THOSE PROBLEMS
THAT RULE AMERICA IS FACING NOW
I KNOW IT'S DIFFERENT WHEN YOU
LIVE- RIGHT NEXT DOOR TO A FIRE
STATION IN YOUR STACKED IN
STAFF IMPACT AND HOUSING IN
MOST OF THESE- CITY AREAS BUT
THAT'S ALSO- BEEN PROVEN
BECAUSE OF THIS CHO SITUATION
THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT VERY SAFE
WE LIVE. AT ALL SO I WOULD JUST
ASK AUTHOR HE WOULD RECONSIDER
AND JUST REALLY ADDRESS THIS-
ISSUE IT IS NOT THE INSURERS
PROBLEM INSURERS RIGHT POLICIES
BASED ON RISK AND OF POLICIES
ARE GOING TO BE PASSED THIS
BUILDING. REQUIRE INSURERS TO A
GREAT AMOUNT OF RISK WELL.
INCREASE THE COST OF POLICIES
AND SO POLICIES LIKE THIS THE
INTEREST WILD- OR BY RATES LIKE
THIS IN THIS INCREASE OR NOT
THE INSURERS FAULT IT'S THE
FAULT OF THIS BODY FOR PASSING
LEGISLATION DOESN'T ALLOW. AN
INJURES FOR A FAIR COMPETITIVE
MARKET NAY URGING OVER. THANK
YOU SENATOR GROCER MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TO A
COLLEAGUE SAID TO DO ARE
TRUNCATED SESSION. THIS BILL
WAS NOT REFERRED THE SENATE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE WHERE I
WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE HAD
SOME FUN- DEALING WITH IT- I'VE
I FULLY UNDERSTAND APPRECIATE
WHAT THE AUTHORS ATTEMPTING. TO
DO AND I ADMIRE. HIS TENACITY
AND HIS LEADERSHIP IN THIS
AREA. BUT ITS USE IN THE FREE
MARKET. THAT DETERMINES BEST
PRACTICES IN PRICES AND YOU
KNOW IT'S INSURANCE ACCORDINGLY
SO I. I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED
THAT MAYBE WERE INVERTING THE
PROCESS. HOME HARDENING IS A
RELATIVELY NEW SCIENCE WITHOUT
ESTABLISH STANDARDS. BUT WE RE
DONE A LOT OF THINGS- LIKE
DISCOURAGING WOOD SHAKE ROOFS
AND- PLANTING TRIBES NEAR
HOMES- THERE'S BUT THERE HASN'T
BEEN A LOT OF NEW AND
REVOLUTIONARY. ACTIVITY I WOULD
THINK IT WOULD BE COMING. FROM
THE PRIVATE SECTOR IN THE
INSURANCE COMMUNITY AND I. LOOK
FORWARD TO THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WILL BE A PROVIDED- WINNING
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE BUT AT
THIS POINT I'M A LITTLE. WELL
HAS TENTS ON. SB ELEVEN NINETY
NINE THANK YOU MATTER PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SAN MORE SENATOR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT BOB
AS CHAIR OF THE SENATE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE I ALSO YOU
KNOW I AGREE THAT THIS CLUB IN
NINETEEN DID NOT GIVE US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR THIS. BILL
IN THE INSURANCE COMMITTEE BODY
I HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
DILIGENTLY WITH. SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND I REALLY WANT TO
THANK THEM FOR COMING TO THE
TABLE WE'VE BEEN. REALLY ENGAGE
TRYING TO ENSURE THAT THIS BILL
DOES THE RIGHT THING FOR
CONSUMERS AND- I DON'T THINK.
ANYONE'S MORE DEDICATED. THEN
HE HAS TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
DONE RIGHT AND SO I WANT TO
THANK THEM FOR THE AMENDMENT
THAT HE HAS TAKEN. TO ALLOW US
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS.
CLEARLY WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO IN THIS AREA. AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S DATA
DRIVEN IN THAT WE HAVE THE
INFORMATION WE HAVE. SO AGAIN I
REALLY WANT TO THANK HIM OUR
GOAL ULTIMATELY IS TO ENSURE
THAT EVERYONE HOUSE AFFORDABLE.
AND AVAILABLE INSURANCE AND
THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT GETTING
DROP OR NON RENEWED AND SO I
WANT TO THANK THEM FOR TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE.
SECTION THREE PNC AND MAKING A
MESS TO SECTION THREE EIGHT SO
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS THANK. THE CENTER
RUBIO CENTER JONES. I JUST
WANTED TO- RISE IN- BACK UP
THE- CHAIR OF THE INSURANCE AND
THE MEMBER- FROM ORANGE COUNTY
OF INSURANCE WE DID HAVE A GOOD
CONVERSATION ALL THAT DIDN'T GO
THROUGH COM- INSURANCE AND WE
DID HAVE A GOOD CONVERSATION IN
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION AND I
KNOW THAT THE CHAIR OF
INSURANCE HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR I LOOK FORWARD TO
THOSE CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS
I'LL BE VOTING NO TODAY BUT-
HOPEFULLY BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
WHEN IT COMES BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU SENATOR
JOHN SENATOR WIENER. I THANK
YOU AND PRESIDENT I SUPPORT
THIS BILL I DO JUST WANT TO
BRIEFLY RESPOND TO CENTER FROM
BAKERSFIELD TO- MADE A
REFERENCE TO HOUSING DENSITY OR
STOCK COMPACT HOUSING ISSUE FOR
TO HAVING SOMETHING TO DO WITH
THE PANDEMIC- THAT IS
COMPLETELY FACTUALLY INACCURATE
I'M HAPPY TO SEND HER THE
BINDER OF STUDIES. HAVE SHOWN
THAT HOUSING DENSITY HAS
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO DO WITH A
SPREAD OF CARBON NINETEEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER WIENER
MEMBER SCENE OF FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER WE
US SENATE MCGUIRE PLEASE CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MATTER
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I WANNA.
TALK ABOUT WHAT THE STATE IS
BEEN THROUGH AND I'LL BE BRIEF
MADAM PRESIDENT. AND WHAT I SEE
IN MY OWN BACKYARD. LIKE THE
GOOD SENATOR WHO REPRESENTS
PARADISE THE NORTH BAY- THE
SENATE CISCO BAY AREA'S BEEN
DEVASTATED BY WHILE IN FIRE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN.
WE'VE LITERALLY LOST THOUSANDS
THOUSANDS OF HOMES. IN DOZENS
OF LIVES HAVE BEEN LOST. WHAT
WE REALIZE IS THAT THE BUILDING
CODE WHILE IT IS IMPROVE THE
SAFETY THE SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIANS WHICH BY THE WAY
WERE PASSED BY THIS AUGUST BUT
HERE YEARS AGO. WE KNOW WE NEED
TO GO FURTHER. FOURTEEN OF THE
TWENTY LARGEST WALLIN FIRES IN
OUR STATE'S HISTORY FOURTEEN OF
THE TWENTY HAVE HAPPENED IN THE
LAST DECADE. TWELVE OF THE
TWENTY MOST DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES IN THIS STATE HISTORY
HAVE HAPPENED IN THE LAST
DECADE. THE LARGEST WHILE THEN
FIRES THOUGH WHEN WE TAKE A
LOOK AT HOW TIME IS SPEEDING UP
BECAUSE OF THE ISSUE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE HAS ACTUALLY HAPPENED IN
THE LAST FIVE YEARS. WE CAN
CONTINUE TO BE HOSTAGES AND
STICK OUR HEAD IN THE SAND AND
SAY THAT WE DO NOT NEED DATA
DRIVEN POLICIES. IN SCIENCE THE
BETTER DRIVER DECISION MAKING
OR WE CAN SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THIS BILL IS BY THE WAY MODELED
AFTER WHAT FLORIDA DID WIN THE
INSURERS PULLED OUT OF THE
FLORIDA MARKET BECAUSE
HURRICANES. IT DEVELOPS A HOME
HARDENING COMMISSION. THAT
DEVELOPS THE STANDARDS TO HELP
KEEP CALIFORNIAN SAFE IF YOU
WANT TO SAVE LIVES TODAY. YOUR
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THIS ISN'T
ABOUT POLITICS IT'S ABOUT
SAVING LIVES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NINE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES NO WELL I
FOR JUST. NO BRADFORD I HAVE A
I CHIANG NO DALLY. DODD BY
TORONTO I GALGIANI I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE HILL HI WITH SO. I TADA HI
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA HI I
MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ. MITCHELL
FIVE MONNING I MORE LOCK. NO
MARROW NO NIELSEN. PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN HI I'M BURKE
HI MY COUNTY AYE WIENER AYE
WILK. CENTER CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLY.
GLAZER I GROWTH NO MELENDEZ. NO
NIELSEN. WILK. FIVE TWENTY NINE
KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES
BUT IN GENERAL THE SENATE WE'RE
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM THIRTY
FIVE ITEM THIRTY FIVE CENTER
STERN IS PREPARED PRESENT MADAM
SECRETARY GOOD AFTERNOON. CAN
YOU PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
TWELVE FIFTEEN BY SENATOR STERN
AND ACTUALLY INTELLECTUAL CITY.
GOOD MORNING ACTUALLY MISTER
STERN GETTING AHEAD OF
OURSELVES THERE I APOLOGIZE
CENTER STERN THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE PERCENT SB TWELVE FIFTEEN
WHICH IS PART OF THOSE SENATE'S
WILDFIRE PACKAGE. REALLY
DESIGNED EMPOWER US TO ATTACK
THESE PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
OFFS- BEFORE THEY BECOME AN
ISSUE WE UNDERSTAND THAT- THE
WILDFIRES TRIGGERING THE NEED
FOR THIS- THE ENERGIES ASIAN OF
THE GRID MORE AND MORE BUT WE
THINK THERE'S MORE WE CAN DO TO
EMPOWER NOT JUST COMMUNITIES
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BUT ALSO
THE UTILITIES THEMSELVES. AS
WELL AS THIRD PARTIES TO GET IT
OUR CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE IN
OUR CRITICAL CIRCUITS THAT
THEIR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. OUR HOSPITALS ARE
WATER DISTRICTS A LOT OF THE
DIFFERENT PLACES WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT- TO HOPEFULLY MAKE THE
GRADE MORE STABLE- WITH CLEAN
ENERGY IN THE PROCESS- AND TO
BE MORE STRATEGIC ABOUT IT SO.
THIS BILL IS REALLY AN EFFORT
TO HELP KEEP THE LIGHTS ON- AND
REALLY INVOLVED AGREED TO BE
RESILIENT. IN THIS- WILDLY
WILDFIRE AREA AND THEN WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE
A THANK YOU SO MUCH SINISTER
AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE LET'S
SEE IF WE HAVE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. LAST CALL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. HEARING SEEN NINE MINUTE
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA. HI
ATKINS. AYE BATES NO BELL AYE
FORGES. BRADFORD CABALLERO I
CHIANG. DALLY NO DODD. I DORADO
I GALGIANI. I GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG HI HILL I WITH SO. I
TADO I JACKSON I JONES. NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S
NO MITCHELL. HI MONNING I MORE
LOCK. ZERO NO NIELSEN NO PAN. I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I RUBIO. I
SKINNER. FIVE STERN I AM BURKE
I Y. CASKEY AYE WIENER AYE WILK
NO THIS CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
LARGEST. BRADFORD. CHIANG MORE
LOCK. I TWENTY KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX
SENATOR- BURKE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWELVE
TWENTY BY SENATOR UMBERG AN
ACTUAL LEADING TO PEACE
OFFICERS SENATOR UMBERG. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY WHEN
WE SEE AN IMPERFECTION IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
IDENTIFIED IN AND CORRECTED AS
WE KNOW OUR SYSTEM IS NOT
PERFECT. BUT HERE'S A PROBLEM
THAT THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
HAVE REYES THAT NEEDS TO BE
CORRECTED. FORTY YEARS AGO OR
MORE THAN FORTY YEARS AGO IN A
CASE CALLED BRADY VERSUS
MARYLAND. THE US SUPREME COURT
SAID THAT A DEFENDANT. HAS A
RIGHT TO KNOW. INFORMATION AS
TO A TESTIFYING OFFICER THAT
MAY IMPEACH HIS OR HER
TESTIMONY SO FOR EXAMPLE. IF AN
OFFICER HAS SOMETHING IN THEIR
PERSONNEL FILE THAT SAYS THEY
FILED A FALSE REPORT. THEN
DEFENSE COUNSEL AND DEFENDANT
HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW THAT. WELL
THAT'S BEEN THE LAW SINCE
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE AND THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE IS THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE
REQUIRED TO IDENTIFY OFFICERS
BY NAME BADGE NUMBER. WHO HAVE
SOMETHING IN THEIR FILE THAT
MAY INDICATE THAT A DEFENSE
COUNSEL OR DEFENDANT MAY WISH
TO USE IT IN TERMS OF
IMPEACHMENT ON CROSS
EXAMINATION FOR OTHER PURPOSES
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO. A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY DOESN'T
COMPILE THIS INFORMATION. AND
DOESN'T ALERT THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AS THE NAMES IN BATCH
NUMBERS THEN THAT INFORMATION
IS NOT COMMUNICATED TO THE
DEFENSE AND THE RESULT IS THAT
THE DEFENDANT MAY NOT KNOW IT.
THE DEFENDANT MAY NOT KNOW IT
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO USE THAT
INFORMATION. IN THEIR OWN
DEFENSE. NOW DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT FAIRNESS OF
COURSE AND JUSTICE OF COURSE.
BUT THE OTHER ISSUE IS IT THAT
INFORMATION COMES TO LIGHT
LATER ON. THE DEFENDANT MAY
HAVE A RIGHT TO HAVE ANOTHER
TRIAL BECAUSE THE ORIGINAL
TRIAL. WASN'T FAIR THEY DIDN'T
HAVE THE INFORMATION THAT WAS
REQUIRED. SO WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IT SAYS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES YOU'VE GOT TO PRODUCE
THIS INFORMATION. NOT THE
INFORMATION BUT THE NAMES AND
BADGE NUMBERS THIS ATTORNEYS
THEN- IF REQUESTED PROVIDED TO
THE DEFENSE AND THE DEFENSE CAN
ASK A JUDGE TO LOOK OVER THAT
PERSONNEL FILE TO SEE. WHETHER
OR NOT THAT'S INFORMATION THAT
MIGHT BE RELEVANT. TO THE
DEFENSE IN THE ACTION THAT'S AT
ISSUE SCOTT PITCHES MOTION. NOW
ALSO IN THIS BILL IS A
PROVISION THAT SAYS THAT IF AN
OFFICER IS ON THIS LIST KNOWN
AS THE BRADY LISTS THAT THAT
OFFICER BEFORE HE GOES ON OR
SHE GOES ON THE THEY'RE
NOTIFIED AND THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY BY THE WAY
THAT'S THE PROCESS THAT EXIST
IN PLACES LIKE ALAMEDA COUNTY
SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY- LOS
ANGELES VENTURA SAN MATTEO
COUNTY THAT'S THE PROCESS THAT
EXIST TODAY IT SIMPLY GIVES THE
OFFICER AN OPPORTUNITY. TO TALK
TO THE DISAPPEARING IT DOES NOT
DELAY THE TRIAL AND IN FACT IT
DOESN'T EVEN BECAUSE THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY NOT TO
DELIVER THAT INFORMATION TO
DEFENSE COUNSEL THAT'S ALL IT
DOES- SO MEMBERS ARE GINGIVAL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
UMBERG MEMBERS MOVED TO
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
JONES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I WANTED TO- JUST-
SPEAK BRIEFLY- ANDERSON ARMOR
DID A GREAT JOB OF IDENTIFYING
THE AMENDMENTS IN THE BILL.
THAT ALLOW AN OFFICER TO I HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT INFORMATION AND-
AND TALK TO IT SO I WILL I
VOTED NO IN APPROPRIATIONS BUT
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY AND THANK US IN OUR OWN
BURKE FOR WORKING WITH THE
STAKE HOLDERS AND- MAKING A
GOOD BILL SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER JONES SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- WE HEARD THIS BILL
IN PUBLIC SAFETY. AND THERE
WERE SOME- IMPORTANT-
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WERE NOT
SUPPORTIVE. I WE TRIED TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS
I KNOW ADDITIONAL CONCERNS WILL
BE ADDRESSED AS THE BILL MOVES
TO THE ASSEMBLY. BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT. SB
TWELVE TWENTY. IS A NARROW LEAD.
CRAFTED EFFORT TO CODIFY THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT COURT
DECISION. THAT RULED THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES CAN SHARE
INFORMATION ONE OFFICER
MISCONDUCT WITH DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S WHICH SOME AGENCIES
ARE NOT DOING. N. B. WHAT THE
BILL DOES IS AUTHORIZES LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO KEEP
LIST OF OFFICERS WHO IN GAUGE
SORRY. READING MY NOTES WHO
ENGAGED IN MISCONDUCT IN
REQUIRES THOSE AGENCIES TO TURN
OVER THE LIST TO THE D. A.'S
WHICH GIVES THE DA'S THE
ABILITY TO KNOW WHEN TO TURN
OVER INFORMATION TO DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS ABOUT AN OFFICER'S
CONDUCT THAT MAY SHED LIGHT ON
THE CASE AND POTENTIALLY ON THE
DEFENDANT'S INNOCENCE. AND FOR
THOSE REASONS BY SUPPORTED THE
BILL IN OUR COMMITTEE AND IT
DID PASS COMMITTEE THOUGH I DO
EXPECT IT TO BE FURTHER WORKED
ON AS IT MOVES OVER TO THE
ASSEMBLY. AND SO I RECOMMENDED
I GO THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER
MEMBERS SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. NUMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU-
COLLEAGUES. I SHOULD ADD ONE
OTHER ELEMENT TO THIS BILL ONE
OTHER ELEMENT ISTHAT IN
ADDITION TO SUSTAIN MISCONDUCT
IT ALSO REQUIRES THAT. IF AN
OFFICER HAS A SUSTAIN FINDING
OF GROUP BIAS OF GROUP BIAS
THAT THAT ALSO WOULD GO IN THE
FILE AND THAT ALSO WOULD BE
DELIVERED TO DEFENSE COUNSEL-
FOR TO THIS IS THE IS THE MARK.
PROVISION HE MIGHT NOT BE HAPPY
ABOUT THAT BUT BUT IT IS
APPROPRIATE THAT THE DEFENDANT
KNOW IF AN OFFICER HAS A
FINDING. IN THEIR FILE OF SOME
SORT OF GROUP BIAS HIRED AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR UMBERG BEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. ATKINS FACE FIVE
WELL I FORGES. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. I CHIANG. I DALLY I
DODD. I DORADO. I GALGIANI I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ. I GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO. I
TADO I JACKSON AYE JONES I
LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S.
MITCHELL MONNING. MORE LOCK. I
MORRELL. NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. I RUBIO. I
SKINNER FIVE STERN HI NUMBER HI
I WEIGH CASKEY I WIENER AYE
WILK AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA ATKINS AYE
FORGES I BRADFORD. MELENDEZ
MITCHELL. MONNING. ZERO FIVE
THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN SENATOR
DODD LIKE TO SEE RIGHT THERE
PERFECT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR DODD AND
ACTUALLY TO HEALING ARTS CENTER
DOLLARS RESIDENT MEMBERS THAT'S
B. TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN SEEKS TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO CARE FOR
CHILD BIRTH BY ALLOWING
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIVES TO
PRACTICE WITHOUT THE PERMISSION
OF A PHYSICIAN. SB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN PROMOTES T. BASE
CARE WHICH HAS BEEN SHOWN TO
IMPROVE SAFETY AND QUALITY OF
CARE. SUPERVISION JUST DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE ANYMORE IT'S NOT THE
FIGHTING CALIFORNIA STATUTE IT
DOES NOT REQUIRE THE POSITION
TO BE PHYSICALLY PRESENT
EXAMINE THE PATIENT. SIGN A
REVIEW ANY CHARTS OR OVERSEE
PATIENT CARE IN ANY WAY.
SUPERVISION FORCES NURSE
MIDWIVES TO CONCENTRATE IN
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS WERE
PHYSICIANS PHYSICALLY PRACTICE
THEREBY REDUCING ACCESS
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL COUNTIES
IN LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES.
THERE IS A DIRECT LINK BETWEEN
RACE ACCESS MATURITY OUTCOMES
IN MINORITY COMMUNITIES
IMPROVING ACCESS TO NURSE
MIDWIFERY CARE HAS BEEN NAMED
BY LEADING ORGANIZATIONS SUCH
AS THE MARCH OF DIMES IN THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION AS
ONE OF THE MOST INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES IN ADDRESSING RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. LASTLY I WISH TO POINT
OUT THE CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF
ONLY FOUR STATES IN THE NATION
THAT STILL REQUIRE PHYSICIAN
SUPERVISION IN ORDER FOR NURSE
MIDWIVES TO PRACTICE. BUT
MINUTES TAKING IN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SATISFY CONCERNS WERE RAISED BY
THE MEDICAL ASSOCIATION A AT
ANY COST. THE LANGUAGE PLACES
SAFEGUARDS THE BILL WHILE
ALLOWING CERTIFIED. NURSE
MIDWIVES TO FULLY A FULLY
INDEPENDENT PRACTICE WITHIN
THEIR LICENSE SCOPE THESE
AMENDMENTS CODIFIED TEAM BASED
CARE THAT RESULTS BOTH IN IN
BOTH IMPROVED OUTCOMES IT
ACCESS FOR WOMEN. CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT FORTY SIX OTHER
STATES HAVE ALREADY DONE SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN WILL REMOVE
THE POSITION PERMISSION TO
PRACTICE LAW FOR NURSE MIDWIVES
IT ALSO THE POINTS WERE TRUE
COLLABORATIVE CARE IS BETWEEN
PHYSICIANS AND MIDWIVES. IT
CREATES THE FOUNDATION FOR
CONSULTATION COLLABORATION AND
SEAMLESS TRANSFER OF CARE WHEN
NEEDED. SPEC WE ASK YOUR
ABILITY THANK YOU SENATOR DODD
MOVING TO DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OUT MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN THAT CALIFORNIA'S
MADE GREAT STRIDES TO REDUCE
MATERNAL MORTALITY BUT WE STILL
HAVE RATES OF MATERNAL AND
INFANT MORTALITY FAR HIGHER
THAN OTHER COUNTRIES WITH
SIMILAR WEALTH AND DEVELOPMENT.
BLACK WOMEN ARE THREE TO FOUR
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO DIE FROM
PREGNANCY RELATED CAUSES AND
CHILDBIRTH THAN WHITE WOMEN
BLACK BABIES ARE FOUR TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO DIE BEFORE THEIR
FIRST BIRTHDAY. NURSE MIDWIFERY
CARE IS A IS A CRITICAL
STRATEGY TO CURB THE DUAL
CRISIS OF BOTH THE SEVERE WORK
FORCE AND RACE BASED
DISPARITIES MATERNAL OUTCOMES I
HOPE YOU'LL JOIN US IN
SUPPORTING SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL CENTER BOARD JUST. THE
QUESTION FOR THE OFFERS
PERMITTED- ME TAKE A QUESTION.
PLEASE PROCEED JUST A
CLARIFICATION- RIGHT NOW. WITH
THE INSURANCE COVER- THE- THE
MIDWIFE IN THIS SITUATION YES
WHAT IT SO IF THIS REVIEW MOVE
FORWARD THERE BE NO INSURANCE
COVERAGE RELATED ISSUES. THAT
YOU'RE AWARE OF NONE OF BEEN
IDENTIFIED IN THE ANALYSIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
BOARD JUST MEMBERS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THEN SENATOR DODD
PLEASE CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE BOOK THANK YOU SIR.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I BATES. BELL FIVE FOR
JUST I BRADFORD I HAVE A- I
CHIANG HI DOLLY I DON. HI THERE
I WASN'T I GALGIANI HI GLAZER
FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO. I
TADO I JACKSON. I JONES. LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S I
MITCHELL. I MONNING I MORE LOCK
I RURAL NO NIELSEN. PAN
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO. I
SKINNER I STERN I NUMBER. I
WHITE HOUSE SKI AYE WIENER AYE
WILK HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES GROWTH. I JONES.
NIELSEN PAN. I THIRTY FIVE
KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT CENTER HERTZBERG
FOR PURPOSE TO RISE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MADAM PRESIDENT I
WANT TO SAY THAT WE HAVE BEFORE
WE MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT WE HAVE NINE
MEASURES LEFT TO CONSIDER WE
ARE GOING TO NOW IT'S ELEVEN
FIFTY NINE WE ARE NOW GOING TO
TAKE A LUNCH BREAK. THE
PRESIDING OFFICER WILL GAVEL IN
AT PRECISELY TWELVE TWENTY. AND
SHE EXPECTS TO WITH THE FULL
FORCE OF HER STRENGTH TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE IS BACK.
HERE SO WE CAN GET THOSE NINE
BILLS DON. AND GET OUR BUSINESS
DONE SO WE'LL TAKE A LUNCH
BREAK NOW FOR THAT WOULD BE
OKAY WE'LL BE BACK AT TWELVE
TWENTY SHARKS. AND WE WILL
COMPLETE THE LAST NINE BILLS
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU CENTER HERTZBERG MEMBERS
WILL SEE YOU IN TWENTY MINUTES
TWELVE TWENTY.
READ IT FIRST.
FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT SENATOR
HUESO MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL THIRTEEN OH
ONE BY SENATOR HUESO AND
ACTUALLY INTO PUBLIC RESOURCES
SENATOR HUESO. COMING THROUGH
OKAY I AM NOW THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS AS
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW SINCE
YOU'VE BECOME FAMILIAR LATELY
WITH THE QUAN OUT RIVER VALLEY
IN THE SET AND SENEGAL COUNTY
OF A BI NATIONAL RIVER VALLEY
THAT HAS BEEN PLAGUED. BY
POLLUTION AND- YOU KNOW- ON AN
AVERAGE WE CAN ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION GALLONS OF
SOMETIMES UNTREATED SEWAGE FLOW
FROM MEXICO INTO THE THAT THE
QUAN A RIVER VALLEY DUE TO.
INACTION FROM AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL IN OUR GOVERNMENT OF AND
THROUGH DO PROBLEMS IN MEXICO
WITH THEM TREATING THEIR THEIR
EFFLUENT AYE AYE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN I AUTHORED SB FIVE OH
SEVEN WHICH AUTHORIZES ANNUAL
COUNTY. TO CONDUCT THE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT REPORT ON THE
TIJUANA RIVER VALLEY THAT
REPORT WAS RECENTLY RELEASED
AND INCLUDES A COMPREHENSIVE
STUDY IDENTIFIED TWENTY SEVEN
PROJECTS THESE WILL GREATLY%
REDUCE THE IMPACTS OF THAT THE
WANDERER VALLEY. BASED ON STUDY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RECENTLY
ALLOCATED THREE HUNDRED MOUNT
BUILT INTO THE RIVER VALLEY BUT
THE PROJECT IDENTIFIED. TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM. IS A FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS DOLLAR
DIVERTED THAT WILL CAPTURE A
HUNDRED SIXTY THREE MILLION
GALLONS OF RAW SEWAGE PER DAY.
THIS WILL ESSENTIALLY STOP THE
POLLUTION AFTER FORTY YEARS.
BUT THIS. PROJECT DOESN'T SOLVE
THE PROBLEM EVERY SINGLE
WATERSHED EVERY MAJOR RIVER IN
CALIFORNIA HAS A WATERSHED
MANAGEMENT PLAN- WE PASSED
LEGISLATION. THREE YEARS AGO
THAT WILL CREATE A REQUIREMENT
THAT THE QUANDARY OF RIVER
VALLEY CREATE A WATERSHED AS
WELL BUT IT'S NOT A BI NATIONAL
WATERSHED IN THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THAT A BI NATIONAL
WATERSHED BE ESTABLISH AND
QUIRK IN IN COLLABORATION WITH
MEXICO ESPECIALLY SINCE SEVENTY
PERCENT. OF THAT THE QUAN A
RIVER VALLEYS WATERSHED IS IN
MEXICO SO- THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT I'VE BEEN WORKING ON WITH
THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT THEY
RECENTLY VOTED IN THEIR BI
NATIONAL. IN THEIR BI NATIONAL
AND THEN THEIR STATE
LEGISLATURES. OFFICE OF BI
NATIONAL AFFAIRS TO SET NOT
ONLY SUPPORT MY BILL INITIAL
LETTER IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
BUT TO WORK ON THE MEXICAN SIDE
TO DEVELOP- A COMPLIMENT TEEN
POLICY IN THIS WILL BE HER
HUGE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
CENTERS WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK ON. A BI NATIONAL
LEGISLATION HERE THAT WILL BE
THE FIRST OF ITS KIND THAT
WOULD OFFER STEWARDSHIP OF THIS
IMPORTANT WATERSHED AND
HOPEFULLY BE A PERMANENT
SOLUTION. TO OF ALL THE
PROBLEMS PEAK PLAGUE IN THIS
RIVER SO I ASKTHAT YOU JOIN ME
IN SUPPORT OF THIS EFFORT. AND
HELP US SOLVE THIS PROBLEM IN
THE YEARS TO COME I ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE FOR THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE THAT'S ESSENTIAL TO
THIS IMPORTANT RIVER VALLEY.
THANK YOU CENTER HUESO CENTER
MELINDA'S THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THIS. THIS ISSUE IS BIGGER THAN
I THINK MANY PEOPLE IN THIS
ROOM REALIZE- I HAVE PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH. THE POLLUTION
THAT THE AUTHOR IS TALKING
ABOUT OUR OUR OLDEST SON WHO'S
IN THE NAVY. WAS THERE AND SEAL
TRAINING IN SAN DIEGO I CANNOT
TELL YOU HOW MANY TIMES. THEY
COULDN'T GET IN THE WATER.
BECAUSE OF THE POLLUTION IN THE
WATER IT IS A DANGER TO THEIR
HEALTH. THESE ARE FOLKS WHO
HAVE PARTICULAR TRAINING THEY
MUST COMPLETE IN ORDER TO BE
FULLY PREPARED TO DEFEND THIS
COUNTRY THIS NATION OUR ALLIES
WHEREVER THEY ARE SENT IN THE
WORLD THEY CAN'T GET THE
ADEQUATE TRAINING IF THEY CAN'T
GET IN THE WATER AND DO THE
THINGS THEY NEED TO DO. SO I
THINK THERE'S PROBABLY A LITTLE
MORE WORK. BIG YOU'RE GOING TO
DOI MEAN THIS IS IN A IN A
THIS IS THE DOESN'T FIX THE
WHOLE PROBLEM BUT IT IS A START
TO THE PROBLEM. WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO KICK IT TO THE
FEDS. WE NEED THEIR HELP NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT AND I WISH
THEY WOULD MOVE A LITTLE FASTER
FRANKLY BECAUSE THIS IS NOT A
NEW PROBLEM- BUT THIS STATE I
THINK. HAS TO STEP IN WHERE
OTHERS ARE NOT AND GET THE BALL
ROLLING- SO WITH THAT I WILL BE
SUPPORTINGYOUR BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU CENTER MELINDA'S
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CENTER HUESO WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY-
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND DOES
HAVE A HUGE. RESPONSIBILITY
THROUGH THE ROLE IN THE I. B.
W. C. WHICH IS. RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENSURING THAT OUR TREATIES WITH
MEXICO ARE- ARE ENFORCED. AND
WE'RE WORKING ON DOING THAT BUT
IT WOULD BE- THE FIRST OF ITS
KIND TO HAVE TWO STATES WORK
TOGETHER TO CREATE A WATERSHED
MANAGEMENT PLAN. THAT OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS WILL HELP
IDENTIFY. THOSE IMPROVEMENTS OF
THE NEED TO MAKE ME MAKE TO LET
LESSEN THE RUN OFF. AND TO
ELIMINATE THE POLLUTION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER HUESO
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES I DEL.
GORGEOUS HI I BRADFORD I HAVE A
HI CHIANG I DALLY. DODD I RAZA.
GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROW I HERTZBERG I HILL AYE
HUESO. I TANTO I JACKSON. I
JONES. LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S AYE MITCHELL I
MONNING HI MORE LOCK I MARROW.
NIELSEN AYE PAN I PORTANTINO HI
ROTH. RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN I
NUMBER HI MY COUNTY I WIENER
AYE WILK HI SENATOR HUESO
PLACES A CALL MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM THIRTY
NINE SENATOR STERN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY BY SENATOR
STERN AND ACTUALLY ENDED
CLIMATE CHANGE CENTER STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS UNFORTUNATELY OF. THE
CLIMATE CRISIS WILL NOT WAIT
DESPITE THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE'RE FACING RIGHT NOW WITH
CLOSELY THANK TEEN IN FACT HI
THIS. THIS CALL COULD BE- A
VERY DANGEROUS AND DEADLY
WILDFIRE SEASON- THIS BILL IS
REALLY ABOUT STARTING TO DO THE
MATH AND LOOKING AHEAD IN THE
NEAR TERM ABOUT THE COST FACING
THE STATE CURRENTLY WE DO
ASSESS CLIMATE CHANGE RESIDENTS
STATE BUT IN A VERY SCIENTIFIC
WAY TO SOFTEN THE FORCE FROM
THE- VERY SERIOUS FISCAL
REALITIES. THAT WILDFIRE HAS ON
THE STATE BUDGET OR LOCAL AND-
COUNTY BUDGETS- AND ON HUMAN
HEALTH. ONE PARKS STORM PRINCE.
ONE SUPER. MODEL BY U. S. P. S.
ACOSTA ST. AROUND SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION THAT'S WHAT
THE FIFTEEN BILLION WITH A B.
IF WE GET A CONFLUENCE OF
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS AND STORMS
AND WE DON'T HAVE PROPER FLOOD
CONTROL BILL- SO WITH
WILDFIRES. FLOODS IT'S A
DEVASTATING ATTACK ISSUE OF.
BILL OF NOT YET TO WRESTLE WITH
AND SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THINGS LIKE A FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR CLIMB RESILIENCE BOND
AND WHETHER THAT'S TO BE EAGER-
TOO MUCH RIGHT NOW. AND YOU
LOOK AT A TRILLION DOLLAR
LIABILITY FACING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS CENTURY FROM
CLIMATE CHANGE- WE REALLY HAVE
TO RIGHT SIZE ARE MATH AND
UNDERSTAND THE SCALE THE RISK
THEY WERE DEALING WITH
INCREMENTALISM WILL NOT SOLVE
THIS CHALLENGE AND- HOPEFULLY
THIS BILL WILL. PUT SOME HONEST
MATH ON THE BOOKS AND REALLY
LET US BUDGET FOR A VERY RISKY
FUTURE AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES
I FELL FIVE FOR JUST. BRADFORD
HI CABRERA I CHIANG AYE DALLY.
DODD HI THERE I WASN'T I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO. I TADO I JACKSON AYE
JONES NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL. I
MONNING BY MORE LOCK. MURROW.
NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. RUBIO I
SKINNER HI STERN I NUMBER I Y.
CASKEY I WIENER I WILL HI.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
ARE MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM
FORTY SENATOR HER TADO. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR TADO AND ACTUALLY TO
CAL WORKS. CENTER HER TACO. CAN
YOUHEAR ME OK THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT SB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE WHICH WILL
ALLOW CALL WORKS FAMILIES WHOSE
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN PLACED INTO
FOSTER CARE TO CONTINUE
RECEIVING MONTHLY CASH
ASSISTANCE WHILE ACTIVE
REUNIFICATION EFFORTS ARE
ONGOING WITHIN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. THE CURRENT
PRACTICE OF REMOVING CASH
ASSISTANCE FROM A FAMILY THAT
IS ALREADY BELOW THE POVERTY
LINE MAKES IT EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT FOR FAMILIES TO
REUNIFY WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
ADDITIONALLY IT CAN DESTABILIZE
THE FAMILY AND ALTERNATELY
RESULT IN THE FAMILY BECOMING
HOMELESS. GIVEN THE SIGNIFICANT
HOUSING CRISIS. FAMILIES ACROSS
THE STATE ARE FACING IT. IT IS
TIME TO REVISIT THE POLICY
DECISION THAT ALLOW SERVICES.
BUT NOT CASH ASSISTANCE TO
CONTINUE DURING REUNIFICATION
EFFORTS DESTABILIZING FAMILIES
TO THE POINT OF HOMELESSNESS IS
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO OTHER
EFFORTS TO SUPPORT FAMILIES
WHAT THE SEEK TO REUNIFY WITH
THEIR CHILDREN. THIS BLL ONLY
APPLIES TO FAMILIES THAT ARE
ACTIVELY WORKING ON
REUNIFICATION WITH CHILD WHAT
THE CHILDREN WILL FOR WORKERS
MEANING THAT THE CHILD HAS BEEN
REMOVED FROM THE PARENT AND
PLACED IN OUT OF. OUT OF HOME
CARE THIS DOES NOT INCLUDE
CASES WHERE THE CHILD WAS
REMOVED BUT THE COUNTY DOES NOT
RECOMMEND FAMILY REUNIFICATION
SERVICES. SB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE
WILL ENHANCE THE ABILITY OF
CHILD WELFARE PROGRAMS TO
REUNIFY FOSTER CHILDREN. WHAT
THEIR PARENTS. BY ALLOWING CAL
WORKS FAMILIES WHOSE CHILDREN
HAVE HAVE BEEN PLACED IN FOSTER
CARE TO CONTINUE RECEIVING
MONTHLY CASH ASSISTANCE WHAT
ACTOR REUNIFICATION EFFORTS ARE
ONGOING AND THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
HER TACO- DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR JACKSON. YES THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MIGHT. THE
RECOLLECTION IS THAT I DID VOTE
HI ON THIS IN THE REPORT
INDICATES A NON VOTING OF
DURING COMMITTEE BUT THIS IS SO
EITHER WAY THIS IS A OF A VERY
POSITIVE STEP FORWARD AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING FORWARD AND NOTE IF I
COULD THAT I DID CAST AN AYE
VOTE IN COMMITTEE ALTHOUGH IT'S
NOT REFLECTED IN SUCH HERE.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON THIRD
TITLE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
UP EXCUSE ME CENTER HURTADO
CENTER MORE ON. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I JUST. HAD A QUICK
QUESTION ON THIS BILL AND
THERE'S A COUPLE TO A FEW TODAY
WHERE THERE'S A PRICE INCLUDED
I JUST. WANTED MAYBE IN A
CLOSING REMARKS SENATOR COULD
EXPLAIN HOW THIS WILL BE BUDGET
IT THANK YOU. CERTAINLY CENTER
HER TITLE IN YOUR CLOTHES IF
YOU COULD ANSWER CENTER
MORLOCKS QUESTION THAT WOULD BE
GREAT. EIGHTEEN YES. SO THE
FISCAL IMPACT HERE THE- OUR ON
GOING UP FOR MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND. BASED ON YOU CASES. IT
COULD BE AS HIGH AS TWENTY ONE
MILLION FOR FIVE THOUSAND KIDS
BUT IT ALL DEPENDS ON THAT THE
AMOUNT OF CASES WE DON'T REALLY
EXPECTED TO BE. A HIGH NUMBER.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU CENTER
TITLE YOU MAY CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES. BATES.
I TELL I FOR JUST AYE BRADFORD
I HAVE A I CHIANG AYE DALLY. I
DODD I DRAWS THEM I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I
GROWTH.FIVE HERTZBERG AYE HILL
HI HUESO. I TADO HI JACKSON HI
JONES I LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE. I
MELINDA'S AYE MITCHELL FIVE
MONEY I MORE LOCK HIGH MORALE.
HI NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO HI ROTH. RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN HI NUMBER HI
MY COUNTY I WIENER. I WILK HI
SENATOR MUSICAL MEMBERS ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY ONE
SENATOR STERN MAN SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
STERN AND AFTER LEADING TO FIRE
PREVENTION SINISTER. BUT THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- THIS BILL
COMES FROM THE SENATE'S- WILD
FIRE WORKING GROUP PACKAGE AND
DOVE TAILS WITH THE EARLIER
MEASURE YOU HEARD ON A HOME
HARDENING COMMISSION- WHERE THE
HOME AIMS- DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND
THE WILD IN URBAN INTERFACE
BEGIN AND IT'S CRUCIAL THAT WE-
START MANAGING. NOT JUST OUR
WILD LANDS DEEP INTO THE FOREST
BUT REALLY THAT INTERFACE RIGHT
AT THAT ZERO TO FIVE FEET NEAR
THE HOME AND WITHIN THAT
COMMUNITY- LANDSCAPE ZONE THAT
THAT IS TRULY THE CAUSE OF MOST
FIRES IN THE STATE THEY ARE
THEY ARE TYPICALLY NOT STARTED
FROM. HEAT DRIVEN EVENTS OR
EVEN OF FROM A GIANT WALL OF
FIRE BUT SIMPLY THOSE EMBERS
THAT SLIP THROUGH AND CATCH ON
TO- THAT THAT BIT OF MATTER IN
YOUR GUTTERS OR THROUGH EVENTS-
AND THEN IT'S ALL OVER- SO
HOPEFULLY THIS BILL CAN MOVE
THE CONVERSATION FORD. AND GET
SOME KEY DEFENSIBLE SPACE
MEASURES IN PLACE AND REALLY
FOCUS ON AND- A SOLUTION IT'S
NOT ONE SIZE FITS ALL- WHAT
WHAT WORKS IN RURAL CALIFORNIA
SIMPLY IS NOT A SOLUTION FOR
THAT SORT OF SUBURBAN WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE IN OUR STATE
AND IT'S TIME THAT WE START
INVESTING IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
AND- HOPEFULLY THIS. THIS BILL
WILL MOVE US IN THAT DIRECTION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER STERN MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA. I ATKINS.
BATES NO WELL I FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD HI COME BY ADAM HI
CHIANG. I DALLY. DODD BY
TERRORISM I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI HELLO. I WAS SO.
HI TANTO. HI JACKSON I JONES.
LEYVA I MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S
NO MITCHELL. HI MONNING I MORE
LOCK I RURAL. NO NIELSEN. PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. RUBIO
I SKINNER. FIVE STERN HI I'M
BURKE HI MY TRUSTY AYE WIENER
AYE WILK. HI SENATOR MOVES A
CALL MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY
TWO SENATOR HER TITLE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL NINE SEVENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR TADO AN ACT RELATING TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY CENTER
HER TACO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I'M HERE TO RISE I
RISE TO PRESENT SB NINE SEVEN
FOUR AS MANY OF YOU KNOW MANY
SMALL RURAL COMMUNITIES IN MY
DISTRICT AND BEYOND HAVE
EXPERIENCED DRY WATER WELLS
BRING CALIFORNIA'S HISTORIC
DROUGHT AND IN NON DROUGHT
YEARS. ANY TIME WHEN WASHING
YOUR HANDS IS IMPORTANT TO MANY
SMALL DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO CLEAN
WATER BUT HE'S COMMUNITIES
UNDERTAKEN WATER QUALITY
PROJECTS SUCH AS FOLLOWING
SEQUEL GUIDOLIN GUIDELINES OUR
TIME AND COST PROHIBITIVE. LAST
YEAR FOR EXAMPLE THE CITY OF
OUR BAND CELEBRATED THE RIBBON
CUTTING FOR CONSTRUCTION OF A
WATER PROJECT A PROJECT IT TOOK
FIFTEEN YEARS TO GET TO.
FIFTEEN YEARS TO GET SAFE
DRINKING WATER FOR THAT
COMMUNITY THE CONSTRUCTION
ITSELF. WAS ONLY TOOK OR IS
TAKING SHOULD SHOULD NOT TAKE
LONGER THAN A YEAR THAT'S
TYPICALLY THE KIDS FOR
CONSTRUCTION WATER PROJECTS SB
NINE SEVEN FOUR CREATING NARAL
STATUTORY SEQUEL EXEMPTION FOR
WATER PROJECTS IN THESE AREAS.
ESPECIALLY FOR SCHOOL CHILDREN
THIS BILL HELPS REDUCE COST AND
EXPEDITE EXPEDITES SAFE
DRINKING WATER PROJECTS THIS
BILL STRIKES A BALANCE BETWEEN
ACHIEVING EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
WATER WHILE ALSO PRESERVING THE
ENVIRONMENT WILDLIFE SPECIES
AND PROVIDES GOOD PAYING JOBS.
THIS BILL AS AMENDED THAT ADDED
TO- LANGUAGE REGARDING LABOR
REQUIREMENTS A PROJECT MUST
MEET TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR BILLS A
QUICK EXEMPTION FOR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS SB NINE
SEVEN FOUR HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT RECEIVE NO NO VOTES IN
COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER TARA DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE SENATOR GORGEOUS.
MEMBERS A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR ACTUAL SEPT SENATOR HER
TITLE YOU ACCEPT A QUESTION YES
PLEASE PROCEED. THE SEQUEL
EXEMPTION HERE WHICH HAVE
ALWAYS LIKE YEAH EXEMPTIONS-
THING THEY'RE THEY'RE HELPFUL
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND WATER IS IT. ONLY FOR STATE
ENTITIES PERSONS- STATE
SPONSORED PROJECTS THAT A
SEQUEL EXEMPTION IS ALLOWED.
BUT WHAT IF IT WERE A PRIVATE
CONTRACTED ENTITY WOULD THEY BE
ALLOWED TO GET SEQUEL EXEMPTION
FOR THE WATER CONSTRUCTION.
PROJECTS FOR THE SIX THE SEQUEL
EXEMPTION IS ONLY FOR THE
PUBLIC- THE PUBLIC PROJECTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER FOR
JUST CENTER GROVE. SORRY HANG
WITH US FOR SIX THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THERE YOU GO THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT A QUESTION
THE AUTHOR. THERE HER TOTALLY
TO THE QUESTION. YES PLEASE
PROCEED ON- IT LOOKS LIKE JUNE
EIGHTEENTH YOU CHECK AN
AMENDMENT THAT INCLUDED A
PREVAILING WAGE AND HIRING MOST
UNION LABOR- FOR THIS BILL CAN
YOU TELL ME WHY YOU DID THAT IF
THE- IF THE- POSITION ON YOUR
BILL AS IT IT'S A COST SAVING
BILL AND WILL SAVE MONEY AND
ALLOW- LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES TO
PROVIDE SAFE DRINKING WATER.
SENATOR TOM. YES SO THAT BOTH
UNION AND NONUNION CONTRACTORS
THAT MEET THE REQUIREMENTS CAN
WORK WITH GRANT RECIPIENTS TO
ACCOMPLISH THESE PROJECTS SO
CALIFORNIA HAS- STATE PER
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND SOME ARE JOINTLY OFFERED BY
UNIONS AND THEIR EMPLOYERS
SOME- THAT ARE NON UNION OF
COURSE- SO THESE PROVISIONS
JUST SIMPLY STATE THAT THE
GRADUATES OF THESE PROGRAMS
WHICH MEANS THE WORKERS KILLED
IN TRAIN SHALL. BUILD THESE
PROJECTS. IT THAT ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION IT DOES AND I THINK
YOU FOR THE ANSWER I CAN TELL
YOU THAT ONE OF THE CITY'S IT
IS REALLY STRUGGLING WITH CLEAN
DRINKING WATER IN THE SENATOR
GOOD SENATORS DISTRICT IS
ARMING CALIFORNIA AND THEY HAVE
A HUGE DEFICIT. AND FOR THIS
MUNICIPALITY TO- COVER THE COST
OF- TRIPLE OF THE COST OF WHAT
WOULD LABOR WOULD COST IN A
COMMUNITY OF OUR BEEN. ON WAGES
THAT ARE SET IN SAN FRANCISCO.
NOW THE DIFFERENCE IN ARVIN
VERSUS SAN FRANCISCO IS AN ART
AND YOU COULD PROBABLY GET A
THREE THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT%
HOUSE FOR. RED SLEEP PROBABLY
FIVE TO SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH. IN SAN FRANCISCO WHERE
THESE PREVAILING WAGES ARE SET.
IT AT THREE THOUSAND SQUARE
FOOT HOUSE I HAVE TO RELY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
BUT I CAN PRETTY MUCH GUARANTEE
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE- AT SEVEN
OR SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH. SO I JUST THINK THAT
SETTING PREVAILING WAGES FOR
THESE SMALL RURAL COMMUNITIES
WHERE THE COST OF LIVING IS
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS. THAN WHERE
THE WAGES ARE SET IN SAN
FRANCISCO DOESN'T DO ANYTHING
FOR A MUNICIPALITIES. OUR
CITIES AND THAT HAVE A
STRUGGLING BUDGET A REDUCTION
IN A WORK FORCE BECAUSE OF KOBE
AND THE COST OF DOING BUSINESS
AND TO SET. THE WAGES FOR THESE
PROJECTS. IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
REQUIRE THOSE WAGES BE PAID IN
THE SMALL COMMUNITIES THEY DO
NOT HAVE THE COST OF LIVING
LIKE THESE MAJOR METROPOLISES.
WHERE THE WAGES ARE SET IS JUST
UNACCEPTABLE A COMPLETE WASTE
OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS. IF A
STANDARD WAGE A WAGE THAT WAS
EQUITABLE THAT WAS SET BASED ON
THE COMMUNITY IN THE REGION TO
WHERE THE COST OF LIVING WAS
WHICH WOULD BE A REALLY GOOD
WAGE. THAN THOSE WATER PROJECT
FUNDS COULD GO FURTHER AND
MAYBE HELP ARVIN LAMONT WASCO
SHE AFTER ALL THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE A LOWER- A LOWER.
COST OF LIVING TO BE ABLE TO
READ TO LIVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I REQUEST A
NUMBER. THANK YOU CENTER GROW.
SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT. THE FIRST
FOR US I JUST WANNA COMPLEMENT
CENTER HER TITLE ON HER WORK ON
THIS BILL. SO NUMBER ONE THERE
IS NOT BEEN A BIGGER CHAMPION.
A BIGGER CHAMPION FOR FAMILY
SUSTAINING JOBS IN THE VALLEY
THEN SENATOR HER TIME. EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY SHE HAS BEEN
FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE HE'S
PUTTING WORKING FAMILIES. BACK
TO WORK IN THE VALLEY WHETHER
IT'S ISSUES- PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS AND OR WITHIN PRIVATE
ENTERPRISE. NUMBER ONE SHE HAS
BEEN FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE
THAT THE JOBS THAT ARE CREATED.
CAN SUSTAIN A FAMILY. NUMBER
TWO SHE'S BEEN FOCUSING ON
LOCAL APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE WHO ARE
GROWING UP IN THE VALLEY. CAN
STAY IN THE VALLEY. AND THE
NUMBER THREE WHERE SHE'S BEEN
VERY FOCUS IS WORKING WITH OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES IN
MAKING SURE THAT THIS WORKS FOR
THEM AS WELL. SO I JUST WANTED
TO STAND UP TODAY- AND
COMPLEMENT. THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM THE VALLEY FOR ALL OF HER
WORK ON THIS IN FOR HER KEEN
FOCUS HER KEEN FOCUS ON
CREATING THOSE JOBS THAT ARE
GONNA BE ABLE TO. RISE FOLKS AT
A PARTY. THANK YOU SENATOR
REQUIRE MEMBERS SCENE NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CENTER HER TITLE PLEASE CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE VOTE.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES. TELL FIVE
GORGEOUS BRADFORD HI COVER
YELLOW I CHIANG HI DOLLY I DODD
I DORADO HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. NO
HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO. I
TADO HI JACKSON I JONES NO
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S
NO MITCHELL. I MONEY I WARLOCK
NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN HI I PAN
FIVE PORTANTINO I ROTH. RUBIO I
SKINNER. HI STERN. I AMBER I
LIVE MY COUNTY I WIENER I WILL
HI. SEN REMOVES A CALL MEMBERS
REMOVING THE FILE ITEM FORTY
FOUR SENATOR TO RAZA MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL ELEVEN ELEVEN BY SENATOR
DORADO AN ACT RELATING TO
JUVENILES SENATOR DORADO. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
SENATE BILL ELEVEN ELEVEN
AMENDS CALIFORNIA LAW TO PERMIT
YOU TO STAY IN JUVENILE
FACILITIES PENDING THE OUTCOME
OF THE JUVENILE COURT CASE
UNTIL THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE. SB
ELEVEN ELEVEN CRATES OF BOTTLED
PROCESS FOR DETERMINING WHETHER
YOU'VE AGE EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
ONE WHOSE CASES ORIGINATED IN
JUVENILE COURT SHOULD BE HOUSED
IN THE DOLE JAILS. THIS BILL
CREATES A PRESUMPTION FOR
KEEPING YOU IN JUVENILE
FACILITIES AND REQUIRES A THE
JUDGE DECIDE WHETHER OR YOUTH
MAYBE MOVED. IT PROVIDES
GUIDANCE FOR THE JUDGE'S
DECISION CURRENTLY THERE ARE O
THE LAW PROVIDES NO STANDARDS
FOR THIS DECISION. IT ALLOWS
THE USER TO BE MOVED TO THE
DOLE JAIL IF THE JUVENILE
FACILITY CANNOT SAFELY CARE FOR
THEM. OR IF THE PHYSICAL SPACE
CANNOT ACCOMMODATE AN OLDER
POPULATION IT SIMPLIFIES AND
CONSOLIDATES THE RULES WERE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES OF YOUTH
INCLUDING YOUTH IN JUVENILE
COURT AND YOU DO HAVE BEEN
ORDERED TRANSFERRED TO THE
ADULT COURT. ONCE THEY ARE HELD
IN THE ADULT JAIL YOU NO LONGER
RECEIVE EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE
SERVICES FOR THE AGE
APPROPRIATE PROGRAMMING
AVAILABLE IN JUVENILE
FACILITIES. THEY FACE AN
INCREASE RISK OF PHYSICAL AND
SEXUAL ABUSE THEY SUFFER WITH A
HEIGHTENED RISK OF SUICIDE AND
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. OFTEN THE
SAME YOU ARE TRANSFERRED BACK
TO THE JUVENILE FACILITY AFTER
THE DISPOSITION OF THE CSE
AFTER SUFFERING DISRUPTIONS IN
THEIR EDUCATION IN PROGRAMMING.
SB ELEVEN ELEVEN HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND IT IS IMPORTANT
DURING THIS PANDEMIC BECAUSE IT
WOULD REDUCE THE TRANSMISSION
OF- ILLNESSES AND EASE
CONDITIONS FOR STAFF TASKED
WITH MONITORING YOUNGER INMATES
IN ADULT FACILITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR EYE
BELOW. THANK YOU STANDARD ROCCO
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATE
NIELSEN. THAT A PRESIDENT AND-
AT THE SAN THIS A BROADER
CONTEXT THE SO CALLED REFORMS
OF THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
I THINK A VERY PROBLEMATIC.
WHAT'S GRAVITATED OUT OF THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM NOW HAS
BECOME AGAIN LIKE MANY THINGS
RELATED TO REALIGNMENT FOISTED
UPON THE COUNTIES. THE MISSION
OF THE JUVENILE SYSTEM IS ALL
REHABILITATION. AND ARE COUNTY
SHOULD DO NOT HAVE THE
REHABILITATIVE RESOURCES. WHEN
THIS REALIGNMENT CAME DOWN THAT
WAS REPORTED TO BE ALL KINDS OF
MONEY WOULD BE FORTHCOMING TO
THEM WELL IT HASN'T BEEN AND
THEY'RE WRESTLING WITH. AND NOW
THE JUVENILE POPULATION THAT
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THIS BILL.
THESE THESE ARE TO. THE BEST OF
OUR YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS THEY ARE
OF THE WORST OF OUR YOUTHFUL
OFFENDERS. IT IS MY EXPERIENCE
THAT THE SOME OF THEM. ARE NOT
GOING TO GET ANY BETTER NO
MATTER WHAT YOU DO. IN THIS
REMOVES SOME AUTHORITY I THINK
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
MANAGE THAT POPULATION AS THE
BEST SEE FIT. I WOULD URGE AND
OVER. THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN
MEMBERS SEEING NO FURTHER. ONE
MOMENT. SENATOR JACKSON'S
SENATOR RUBIO. IT'S THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I
YEAH I WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND TO
MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM TO HIM
IS OBSERVATION THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES WHAT WE
DON'T HAVE IS THE WILL. AND I
THINK THAT'S CRITICAL WE REALLY
NEED TO TURN THIS WHOLE PROCESS
AROUND. SO THAT WE CAN. TRY TO
REHABILITATE AND TO SUPPORT OUR
YOUTH I AS THEY EXPERIENCE THE
UPS AND DOWNS IN THE VAGARIES
OF THEIR LIVES. ARE CHALLENGES
AND SO I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS AND-
JOSH AS WE GO FORWARD IN
DEALING WITH ISSUES REGARDING
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF PREVENTION AND
INTERVENTION IN REHABILITATION
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT SIMPLE
INCARCERATION AND PUNISHMENT
HAS COST THE STATE FAR TOO MUCH
MONEY WITH VIRTUALLY NO
POSITIVE RESULTS SO OUR YEP
APPRECIATE HIS GOOD WORK IN HIS
PASSION ON THIS ISSUE. BUT I
THINK IT'S TIME THAT WE TURN
THAT CORNER AND SEE THAT THERE
ARE OTHER AND BETTER WAYS TO
RESOLVE THESE PROBLEMS. WE NEED
THE WILL. TO USE THE RESOURCES
THAT WE HAVE TO EFFECTUATE
THOSE THOSE NECESSARY CHANGES I
URGE AN EYEFUL THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENTE I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN ELEVEN I
YOU KNOW I DON'T WANT I BELIEVE
I'VE BEEN TRULY OUTSPOKEN IN
THIS CHAMBER ABOUT VICTIMS
RIGHTS AND- AND EMAIL- BE
PROTECTIVE OF THOSE VICTIMS BUT
IN THIS CASE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT OUR CHILDREN AND I THINK
THAT. THERE COMES A TIME THAT
WE HAVE TO STEP OF FOR OUR
YOUTH I FEEL THAT. SOMETIMES
AND GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY BILL
DO RIGHT BY US AND THE REALITY
IS THAT TIME WHEN THEY'RE
CAUGHT UP IN THIS WEB IT MAKES
IT'S STILL VERY DIFFICULT. FOR
THEM TO COME OUT OF IT AND I
ALWAYS THINK OF THEM AS ADULTS
AND WE DON'T GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY NOW EIGHT. IT JUST
REALLY NOT. UP AND GIVING THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO RECTIFY
THEIR BEHAVIOR AND DA'S SOMEONE
ALREADY MENTIONED THAT.
PREVENTION AND INTERVENTION
WHEN THEY'RE YOUNG IS CRITICAL.
AND SO I URGE AND I BOTH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO
SENATOR GROW. MADAM PRESIDENT I
WASN'T GOING TO SPEAK ON THIS
BILL TO THE COMMENTS CAME UP I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM TO
HIM AND IT SAYS THAT- WE DO NOT
HAVE THE FUNDING AND SPENDING-
IS NOT AVAILABLE FOR THESE
PROGRAMS AND THESE YOUTH THAT
ARE INCARCERATED IN THESE
JUVENILE FACILITIES. I ALSO
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA BARBARA WHO SAYS THAT WE
HE IT'S NOT ABOUT THE FUNDING
IT'S ABOUT THE WILL TO- TO
PRODUCE THE SPENDING AND SOME
OF THOSE THINGS THAT WE JUST
PASSED THIS WEEK BASED ON JUST
THE MAJORITY PARTY'S VOTE. THE
WILL TO DE FUND THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AT TWO POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS WOULD HAVE DONE A LOT
OF GOOD FOR THESE YOUTH IN
THESE FACILITIES IN ORDER TO
HAVE THE FUNDING NEEDED TO MAKE
SURE THAT REHABILITATION
SERVICES WERE AVAILABLE TO
THESE USE- A LOT OF YOU KNOW MY
BACKGROUND. A LOT OF YOU KNOW I
WAS RAISED BY SINGLE MOM MY DAD
LEFT WHEN I WAS VERY YOUNG AND
IN A LOT OF YOU KNOW THAT I
SERVE TIME IN JUVENILE HALL-
BEFORE IN MY EARLY HIGH SCHOOL
DAYS. AND SO. THERE ARE. READ
AND REHABILITATIVE SERVICES
AVAILABLE OBVIOUSLY AS I AM
STANDING ON THE SENATE FLOOR
TODAY AND REPRESENTING OVER A
MILLION PEOPLE- WITHOUT A
COLLEGE DEGREE. AND WITHOUT A
LOT OF THE THINGS THAT- PEOPLE
ARE MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE
HAVE TO DATE- AND AGAIN MY
BACKGROUND IS FROM A SINGLE
MOM. AND SHE WORKED IN THE
FIELDS WERE TO THE POTATO
SHEDS- SO I INTO WORK IN A
FARMER'S INSURANCE AGENT
BECAUSE SHE WENT BACK TO SCHOOL
AT THIRTY YEARS OLD AND GOT HER
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA- SO. I GET
MY TENACITY IN MY FOURTH RIGHT
IN MY FIGHT FOR MY MOTHER- IN
BUT LIKE I SAID THIS IS A
CONTROVERSIAL BILL NOT
CONTROVERSIAL IN THE WAY THAT.
IT DEALS WITH THAT IT'S A BAD
BILL IT JUST DEALS WITH THE
SUBJECT MATTER. THAT
DESPERATELY DOES NEED FUNDING
FOR REAL BILL TATIAN SERVICES.
AND THERE IS A WAY TO DO IT YES
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
BARBARA SAID- WE HAVE THE WILL
TO DO IT- WE NEED TO REDUCE
TAXES WE DON'T NEED TO DO THE
THINGS THAT ARE PUT FORTH ON
THIS. BY THE MAJORITY PARTY IN
THIS BODY. WE JUST DIDN'T NEED
TO ADDRESS HORRIFIC SPENDING BY
THIS STATE THAT DOES NOT
PRIORITISE. SITUATIONS LIKE THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE- YOU KNOW
UNDER TWENTY ONE SOMETHESE
KIDS ARE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
FIFTEEN WHEN THEY COMMIT A
CRIME. MOST OF YOU KNOW I OWN A
BUSINESS THAT WE GET PEOPLE
JOBS AND WE WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH AUTHORITY AND
THEY BRING THESE KIDS IN HERE.
AND SOME OF THEM YOU KNOW. I'M
SKINNY ON A SOMEWHAT THEM IT'S
LIKE THERE'S NO HOPE YOU'RE
NEVER GOING TO GET THEM TO DO-
WHAT'S RIGHT IN SOCIETY. BUT
THERE ARE SOME WHO GENUINELY
COME OUT OF THERE THAT HAVE
BEEN IN THE SYSTEMS AND THEY
WERE FOURTEEN YEARS OLD. AND
THEY COME OUT AND THEY HAVE
BEEN IN A FOOD LINE. FOR THE
LAST. FIVE YEARS SIX YEARS
GETTING THEIR FOOD FROM A
TRAIN- AND GOING AT A CAFETERIA
STYLE. AND SO I HAD THIS YOUNG
MAN CAME INTO MY OFFICE AND HE
GOES I GOT THIS JOB AND HE'S
GOT A BAG OF BREAD. IN SOME
BOLOGNA AND HE'S LIKE CAN I CAN
I MAKE A SANDWICH AMENITIES AND
NOT GET POISONED BECAUSE HE WAS
THINKING THAT IF HE DIDN'T HAVE
A SANDWICH REFRIGERATED. SO
WHICH IS THE CIRCUMSTANCES IN
WHICH THEY GROW UP IN. SO I
THINK THAT IF WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO- DO REAL
BILLETED HATE OF SERVICES. AND
REACH THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AT A
PLACE FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN BE GAINFULLY
EMPLOYED AND BE A PRODUCTIVE
MEMBER OF SOCIETY. WE SHOULD DO
THAT. AND DEAL WITH THE OTHER
ONES IN A DIFFERENT WAY BUT- I
PLUG THE AUTHOR FOR BRING IT
FORWARD LIKE I SAID I AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM TO HE
MEANT. THAT RESOURCES NEED TO
BE AVAILABLE AND ALSO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA.
THAT IF THERE'S A WILL THERE'S
A WAY AND THERE DEFINITELY IS A
WILL ON OUR SIDE TO LIMITED
HIGH SPEED RAIL FUNDS TO HELP
WITH HIS JUVENILE. ISSUE THAT
WE HAVE. BIG SENATOR GROW
SENATOR MITCHELL. BUDGET
TRAINING ONE OH ONE DOLLARS
ALLOCATED TO TRANSPORTATION.
COULD NOT IF WE WANTED TO BE
REDIRECTED TO JUVENILE
DETENTION. I GET. I THINK IT'S
REALLY UNFORTUNATE THAT THAT WE
AS LEGISLATORS AND EVEN ADULTS
ARE FIND OURSELVES SPEAKING IN
GROSS GENERALITIES ABOUT KIDS
IN AND- BASED ON OUR
INDIVIDUALIZE EXPERIENCE THE
EVEN SIR EITHER EITHER SERVING
ON THE BOARD AND PRISON TERMS
DECADES AGO OR EXPERIENCES WE
HAVE WITH YOUNG PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE. WHATEVER THAT
WE HAVE THESE GENERAL. IS A
WORTHY AND WHO'S NOT. THIS BILL
SAYS. TO BRING US BACK TO THE
DEBATE AT HAND. THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE ANY PERSON WHO'S CASE
ORIGINATED IN JUVENILE COURT TO
REMAIN IN A COUNTY JUVENILE
FACILITY UNTIL THEY TURN TWENTY
YEARS OF AGE EXCEPT EXCEPT AS
SPECIFIED. AND SO WHETHER OR
NOT WE THINK THEY'RE REDEEMABLE
OR NOT. THEY HAVE A CASE IN
JUVENILE COURT AND THIS BILL
SIMPLY SUGGEST THAT THEY SHOULD
STAY IN A JUVENILE FACILITY AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL PERSON BE
TRANSFERRED TO A STATE ADULT
FACILITY FOR THOSE REASONS I'LL
BE SUPPORTING SB ELEVEN ELEVEN.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
CENTER MELINDA'S. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- YESTERDAY WE
DEBATED A BILL THAT SAID THAT-
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS ARE SO
WISE. SO SAGE BEYOND THEIR
YEARS STATE THEY SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT. WHO REPRESENTS THEM IN
OFFICE. THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
VOTED SEVENTEEN YET TODAY WE'RE
HAVING CONVERSATION SAYING THAT
NO NO THEY'RE NOT. WISE ENOUGH
THEY'RE NOT MATURE ENOUGH. TO
BE HELD IN A PARTICULAR TYPE OF
FACILITY. WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
PUTTING IN AN TWENTY OR TWENTY
ONE YEAR OLD IN WITH. KEEPING
THEM WITH FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS.
THAT IS THE POTENTIAL FOR SOME
VERY DANGEROUS CONSEQUENCES YOU
KNOW THERE IS A BIG DIFFERENCE
THOSE IF YOU HAVE CHILDREN YOU
KNOW THERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A FIFTEEN YEAR OLD AND
A TWENTY YEAR OLD AND I DON'T.
THINK THAT. REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THE CASE STARTED I DON'T THINK
IT'S WISE. TO SUGGEST THAT IT'S
PERFECTLY SAFE. TO PUT
INDIVIDUALS A BAD AGE- TOGETHER
WHEN YOU'RE EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD
BY THE LAW YOU'RE RECOGNIZED AS
AN ADULT NOT A CHILD. AND
THOUGH IT IS UNFORTUNATE FOR
SURE THAT WE HAVE. PEOPLE EVEN
IN THIS SITUATION I THINK IF
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
SAFETY IN THE PROTECTION OF
YOUTH GET TO TALK ABOUT IN THE
FULL CONTEXT AND THAT IS THAT A
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD I THINK COULD
BE PLACED IN YOUR DANGER WHEN
IN THE SAME FACILITY WITH ONE
THAT IS. TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD
AND MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED
THAT- YOU KNOW THIS WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT YOUTHFUL
OFFENDERS WHO HAVE. DONE SOME
MONEY- CRIME. OFTENTIMES ARE
TALKING MISS HIM VERY VERY-
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT CRIME SO I
JUST WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT
THAT IT'S NOT THAT THE PEOPLE
IN THIS ROOM. HAVE NO MERCY
TOWARD OUR YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS
BUT I THINK WE HAVE TO BE SMART
ABOUT. HOW THE SITUATION THAT
WE'RE PUTTING THEM AND TO KEEP
THEM ALL SAFE. DECEMBER
MELINDA'S CENTER PAN. I THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH. AND CHAIR OF
SENATORS. I DID WANT TO SERVE
ADDRESS US SOME REMARKS ABOUT-
I THINK THE DEVELOPMENT AS OF
OUR ADOLESCENTS AND- CERTAINLY
IS A- PHYSICIAN WHO'S ACTUALLY
SPECIFICALLY TRAINED AND
DEVELOPMENT- YEAH I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT THERE ARE CERTAINLY
SOME DIFFERENCES BETWEEN A
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD AND A TWENTY
ONE YEAR OLD AND I'M SURE THE
FACILITY. HAVING EXPERIENCE
MANAGING USE- WILL HAVE.
SEIZURES AND POLICIES TO
ADDRESS THAT I THINK THAT WE
ALSO SHOULD THINK THOUGH AND
WHAT THEY THINK THIS BILL
ADDRESSES IS THAT YOU IF YOU
HAD SOMEONE WHO YES THERE ARE
NOW IN THEIR EARLY TWENTIES WHO
IS BASICALLY STILL HAVE SOME
TIME LEFT TO IS BEEN IN A
JUVENILE FACILITY. THAT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE BOTH EITHER FOR THAT
A JUNE THAT PERSON I AM A
COMMON JUVENILE MORE OF THEIR
IN THEIR TWENTIES BUT TO THEN
BE TRANSFERRED TO AN ADULT
PRISON WHERE THERE'S A VERY
DIFFERENT CULTURE OR THEIR NOW
EMBEDDED WITH PEOPLE WHO HAVE.
HE BASICALLY PERHAPS HAVE A
LITTLE MORE EXPERIENCE- IT
CETERA SO I MEAN. IF YOU KNOW
WHAT. CERTAINLY I THINK ONE OF
THE GOALS WE HAVE HIS
REHABILITATION RIGHT AND- I
THINK THAT A JUVENILE FACILITY
CERTAINLY CAN THROUGH THEIR
PROCEDURES I THINK HE'D BE ABLE
TO MANAGE SOMEONE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A FIFTEEN OR
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD AND A TWENTY
OR EVEN TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD.
TWENTY THREE YEAR OLD PERSON-
BUT I'M NOT SURE IF. WE'RE
GOING TO IT'S GONNA BE VERY
BENEFICIAL TO TAKES SOMEONE
WHO'S BEEN AND DIED IN GIVEN
NOW WHO. AND THEN THEM TO ADULT
PRISON. TO COMPLETE- TERM AND
THAT THAT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO
BE HELPFUL EITHER TO THE PRISON
TO SOCIETY AS WELL IN TERMS OF
THE REHABILITATION I WOULD OR
DENY THAT. THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN CENTERVILLE. I'M ALWAYS SO
INTERESTED IN THESE DISCUSSION
ON BILLS BECAUSE I KIND OF TAKE
THE PERSPECTIVE HAVE BEEN ON.
CRIMINAL YOU KNOW THE PUBLIC
SAFETY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE. I
DON'T KNOW HOW LONG I WAS WITH
CENTER HANCOCK CENTERS SKINNER.
AND WE'VE LOOKED AT THE NUMBERS
AND I TEND TO LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS THE RESEARCH AND THE
RESEARCH SHOWS ONE THING IT'S
WAY MORE EXPENSIVE. FAR MORE
EXPENSIVE. TO PUT A YOUNG
PERSON EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE.
INTO A ADULT FACILITY BECAUSE
YOU WILL HAVE A LONGER TERM.
EVENTUALLY OVER THE LIFE OF
THAT PERSON STAY IN IN PRISON
NOT THEY THEY WILL GO BACK TO
PRISON BECAUSE IT'S ALMOST LIKE
PUTTING A MAN CRIME COLLEGE. IF
YOU PUT A YOUNG PERSON IN AN
ADULT FACILITY. IT'S EXTREMELY
HERE IN HUMANE TO PUT SOMEBODY
THAT'S A YOUNG PERSON. IN AN
ADULT FACILITY. I THINK THAT WE
ALSO HAVE TO LOOK AT NUMBERS
WHAT'S THE COST OKAY. THE STATE
JUVENILE CORRECTIONS FACILITIES
THEY RUN ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PER INMATE PER YEAR.
WE FORTUNATELY HAVE A NEW
REFORM THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
DOING. OVER THE NEXT YEAR
FINALLY. TO FOCUS. A LIMITING
DOUBT AND CREATING A NEW AGENCY
UNDER THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. WE SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THAT- JUVENILE
FACILITIES IN THE STATE YOU
KNOW WHAT THE YOU KNOW WHAT THE
OCCUPANCY IS LESS THAN A THIRD
ARE OCCUPIED. I REPEATTHAT
THERE'S PLENTY OF SPACE LESSEN
THE THIRD ARE OCCUPIED. TO ME
IT TO ME. THE GOAL IS TO PUBLIC
SAFETY GOAL IS TO NOT HAVE A
PERSON RESERVE A AND THE LEAGUE
AND- TO CORRECT A MISTAKE THEY
MADE WHEN THEY WERE YOUNG
PERSON. AND LEAD A BETTER LIFE.
AND SO I THINK THIS THIS BILL.
WILL BE A PERFORMANCE BILL
IT'LL PERFORM BETTER THAN WHAT
WE DO NOW. SO I VOTE I THINK
THIS WILL SAVE MONEY. IT'S A
HUMAN. IT HELPS THE HUMAN BEING.
BUT IT ALSO SAVES A STATE A LOT
OF MONEY YOU WANT TO KEEP
SPENDING MONEY. VOTE AGAINST
THIS BILL. YOU CAN YOU CAN
YOU'LL SEE. THAT WE WILL END UP
SPENDING TONS OF MONEY. IT MAY
BE IT MAY BE. HELP TERMS OF
LIVES TO IF YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT STOPPING CRIME. STOPPING
CRIME. I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
WAY TO STOP CRIME. SERGEANT
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR BILL
MEMBERS SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
ALSO YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THEY'RE ALREADY
NINETEEN COUNTIES THAT ALLOWED
TRANSITION AGE YOU TO BE HELD
IN THE JUVENILE FACILITIES BOTH
COUNTIES HAVE NOT REPORTED ANY
ADDITIONAL COSTS. JUVENILE
FACILITIES ARE OPERATING UNDER
CAPACITY SO THAT IS NOT THE
ISSUE TODAY THE ISSUE IS ABOUT
STANDARDIZING THIS ACROSS TE
STATE AND I LASTLY WANT TO SAY
THAT. I WILL NOT GIVE UP ON
ANYONE ESPECIALLY OUR YOUTH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
ALSO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA OR AYE ATKINS I FACE.
WELL FIVE FORGES NO BRADFORD I
CAN BY ADAM I CHIANG. DALLY NO
DODD. THERE ARE OTHER. I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
I HILL AYE HUESO HI TADO HI
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL
AYE MONNING. I MORE LOCK MORALE.
NO NIELSEN NO HAN AYE
PORTANTINO. HI ROSS RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AYE NUMBER
FIVE WHAT COUNTY AYE WIENER I
WILK HI CENTER MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM
FORTY FIVE SENATOR GONZALEZ
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL OPEN THIRTY BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ AND ACTUALLY
TO TELL TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
DONALD MEMBERS- I AM HERE TODAY
TO PRESENT SB ELEVEN THIRTY
WHICH IS A CRITICAL MEASURE TO
HELP CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
BOTH DURING AND AFTER THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC A LACK OF
ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED INTERNET
WAS AN ISSUE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
EVEN BEFORE THIS PANDEMIC TO
COLD AND CRY STATE LEADERS
EXAMPLES OF HOW THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. IS TWENTY CALIPHATE
TERMING IN CREDIT ACTED. I HAVE
FIVE KIDS AND A ROOM WITH AND
WE OLDER CALIFORNIANS. CAN NOT
HAVE ACCESS OR DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO RECEIVE TELEHEALTH
SERVICES. AND OTHER COUNTRIES A
HUB FOR TECHNOLOGY AND
INNOVATION THIS IS SIMPLY
UNACCEPTABLE AND WE MUST DO
BETTER. A LACK OF LONG TERM
INVESTMENT IN TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY READY BROADBAND
TECHNOLOGIES IT IS A KEY DRIVER
OF THE EXISTING DIGITAL DIVIDE.
AND AT ELEVEN THIRTY WILL BEGIN
TO THE INVESTMENT NEEDED TO
BUILD FUTURE PROOF CONNECTIVITY
TO EVERY HOME SCHOOL BUSINESS
EVERY PART OF. FORMULA THE BIG.
THIS BILL WILL REDEFINE THE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS FOR
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND. TO ENABLE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS THAT REPLACE OUTDATED
INTERNET SPEEDS AND UNSERVED
AREAS. THIS CHANGING CRITERIA
WILL ENABLE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
OF ALL SIZES TO APPLY FOR
GRANTS AND AT THE SAME TIME.
INVEST IN TWENTY FIRST CENTURY-
INFRASTRUCTURE CURRENTLY. THE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE ADVANCED SERVICES FUND ARE
TIED DIRECTLY TO LOW INTERNET
SPEEDS MAKING MOST INTERESTED
AND- WOULD LIKE TO DEPLOY A
FASTER SPEEDS IN ELIGIBLE FOR
THE GRANT FUNDS. TO NOTE
CURRENTLY MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
SITTING IN THE FUND THAT NEED
TO BE LEVERAGED. CERTAINLY ARE
THE P. YOU SEE I'M SORRY SB
ELEVEN THIRTY WILL ALLOW THE PC
TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO FINANCE
OPEN ACCESS HIGH SPEED
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS. THAT WOULD BRING
CALIFORNIA ON PAR WITH
INTERNATIONAL NORMS. AND I'D
ALSO LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT I
ACCEPTED ENERGY- COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
WORKING WITH THE ISSUE OF RULE
SERVER AREAS AND ENSURING THAT
THESE. ARE THIS FUND. SB THIRTY
PASSED OUT OF THE SENATE ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMIT
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND HAS
ALSO HAD THE SUPPORT OF A RURAL
AND URBAN COMMUNITIES LIKE RC
RC AND IS MEASURE IS ALSO A
LEGISLATURE LATINO CAUCUS PARTY
BUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
GONZALEZ MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE SENATOR DOLLY. THE
MATTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION IT'S NOT THAT I
DON'T TO. THE REALLY RESPECT
THE CLASS OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN- GOING TOE TO TOE HERE
BUT- IN IN I THINK WAS TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN OR SIXTEEN WE
GET THE BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE.
IN THE SIMPLY THAT ACTUALLY.
MADE THESE FUNDS AVAILABLE AND
DURING THE NEGOTIATIONS THE
LOCATION OF THAT- PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WE WERE TARGETING
AREAS THAT WERE NOT JUST
UNDERSERVED BUT NOT SERVED AT
ALL. AND SO THOSE FUNDS THERE'S
FIFTY I THINK FORTY FORTY FIVE
TO FIFTY APPLICATIONS AT THE P.
YOU SEE RIGHT NOW. ACCORDING TO
THOSE POSH THOSE FUNDS WILL BE
EXPANDED. TO DO EXACTLY WHAT WE
INTENDED TO DO THESE ARE CAST
OF FUNDS- EVERYBODY GETS A
LITTLE CHARGE ON THEIR ON THEIR
BILL AND THERE FOR UNDERSERVED
AREAS. THE BILL WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY WELL ACTUALLY IS A
WAY HIGHER SPEED IN THOSE AREAS
THAT- WE WERE FOCUSED ON SIXTY
SIXTY FIVE. I ONLY SAID I KNOW
THAT TO THE GROUP THAT PUT THAT
BILL TOGETHER SIXTEEN SIXTY
FIVE- IS CONVENING AGAIN THEY
REACH OUT TO ME I WILL BE
WORKING ON. ANOTHER PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WE ABSOLUTELY DO
NEED TO SERVE UNDERSERVED AREAS
BUT THERE IS A DON'T HAVE ANY
SERVICE AT ALL SHOULD BE THE
TARGET FIRST NOT GETTING HIGHER
SPEEDS FOR AREAS THAT ALREADY
HAVE. SERVICE AND YOU KNOW
THERE WAS A LOT OF TALK ABOUT.
INNER CITIES AND THE ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO- GET THOSE LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED FOLKS
IN THE INNER CITIES- SERVICE
BUT I WILL SHARE THIS WITH YOU
IF YOU GO. TO MANY PARTS OF THE
RULE PART OF CALIFORNIA. YOU
CAN'T GET SERVICE I CAN GO TO
ANY STARBUCKS OR ANY PLACE IN
THE INNER CITY AND GET ON THE
WIFI AND GET MORE SERVICE THAN
YOU GET THE RULE AREAS SO MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE IT'S RUNNING
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION WE
NEED TO EXPAND THE POT SO WE
CAN SERVE- ALL THOSE AREAS WE
SHOULD FIRST SERVE THE AREAS
THAT HAVE NO SERVICE ARE VERY
VERY LOW SERVICE- FOR EXAMPLE
WHERE I LIVE MY KIDS HAD TO
DRIVE SIX MILES TO TAKE AN AP
CLASS BECAUSE WE JUST DID NOT
HAVE SERVED OUR OWN. THERE
SHOULD VOTE FIRST I KNOW THIS
BILL IS GOING TO GET OUT TODAY.
AND I JUST WOULD ENCOURAGEYOU
WHEN IT COMES AROUND NEXT TIME
TO BE ENGAGED. TO EXPAND THOSE
FUNDS AND EXTEND THEM BECAUSE
THEY'RE GONNA BE OUT IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR FOR THOSE RESULT BE
OPPOSING THE BILL. I DON'T WANT
TO. TAKE AWAY FROM THE POT OF
MONEY THAT'S ALREADY EXISTING
THANK YOU MEMBERS. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALLEN SENATOR GORGEOUS.
I'D LIKE JUST TO CONFIRM- SOME
CONCERNS THAT MY CALLING JUST
MENTION I THINK BOB THIS PIECE
LEGISLATION HAS SIGNIFICANT
BENEFIT BUT MAYBE IN HE
AUTHORS CLOSING SHE COULD TALK
ABOUT MORE DETAIL. ON I BELIEVE
THE FREE THAT WAS USES THAT
THERE BE PRIORITY FOR RURAL
AREAS IN YOUR CLOSING IF YOU
CAN TALK ABOUT WHAT GUARANTEES
THERE ARE IT IS LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD. ALLOW FOR RURAL
AREAS TO BE PRIORITIZED OVER-
URBAN UNSERVED AREAS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER BORCHERS THING
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CENTER CONSOLES PLEASE CLOSE.
YES I JUST WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FROM A BEEPER AND
FROM- THE FRESNO AREA FOR
BRINGING UP THESE CONCERNS AND
WE CERTAINLY WHEN WE BROUGHT-
FOR THIS- ITEM WE WANTED TO
ENSURE THAT RURAL AND URBAN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. WE
WERE PRIOR THERE'S A COMMON
MISCONCEPTION THAT UP PARTS OF
LA COUNTY FOR INSTANCE WHAT I
REPRESENT ARE COMPLETELY
STRIPPED AND IT'S NOT TRUE.
THERE ARE AN INCORPORATED PARTS
OF LA COUNTY THAT ARE
COMPLETELY OFF THE GRID WITH NO
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THERE ARE
BROAD SUCH THAT. HE SO WE'RE
UNABLE FIELD I THINK- WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS AND IT
SHOULD THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
THAT THOSE AREAS UNSERVED WHAT
ARE YOU ARE AND URBAN LOS
ANGELES OR RURAL FRESNO AREA
THAT YOU BE PRIORITIZE. A
ANOTHER IS THAT WE SETTLE POST
JUST BECAUSE YOU HAVE. BUT IS
TWENTY FIVE THREE TWENTY FIVE I
UP DOWNLOAD THREE UPLOAD THAT'S
STILL NOT ENOUGH FOR KIDS AND
RIGHT NOW A LOT OF OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES HAVE SIX ONE WHICH
MAKES YOU ELIGIBLE FOR THE
FUNDS CURRENTLY AS IT STANDS.
THIS BUNDLE OF THIS BILL WILL
NOW A STATE THAT YOU WILL HAVE
AN ABILITY TO RE ENGAGE WITH
THE- AND ACTUALLY HAVE A SPEED
THAT WILL WORK FOR YOU
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THIS TIME. SEE
WHAT IT OPEN AT AND PROMOTES
COMPACT COMPETITIVE ALLOWS FOR
LOWER RATES IN SOME CASES AND
IT ALLOWS FOR A DEEP MONOPOLIES
A OF OUR- EXACT BUT WE- I.
LIKELY AFTER I'VE BUT I THINK
YOU FOR ENGAGING APPRECIATE IT
AND I LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
EVERYONE. THANK YOU CENTER
GONZALEZ MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
NO BELL FIVE FOR JESS NO
BRADFORD. CABALLERO I CHIANG
AYE DALLY NARROW DODD. I DRAWS
OWN AYE GALGIANI. I GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
I HELLO AYE HUESO. HI TADA I
JACKSON AYE JONES NO LEYVA FIVE
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S. NO
MITCHELL. I MONNING AYE WARLOCK
NO MORALE NO NIELSEN NO HAN
FIVE PORTANTINO. HI ROTH. RUBIO
I SKINNER. I STERN AYE NUMBER
NINE HI MY COUNTY I WIENER I
WILK. SEN REMOVES A CALL
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
FORTY SIX SENATOR CABALLERO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FORTINO NINE BY
SENATOR CABALLERO AND ACTUALLY
TO TAXATION CENTER CABALLERO
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TO PRESENT SB FOURTEEN OH
NINE. THE BILL THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD. STUDY IN ISSUE A PLAN TO
IMPLEMENT A PILOT PROGRAM
DESIGNED TO REMIT THE
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT FOR THE EITC TO ELIGIBLE
FAMILIES WITHOUT THE NEED TO
FILE A TAX RETURN. THE KELLY I.
T. C. IS ONE OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL ANTI POVERTY
PROGRAMS IN OUR STATE AND IT
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCES THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN WHO LIVE IN
POVERTY MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST ECONOMICALLY FRAGILE
HOUSEHOLDS. DO NOT CLAIM THAT
CAL E. R. T. C. BECAUSE THEY
EARN TOO LITTLE AND THEREFORE
DON'T FILE A TAX RETURN BECAUSE
THEY ARE ON AWARE THEY QUALIFY
FOR THE CREDIT. FOR THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TAX YEAR F.
B. ESTIMATED ONE POINT TWO FIVE
MILLION ELIGIBLE TAXPAYERS. ALL
OF YOUR TAXPAYERS WOULD NOT
PLAY IN THE CAL E. I. T. E. AND-
THE VET. FILE TAX. THE BILL
WOULD ABOUT PROBLEM. WILL HAVE
NO OP AND I RISK ASK FOR YOUR
AYE BOAT. THANK YOU CENTER
CABALLERO MEMBERS DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
I ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS. AYE
BATES. AYE BELL I FORGES AYE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE CABRERA
I CHIANG I DALLY. DODD HI THERE
I WASN'T HI GALGIANI. I GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. I
HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO. HI
TADO HI JACKSON I JONES. I
LEYVA I WIRE AYE MELENDEZ AYE
MITCHELL. I MONEY. I MORE LOCK
MORRELL. NIELSEN I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AYE NUMBER I
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER AYE
WILK. CENTER MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM FORTY EIGHT SENATOR HUESO
MEN SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR HUESO AN ACT
RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION
CENTER HUESO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND SENATORS
INNOVATION CREATES JOBS AND
OPPORTUNITY AND SOLVES PROBLEMS
THAT'S WHY CALIFORNIA'S THE IN
ON INNOVATION STATE LEADS THE
NATION IN JOB CREATION THIS
BILL- SB TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT IS
A USES ANINNOVATIVE STRATEGY.
TO MITIGATE THE STATE'S ON
RECYCLED PLASTIC SURPLUS BY
ASKING THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION TO CONDUCT THE
SUCH A STUDY ASSOCIATE
VISIBILITY COST EFFECTIVENESS
AND- LIFECYCLE ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS. INCLUDE RECYCLE
PLASTICS AN ASPHALT PRODUCTION
FOR ROAD CNSTRUCTION AND
REPAIR PROJECTS A SENATORS THIS
PROJECT WAS PROPOSED BY A GROUP
OF STUDENTS IN MY DISTRICT FROM
THE BUT NEED OF THIS THE GREEN
TICK GRAY TO. BUT NATIVIST IS
COOL THE HOME OF THE PROUD
BEHRENS IN TWENTY ELEVEN AS
LEGISLATURE. WE ESTABLISHED A
STEAK WIDE GOAL OF 75%
RECYCLING BY TWENTY TWENTY BUT
WE ARE IN TWENTY TWENTY VERY
FAR FROM THAT GOAL IN ORDER TO
MEET THE GOALS WE SET FOR
OURSELVES WE FIND WE MUST FIND
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS PRESS ONE
OF OUR STATE'S MOST PRESSING
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES.
RESEARCHERS FROM AROUND THE
WORLD HAVE BEEN DEVELOPING NEW
USES FOR RECYCLED PLASTICS AND
IN THE LAST DECADE WE HAVE BEEN
THE HEAD OF USING MICHAEL
PLASTIC IN AN **** ADDED. INTO
TWELVE CANADA REPORTED THAT
THEY WOULD INCORPORATING THE
USE OF BLUE BLACK PLASTIC IS AN
**** WELL ADDITIVE FOR ROAD.
TWENTY FIFTEEN ROTTERDAM
ANSWERED A NEVER ENDS BUT NOW
THEY'RE. TO FOR A FACTOR
PRODUCED FOR A FACT PRODUCED
RECYCLE PLASTIC THE THAT'S IN
SEGMENTS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ROAD CONSTRUCTION MORE RECENTLY.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE YEAR TO
THE CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY PARTNERED
WITH THE PLASTIC ROAD DEVELOPER
TO ENGINEERS. THE FIRST KNOWN
ROAD OF THE UNITED STATES USING
RECYCLED PLASTIC IN ITS ASPHALT
THIS BILL WOULD ASK CALTRANS TO
WORK TO DEVELOP THIS PROGRAM IF
FEASIBLE. AND THIS IS A GREAT
BILL THAT WILL CREATE JOBS IN
OUR STATE HELP TO RECYCLE
PLASTIC AND HELP REDUCE IMPROVE
THE INTEGRITY INTEGRITY OF OUR
ROADWAYS AND I ASK FOR YOUR
BOOK. YOUR AVAILABLE FOR THIS
IS LET'S XIN. YES MEMBER
DISCUSSION A DEBATE. SEE
HEARING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
CALL THE- ALLEN I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BELL I
BARGES AYE BRADFORD I HAVE A
ADAM I CHIANG. I DALLY WILL. I
DODD I RISING. I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROW. I
HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO. I
TANTO. HI JACKSON I JONES I
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ
AYE MITCHELL. I MONEY. I MORE
LOCK I RURAL. I NIELSEN HI PAM
I PORTANTINO I ROTH. RUBIO I
SKINNER. STERN I NUMBER NINE HI
MY CASKEY I WIENER AYE WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ROTH SKINNER WILK. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MAJOR PASSES
MEMBERS STAND TIGHT FOR A
MOMENT AND WE ARE GOING TO LIFT
CALLS ON A FEW BILLS.
MEMBERS
WE ARE READY TO LIVE CALLS
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM TWENTY SIX.
OKAY MEMBERS
WELCOME BACK SENATOR ROTH FILE
ITEM TWENTY SIX SENATOR ALLEN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS I
BRADFORD. GROWTH I JONES. MORE
LOCK. NIELSEN STERN. I WIENER.
HI NIELSEN I. BRADFORD I'D BY
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES MOVING TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN SENATOR SKINNER
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS I FORGES.
GROWTH NO MORE LOCK I WIENER. I
WILK. PRICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS
NINE THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
TO FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT WHICH
IS CENTER SCANNERS- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES GLAZER
AYE WIENER I. BATES NOW. FIVE
THIRTY KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT SENATOR HUESO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN I FELL. I
VALLEY. THERE ARE OTHER. I
JONES. MORRELL ROTH HI. FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM THIRTY
NINE STERN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN HI ATKINS
I FORGES. DALLY NO GROWTH NO
MORE LOCK. FOR JUST NO MORE
LOCK. ROTH HI. EYES THIRTY TWO
NO SEVENTH THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY
SENATOR HER TITLE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ATKINS HI. HI GUYS
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING TO FILE ITEM
FORTY ONE STERN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS FIVE
DALLY. GROWTH JONES NO NIELSEN.
ROTH HI BY THIRTY TWO KNOWS
FIVE THE EASURE PASSES BY LINE
FORTY TWO HER TITLE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS I
BATES NO FOR JUST. ROTH. FIVE
FIVE THIRTY THREE NO SIX THE
MAJOR KERRY'S FILE ITEM FORTY
FOUR DERON SO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES. CHIANG
NO DODD. MORE LOCK I ROTH HI.
SIZE THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON THE
FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE GONZALEZ
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD HI ROTH I WILK. FIVE
THIRTY KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM FORTY SIX
CABALLERO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLY MORE LOCK.
MORALE. ROTH AYE WILK. FIVE
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS THAT IN OUR LIST
OF BILLS ON CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE DID A GREAT JOB- TODAY
SENATOR NIELSEN FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU RISE. THE
CONDITION THE FILE THIRD IN
HERE THEN YOU HAVE SERVICE
LEGISLATURE WITH THE STING SET
DISTINCTION BEGINNING IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE YOU HAVE
BEEN A SYMBOL OF DEDICATION TO
PUBLIC SERVICE AND THE NEEDS OF
YOUR CONSTITUENTS CONSTITUENCY.
EVEN IF I CAN'T SAY THE WORD WE
STILL BELIEVE IT. MANY OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES SEE YOU AS THE DEAN
OF THE SENATE AND WE APPLAUD
YOUR LEGISLATIVE CAREER AS A
MEMBER AND A LEADER OF THIS
LEGISLATURE SO PLEASE UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
PROCEED. WELL. TWENTY WELL
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN CENTER MY
PURPOSE TO GET UP WHICH TO-
DOES TO EACH AND ALL OF YOU.
OVER THE YEARS OF BEEN ABLE TO
BE IN THE PRESENCE IS A VERY
WONDERFUL INDIVIDUALS VERY
ELOQUENT SPEAKERS AND PROBLEM
SOLVERS ACHIEVERS. EVERY TIME
AFTER I CAME BACK HERE AFTER
EIGHTEEN YEARS ABSENT. THEY
WOULD ASK ME JIM WHAT'S
DIFFERENT NOW SAID WELL.
RESPECT FOR EACH OTHER AND
RESPECT FOR THE INSTITUTION
HAVE DIMINISHED AND THEY HAVE
OVER THE YEARS. BUT THAT IS NOT
MY POINT TO THE CONTRARY. IT IT
TYPICALLY HAS STRUCK ME IN THE
LAST FEW DAYS HERE. THE QUALITY
OF THE DEBATE IN THE
COMPARTMENT OF EACH AND EVERY
MEMBER OF THE SENATE AND ALMOST
WELL I THINK EVERYONE OF YOU
HAVE BEEN UP SPEAKING. IT IS
REALLY IMPRESSIVE. IN A CAN TO
THE BEST OF TIMES THAT I EVER
HAVE WITNESSED HERE. SO MY
WHOLE PURPOSE ON THIS MOMENT OF
TWO ON THE CONDITION THE FILE
IS TO COMMENDED COMPLIMENT YOU.
OBVIOUSLY ARE STAFF TO THEY ARE
ALWAYS WONDERFUL BUT HOW YOU
COMPORT YOURSELVES YOUR COMMAND
OF THE- YOU RAISED PRESS. JUICE
THE FACT THAT YOU SHOW. IS
STILL VERY IMPRESSIVE. AND TO
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE DETRACTORS
OF THIS INSTITUTION I WOULD
SUBMIT THAT TO THEM TUNE IN
SOMETIME AND WATCH WHAT WE DO
HERE THEN HOW HARD ALL OF THIS
WORK MY THANKS AND
COMMENDATIONS ARE TO EACH OF
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN.
UNDER GROVE. PRESIDENT BY TWO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK A FEW
MOMENTS JUST ON PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR YOU KNOW I LOOK AT
THE WE ALL CAME INTO OFFICE THE
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN-
HERE AND SOME OF YOU WERE HERE
BUT WE STARTED THIS SESSION
INTO EIGHTEEN IN LAST- WHEN WE
FINISH THE LAST FEW DAYS OF
CYCLE IT WAS THE MOST FUN TIME
ALRIGHT RIGHT REMEMBER. YEAH
THIS CHAIN INTO A SMALL LITTLE
ROOM AND SITTING ON OUR CHAIRS
WITH ALL OF OUR DOCUMENTS IN
FRONT OF US AND- THE DESK STAFF
AND ERICA DID SUCH AN
OUTSTANDING JOB. IN IN THIS
YEAR WE THOUGHT TWENTY TWENTY
WILL START OFF IN THE MUCH
BETTER THAN THE PREVIOUS YEAR.
AND WE ENDED UP WITH CALVIN
BEING GONE FOR ALMOST THREE
MONTHS AND BE AWAY FROM THE
CAPITAL. AND COMING BACK TO.
WHERE WE HAVE TO OPERATE A
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENT AND-
ERICA HAS DONE AN OUTSTANDING
JOB. TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
STAFF AND- ALL OF US ARE SAFE.
I SOMETIMES THINK SHE'S GONE
OVERBOARD AND I VOICE MY
CONCERN WITH THAT. BUT SHE
STILL HOLD THEIR GROUND IN AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE ALL FOLLOW
THE RULES AND EVERYBODY'S SAFE.
AND BERNIE AT THE DESK JUST AN
OUTSTANDING INDIVIDUAL WHO MAKE
SURE THE HOUSE RUNS. VERY
SMOOTHLY THE- FLOOR EARLY
MAJORITY FLOOR LEADER AT THE
WIND HE COMES UP AND WE COME UP
WITH SOME CRAZY IDEAS ON HOW WE
CAN MOVE THINGS ALONG AND MAKE
THINGS A LITTLE BETTER AND- IN
BERNIE JUST LOOKS AT US AND
ROLES ARE. SOMETIMES BUT SHE
ALWAYS MANAGES TO MAKE SURE IT
WORKS. WE CAN EXPEDITE AS
THINGS THAT HAPPEN ON THE
FLOOR. AND SO I JUST THINK THAT
LEADERSHIP IN THE STAFF AND-
WHEN I THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW
EVEN OUR BUDGET CHAIR WHO IS
LIKE SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES SAID
VERY VERY GOOD. AND KNOW HOW TO
KEEP SHE KEEPS IT ALL STRAIGHT.
A BILL AFTER BILL AFTER BILL
BUT SHE DOES. AND THE SENATE
PRO TEM. AND YOU LOOK AT OUR
SENATE PROTEIN LIKE I SAID MANY
TIMES THAT IF YOU WALK DOWN
THIS HALLWAY BEHIND ME. THERE'S
ALL THESE MEN THAT HAVE BEEN IN
THAT POSITION AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN YOU SEE LAST PHOTO IT.
IN THE IN THE ROW IS A WOMAN.
SO AS I APPLIED ERICA BERNIE
MYSELF ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE.
THE BUDGET CHAIR IN THE STATE
PRO. I REALLY BELIEVE THAT WE
ARE. NO TH. GUYS BUT THIS
HOUSES OP. VERY SMOOTHLY AND IN
A DIFFERENT WAY BECAUSE WOMEN.
ARE IN CHARGE AND. I WANT TO
SEE- MY REPUBLICAN STAFF YOU
KNOW OF A- COUNTRY TO BEING IN
THE MAJORITY PARTY REPUBLICAN
SEEM TO GET INFORMATION ON THE
BUDGET EITHER FROM LOBBYIST OR
THE MEDIA. THAT'S OUR SENSE OF
RESOURCE TO BE ABLE TO GET
INFORMATION ON MY STAFF HAS
DONE AN OUTSTANDING JOB TO
GARNER THAT INFORMATION AND
THEN WE ACTUALLY DO GET THE
LANGUAGE AT THE LAST MINUTE
THEY ARE ABLE TO PUT THOSE
THINGS TOGETHER. AND US AS
MEMBERS. THE BEST ANALYSIS
POSSIBLE ON THE INFORMATION
THAT'S PROVIDED TO THEM AND
THEY DO AN OUTSTANDING JOB A
GREAT MOM BEHIND ME WORKS SO
WELL LIBERTY ON THE FLOOR ON
MAKING SURE THAT THEY WORK
TOGETHER ON ON ISSUES AND
BERNICE JUST OUTSTANDING
WORKING WITH MY- HALF AND I
JUST. APPRECIATE MIGHT INDICATE
THAT WE HAVE EVERY DAY BEFORE
THE FLOOR WITH THE MAJORITY
FLOOR LEADER AND HIS STAFF
GIVING THE INFORMATION NEDS SO.
WITH I KNOW. TO GO OVER THIS.
ELIMINATE BILLS. AT THE LIMITED
TIME TO GO. BILLS THAT MY
CAUCUS FOCUS ON CHEN ONE ARE
GOING TO BECOME A AT IN THE
FOCUS ON OTHERS AS COME UP
LATER. SO I APPLAUD THAT
COOPERATE WITH YOU SIR AND I
REALLY DO A- IT. MY AT MY CALL
YOU FRIEND YOU KNOW WE CAME IN
THE ASSEMBLY TOGETHER. I HAVE
TO TELL YOU CONFESS RIGHT SO
SHE SENDS ME THIS BEAUTIFUL
LETTER AND SHE GOES WOW TEN
YEARS AGO WE CAME IN THE
BUILDING AND- IT WAS THE
SWEETEST KINDEST LETTER AND I
TO START BAWLING MY GOD I'VE
BEEN HERE FOR A DECADE. AND SO
I WAS JUST THINKING ABOUT THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE HAD IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE TO. OVER HERE
IN. SENATE INSTEAD IS. THE SAME
SIDE I ALL THE LEADERS ROLE IN
IN THE ASSEMBLY SO. BUT COMING
UP HERE AND WITH MY COLLEAGUES
SENATE TEN IN A- POSITION YOU
AYE BAR FAR. EVEN THOUGH WE
DON'T AGREE ON ISSUES ONE OF
THOSE. PRESS FOR. PEOPLE IN
THIS BILL. AND I THINK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING MY PARTNER IN
CRIME ON THIS LEADERSHIP TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVEN THOUGH. WE
DISAGREE ON ISSUES. THAT YOU
PROVIDE FAIRNESS AND EQUALITY.
SO THAT MY COLLEAGUES HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY- IN MY CAUCUS HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY BILL TO SPEAK
THEIR MIND AND ISSUES THAT THEY
AGREE AND DISAGREE WITH. AND I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND AT. AND I GOT BLESS YOU MY
FRIEND. CENTER GROVE. MADAM
FROM HIM THANK YOU SO MUCH-
MADAM PRESIDENT AND INTO MY-
COLLEAGUE AND FRIEND FROM
BAKERSFIELD SHE KNOWS I'M
PARTIAL T BAKERSFIELD- IT
REMINDS ME OF HOME. I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP I THINK WE'VE HAD
SOME MOMENTS ON THE FLOOR AND I
WAS THINKING AS THE D. OF OUR
IN. OUR COLLEAGUE FROM TO HE
MISSPOKE AND LISTEN TO HIS
ELOQUENT WORDS I THINK YOU KNOW
WE ASPIRE TO THOSE WORDS
SENATOR. THERE ARE MOMENTS WE
DON'T ALWAYS. BUT YOU KNOW BUT
SHE THAT BUT WE CERTAINLY A
SPIRE AND I THINK AS WE FINISH
TODAY. HERE IN TE COMMENTS OF
FOR MY COLLEAGUES. IT MAY IT'S
A REMINDER TO ME THAT WE CAN
HAVE A TENSE MOMENT ARE TOO BUT
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO. AS A SENATE
FAMILY IS FIGURE OUT HOW TO
COME BACK TOGETHER ND MOVE
BEYOND THOSE MOMENTS BECAUSE-
IF WE WEREN'T PASSIONATE ABOUT
THE WORK THAT WE DO. THAT WE
SHOULDN'T BE HERE WE SHOULDN'T
BE HERE REPRESENTING OUR
DIVERSE OUR CONSTITUENTS FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO. I APPLAUD THE
DEAN OF OUR SENATE I APPLAUD
OUR REPUBLICAN LEADER- AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INSPIRATIONAL WORDS AND YOUR
ELOQUENCE. I THINK THIS WEEK-
AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS.
MADAM REPUBLICAN LEADER THAT
YOU ACKNOWLEDGE YOU ARE SO
RIGHT. OUT WE ARE BLESSED TO
HAVE TALENT BEYOND BELIEF
PEOPLE WHO WILL WORK UNTIL ONE
IN THE MORNING AND THEN COME
BACK. AT NINE AM THE NEXT DAY
READY TO GO AND DO THE WORK
THAT THEY NEED TO DO. TO THE
SERGEANTS IN THE SECURITY. WE
HAVE RISEN TO THE OCCASION THEY
HAVE RISEN TO THE OCCASION TO
SUPPORT AND PROTECT US. IN WAYS
THAT NO ONE COULD HAVE IMAGINED
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE END OF
SESSION. I AM INCREDIBLY PROUD
OF US AS A BODY AND THE STAFF
AND THE WORK THAT WE DO. TO
TAKE CARE OF EACH OTHER EVEN AS
WE MAY DISAGREE OR HAVE
DIFFERENCES. ARE PUT OUR WORK
THROUGH DIFFERENT LENSES FROM
OUR OWN PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE-
OUR STAFF WORKED VERY WELL
TOGETHER ACROSS THE AISLE THEY
DO- AND THEY RESPOND TO US AND
THEY DO THEIR JOBS. I ALSO
WANTED KNOWLEDGE MY VICE CHAIR
RULES WHO ARE OUR RULES
COMMITTEE WORKS VERY HARD
WE'VE- ADJUSTED AND GOTTEN USED
TO. A WORKPLACE CONDUCT UNIT TO
HELP CHANGE THE CULTURE IN OUR
SENATE FAMILY AN INSTITUTION.
AND I'M JUST A PRIVILEGED AND
HONOR TO WORK WITH THE MEMBERS
OF THE RULES COMMITTEE IN MY
VICE CHAIR. SO ARE WEEK IS THAT
INCLUDED. IT'S INCLUDED
OBVIOUSLY ROBUST DISCUSSION AND
AGAIN AS IT SHOULD BE GIVEN OUR
DIVERSE CONSTITUENTS. AND THEIR
PERSPECTIVES. ARE BUDGET WORK
IS CONCLUDED AND I FOR ONE.
FEEL PRETTY PROUD EVEN IF THERE
ARE FOLKS WHO DISAGREE WITH
VARIOUS COMPONENTS DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS ALIKE. OF WHAT
WE'VE DONE IN PIECES OF THIS
BUDGET. AS A WHOLE WE SHOULD BE
PROUD BECAUSE- OF WE LIVE HERE
WITH RESTORE. INTO RESERVE. AND
I COMMIT TO KEEP THOSE AND- WE
MOVE IN THE HERE WE'VE OUR
HOUSE OF OR DEAD. AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY HOW ARE. PLEASED
AND PROUD AND THANKFUL I AM.
THAT MEMBERS REALLY HONE DOWN
THERE BILL PACKAGES I MEAN
THAT'S A THAT'S A HARD THING TO
ASK LEGISLATORS TO DO. ARE YOU
DID THAT KEEPING IN MIND THE
CODED NINETEEN THE LENS THE
ECONOMIC SITUATION THAT WE ARE
IN. AND YOU REALLY ROSE TO THE
OCCASION IN LINE WITH THE
MOMENTIN TIME THAT WE ARE IN
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO LET YOU KNOW. THAT WE
CAN YOU TO DO THAT WORK AND
WE'RE GONNA REPRESENT AND
SUPPORT- ARE SENATE- COLLEAGUES
AS OUR BILLS MOVE OVER AND WE
CONTINUE TO DO OUR WORK. GOING
TO CONTINUE TO BE PART OF THAT
WE GET SOME GOOD PIECES OF
LEGISLATION DONE FROM THE
REPUBLICANS DEMOCRATS AS WE
MOVE INTO THE OTHER HALF I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU I HOPE YOU MAKE
IT HOME. I KNOW. WHAT DO. A I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- BEING HERE
FRIDAY TO GET OUR WORK DONE
BUDGET AND HOUSE OF ORIGIN
DEADLINE BE SAFE. I BE HAPPY
WITH THE I WE WILL. I WILL SEE
YOU AGAIN ON MONDAY JUNE TWENTY
NINE. TWENTY TWENTY AT TWO PM
MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU
pFURTHER BUSINESS THE DESK IS
CLEAR THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE PLACED WE WILL
RECONVENE ON MONDAY AT TWO PM
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND EVERYONE.